AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY ENTER
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND T
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS IN THE CAPITAL WITH
SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY WE
EXPECT TO HAVE ABOUT EIGHT
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
SENATOR KABBADI AT ALL SENATOR
DODD SENATOR JACKSON SENATOR
JONES WILL JOIN US LATER
SENATOR MCGUIRE SENATOR- BURKE
SENATOR WIENER SENATOR DICK
GRASSO WHO IS THE VICE CHAIR OF
THE LATINO CAUCUS. AND IN THE
SENATE CHAMBER WITH ME ARE
SENATOR RICHARD PAN WHO IS A
MEMBER OF HIS COMMITTEE OF THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE AND SENATE.
SORRY THE SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS SENATOR
HOLLY MITCHELL WHO CHAIRS THE
SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE AND THE SPECIAL
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE UNCOVERED
NINETEEN RESPONSE. WE ALSO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE NEWS
AND ADMINISTRATION AND FROM THE
ESSENTIAL WORK FORCE COMMUNITY
CORPORATISM PAINTING REMOTELY
AS WELL. FOR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. AND ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZE IT USE THE RAISE YOUR
HAND FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM.
EACH TIME THAT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND MUTE
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT. YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND
THEN YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. AGAIN THANKS TO
OUR SENATE STAFF WHO'S WORKING
FOR US TO SEE BEHIND THE SCENES
AS WELL TO GET THIS STARTED SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THEIR
HARD WORK. AND TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO.
UP TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PRESENT
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL NOW SIT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN SIX TWO. ONE TWO
SEVEN NINE THAT IS SEVEN SIX
TWO. ONE TWO SEVEN NINE FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES DIM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WE WILL WE WILL
BE HEARING FROM BOTH PANELS OF
WITNESSES ON THE AGENDA PRIOR
TO TAKING PUBLIC COMMENT. ONCE
WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL THE
WITNESSES ON THE AGENDA WILL
HAVE A SPECIFIC. PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
COMMENT ON THE TOPICS OF
TODAY'S AGENDA. PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING. THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTED MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS NEEDED. WELL EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AND
IT'S CLOSE. TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
WERE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE
OF ONLINE TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
WELL GOD AFTERNOON SENATOR
LENA GONZALEZ IS AS CHAIR OF
THE SPAT SPECIAL COMMITTEE ON
PANDEMIC EMERGENCY RESPONSE I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK. AND
WELCOME EVERYONE WHO IS
PARTICIPATING TODAY. IN A
SERIES OF OVERSIGHT HEARINGS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING THIS
FALL. OUR COMMITTEE HELD
HEARINGS EARLIER IN THE YEAR
ABOUT TESTING AND CONTACT
TRACING OUTBREAKS IN SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES. AND ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF COVERT NINETEEN
AT THE BORDER REGION. WE'VE
BEEN VERY BUSY. NOW THAT WE ARE
SEVEN MONTHS INTO OUR PANDEMIC
RESPONSE WE ARE HOLDING
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS TO EXAMINE
HOW THE ADMINISTRATION IS
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE MOST
CRITICAL NEEDS. EVERY MANY NOT
THAT REMAIN IN OUR EFFORTS TO
CONTAIN COBEN NINETEEN AND SAVE
LIVES. TODAY'S HEARING IS ABOUT
WORKPLACE HEALTH AND SAFETY
DURING THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. WE WILL BE HEARING
FROM KEY LEADERS AND THE
NEWSMEN MINISTRATION ABOUT WHAT
IS BEING DONE TO PREVENT FUTURE
OUTBREAKS. PARTICULARLY IN OUR
WORKPLACES. WE WILL BE ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT HAS BEEN
LEARNED FROM SOME OF THE
TRAGEDIES THAT UNFORTUNATELY
HAVE BEEN. TAKEN AT WORK SITES
AROUND THE STATE WHAT IS BEING
DONE 2% PROTECT ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. AND HOW RECENT CHANGES
IN THE LAW PASSED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE. AND SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR WILL EXPAND WORKER
PROTECTIONS AND BETTER ENABLE
THE STATE TO TAKE SWIFT ACTION
TO PREVENT A SMALL OUTBREAK.
FROM BECOMING A LARGER
OUTBREAK. THAT INFECTS HUNDREDS
OF WORKERS IN OUR STATE. THE
WORKPLACE TRAGEDIES THAT HAVE
COST LIVES ARE ALL MORE TRAGIC
WHEN WE- WHEN MORE COULD HAVE
BEEN DONE TO PREVENT THE SPREAD
OF CLOVER NINETEEN AND SOME OF
THESE WORKPLACES. AND CERTAIN
EMPLOYMENT SECTORS AND SPECIFIC
COMPANIES HAVE EXPERIENCED
LARGE OUTBREAKS THAT HAVE
IMPACTED HUNDREDS OF WORKERS.
FOR WHOM THE LONG TERM HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES OF CONTRACTING
COVE IN NINETEEN. OUR AS YET
NOT FULLY KNOWN. WE WILL BE
HEARING TODAY FROM WORKERS IN
THE REPRESENTATIVES FROM MANY
OF THE INDUSTRIES WHOSE WORKERS
HAVE SUFFERED A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF THE
HEALTH CONSEQUENCES OF
CONTRACTING. COVERT NINETEEN.
MEAT PACKING. HEALTH CARE
WORKERS BOTH FROM SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AND
HOSPITALS. FORMER OCCURS
GROCERY WORKERS DEPARTMENT AND
WAREHOUSE WORKERS AND AGAIN I
THINK EACH AND EVERYONE OF THEM
FOR JOINING US TODAY. BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH OUR SPEAKERS I'D
LIKE AGAIN TO INVITE THE PUBLIC
WOULD LIKE TO PARTICIPATE TO
CALL IN NOW. AGAIN THE TOLL
TOLL FREE NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE
SIX FOUR WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE
USE THE ACCESS CODE. SEVEN SIX
TWO ONE TWO SEVEN NINE. SO WE
WILL COMMENCE WITH PANEL NUMBER
ONE FOR EACH PANELIST WILL BE
GIVEN FIVE MINUTES EACH- I WANT
TO WELCOME FROM OUR FIRST
PRESENTER KATIE HAGEN. THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS WELCOME
MISTAKEN YOU MAY PRESENT. THANK
YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME OK YES WE
CAN. GREAT THANK YOU RKD HAGEN
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS A GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS. AND HOW WE'VE BEEN
DOING ADD TO KEEP WORKPLACES
SAFE AMIDST THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THE MISSION OF OUR
DEPARTMENT IS TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF CALIFORNIA
WORKERS AND ENSURE EMPLOYERS
COMPLY WITH LABOR REGULATIONS.
THE SUDDEN EMERGENCE AND SPREAD
OF KOBE NINETEEN IN OUR STATE
HAS LED TO UNPARALLELED
CHALLENGES AND FURTHER
DEMONSTRATED THE MORAL
IMPERATIVE OF PROTECTING OUR
WORKFORCE. ESPECIALLY THE MOST
VULNERABLE. WE OWE A GREAT DEAL
OF RESPECT AND GRATITUDE TO OUR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHETHER THEY
ARE SUPPLYING THE FRUIT
VEGETABLES THAT ARE GROCERY
STORES SEARCH STOCKING SHELVES.
FIGHTING WILDFIRES WORKING IN
AN E. WIRD MINISTERING COVED
NINETEEN TESTS THEY ALL DESERVE
THE PEACE OF MIND THAT THEY ARE
NOT PUTTING THEMSELVES OR THEIR
LOVED ONE IN HARM'S WAY JUST BY
GOING TO WORK. I WAS APPOINTED
DIRECTOR OF THIS DEPARTMENT SIX
MONTHS AGO JUST A FEW DAYS
AFTER THE STAY AT HOME ORDER.
SINCE THEN OUR DEPARTMENT HAS
BEEN RAMPING UP ENFORCEMENT AND
OUTREACH EFFORTS TO MEET THE
SURGEON REQUESTS FOR WORKPLACE
GUIDANCE AND THE NEED FOR
INSPECTION. TODAY WILL BE
FOCUSING ON THE EFFORTS BY THE
DIVISION OF OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH ALSO KNOWN AS CAL
OSHA LED BY CHIEF DOUG PARKER.
AS A WORKPLACE SAFETY IS THEIR
PRIMARY JURISDICTION. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO TAKE THIS MOMENT
TO THANK CHIEF PARKER AND A
REMARKABLE STAFF AT CAL OSHA
AND DIR. IT IS OUR PRIORITY TO
KEEP OUR STAFF'S FAITH AS WE DO
THIS WORK AND I CONTINUE TO BE
INSPIRED BY THEIR WILLINGNESS
TO STEP UP DURING THIS VERY
CHALLENGING TIME AND MAKE IT
POSSIBLE EACH DAY FOR US TO
SELL OUR MISSION AS A
DEPARTMENT. TO BEGIN I'D LIKE
TO BRIEFLY EXPLAIN THE
FUNCTIONS OF THE DIVISION OF
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH.
IN ADDITION TO PROTECTING THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF WORKERS
HELLO SHE IS ALSO RESPONSIBLE
FOR ENSURING THE SAFETY OF
PASSENGERS. RIDING ON ELEVATORS
AMUSEMENT RIDES AND TRAMWAYS.
HELLO SHOULD DOES THIS WORK BY
SETTING AND ENFORCING HEALTH
AND SAFETY STANDARDS. PROVIDING
OUTREACH EDUCATION AND
ASSISTANCE ISSUING PERMITS
LICENSES CERTIFICATION
REGISTRATIONS AND APPROVALS.
HELLO SIR ENFORCEMENT BRANCH IS
TASKED WITH CONDUCTING
INSPECTIONS IN RESPONSE TO
COMPLAINTS AND REFERRALS
ALLEGING HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS
SUCH AS EXPOSURE TO HAZARDOUS
CHEMICALS OR UNSAFE MACHINERY.
INSPECTIONS CAN ALSO BE
CONDUCTED IN RESPONSE TO A
WORKER'S INJURY ILLNESS OR
FATALITY. INSPECTIONS ARE
CARRIED OUT BY CAL OSHA
INSPECTOR SECTORS FROM ONE OF
OUR SEVENTEEN ENFORCEMENT
DISTRICT OFFICES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. HELLO SHOULD
INSPECTORS VISIT WORK SITES
CONDUCT INTERVIEWS AND REVIEW
EMPLOYER RECORDS TO IDENTIFY
POTENTIAL HAZARDS AND ARE
EXPECTED TO GATHER AND DOCUMENT
SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE TO SUSTAIN
A CITATION IN AN ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARING. IF VIOLATIONS ARE
FOUND HELLO SHOULD ISSUE
CITATIONS WHICH IN MOST CASES
CARRY ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES
BOTH THE DIVISION WORKS WITH
EMPLOYERS TO TAKE CORRECTIVE
ACTION AND THE BAIT ANY HAZARDS.
HELLO CHAU ALSO PROACTIVELY
WORKS WITH EMPLOYERS TO PREVENT
WORKPLACE. INJURIES HELLO CHAU
CONSULTATION SERVICES BRANCH
PROVIDES FREE CONSULTATION
ASSISTANCE TO ADVISE EMPLOYERS
ON BEST PRACTICES IN ACCORDANCE
WITH HEALTH AND SAFETY
REGULATIONS. IN ADDITION TO
THIS ENFORCEMENT IN
CONSULTATION WORK A LARGE PART
OF CAL OSHA DUTIES INVOLVED
INFORMING WORKERS OF THEIR
RIGHTS AND PROTECTIONS UNDER
CALIFORNIA LABOR LAW. IN OUR
MASS MAILERS REQUIRED SIGN
POSTINGS AND PRESS RELEASES WE
REMIND WORKERS OF THEIR
ENTITLEMENT TO REPORT WORKPLACE
HAZARDS TO TAKE TIME OFF SHOULD
THEY OR A FAMILY MEMBER BECOME
ILL. AND NOT BE RETALIATED
AGAINST BY THEIR EMPLOYER. AS
YOU ALL KNOW AS A RESULT OF THE
COLBERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC CAL
OSHA HAS RECEIVED A RECORD
AMOUNT OF COMPLAINTS. REQUIRING
THE DIVISION TO QUICKLY AND
STRATEGICALLY RE DIRECT STAFF
AND RESOURCES TO MEET THIS
GROWING NEED. TO INCREASE
ENFORCEMENT OUTREACH AND
CONSULTATION EFFORTS HELLO CHAU
HAS TEMPORARILY REDIRECTED
FORMER STATE STAFF BACK TO THE
DIVISION TO HELP WITH HIRING
EFFORTS. AND INTERNAL STAFF
FROM THE AMUSEMENT RIDES AND
FAMILY UNITS TO ASSIST IN
CORBETT NINETEEN ENFORCEMENT.
THE DIVISION HAS ALSO REACHED
OUT DIRECTLY TO RETIRED SAFETY
ENGINEERS AND INDUSTRIAL
HYGIENISTS TO ASSIST WITH
ENFORCEMENT. HELLO SIR IS
ENGAGED IN A NATIONWIDE
RECRUITMENT EFFORT FOR SAFETY
ENGINEERS AND INDUSTRIAL
HYGIENISTS. OUR CURRENT GOAL IS
TO FILL SIXTY FIVE ENFORCEMENT
POSITIONS BY THE END OF THIS
CALENDAR YEAR. BY SPRING TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OUR GOAL IS TO FILL
OUR REMAINING VACANCIES SEVENTY
IN CAL OSHA- AND OUR DIVISION
IS ON TARGET TO MEET ITS END OF
YEAR ENFORCEMENT GOAL WHILE
ALSO MAKING PROGRESS ON HE
HIRES OUTSIDE OF THE
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM. THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR NEW
SOME FOR BOLSTERING THESE
EFFORTS BY ALLOCATING
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO CALLOW
SHACK AND D. I. R. IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. SUCH
SUPPORT HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
TO BUILD THE CAPACITY NEEDED TO
CONTINUE OUR WORK. LASTLY HELLO
SHOULD WAS PROACTIVELY ENGAGED
AND CONTINUES TO BE- AND
COLLABORATES WITH STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES ARE TARGETED
EFFORTS TO REDUCE CARBON
NINETEEN TRANSMISSION AND
PROTECT WORKERS THANK YOU
MISTAKEN AND I NEED YOU TO WRAP
UP JUST A QUICKLY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR. AFTER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ENFORCEMENT
STRIKE TEAM CAL OSHA HAS
PERFORMED OVER TEN THOUSAND ON
SITE VISITS. WITH A FOCUS ON
HIGH RISK COMPANIES AND
INDUSTRIES. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR TIME AND I WILL NOW TURN
IT OVER TO DOUG PARKER CHIEF OF
CAL OSHA THE TALK ABOUT THE
DIVISIONS WORK OVER THE LAST
SIX MONTHS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WE WILL MOVE ON WITH DOUG
PARKER THANK YOU. MR PARKER.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRPERSON
GONZALEZ MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I AM THAT PARKER
CHIEF OF CAL OSHA I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY. ABOUT CALLUSES
RESPONSE TO THE COPA NINETEEN
CRISIS. FIRST I WANT TO ECHO
DIRECTOR HAGENS ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
OF THE TREMENDOUS WORK AND
SACRIFICE OF FIRST RESPONDERS
AND OTHER ESSENTIAL WORKERS-
THEY'VE CONTINUED TO CARE FOR
US FEED US TRANSPORT US-
CONSTRUCTOR HOMES AND PROVIDE
US WITH OTHER- ESSENTIAL NEEDS-
AND- SOME OF THEM. TOO MANY
HAVE TRAGICALLY LOST THEIR
LIVES PROVIDING THE REST OF US
WITH THESE NECESSITIES. QALISYA
WE TRY TO REMAIN FOCUSED ON
PROTECTING THOSE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS WHO FACE THE GREATEST
RISK. AND WE HAVE ALSO TRYING
TO MAINTAIN THE HIGHEST
STANDARDS OF WORKER PROTECTION
DURING THE CRISIS. CALIFORNIA'S
FINANCIAL LEADER AND WORKER
HEALTH WORKER HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS IN MAINTAINING THOSE
HIGH STANDARDS IS NOT A GOAL WE
HAVE TRIED TO MAINTAIN AS WE
APPROACH THE CHALLENGES OF THIS
PANDEMIC. I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO PROVIDE THE
COMMITTEE AN OUTLINE OF OUR
STRATEGY FOR RESPONDING TO THE
COVE IN NINETEEN CRISIS. WE
REALIZED EARLY ON THAT WE HAD
TO DEVELOP A STRATEGY TO
ADDRESS A PROBLEM THAT WAS ON A
SCALE MUCH LARGER. THAN WE WERE
GONNA BE ABLE TO HANDLE WITH
BUSINESS AS USUAL SO WE HAD TO
MAKE SOME ADJUSTMENTS- AND WE
TRY TO FOCUS ON THREE THINGS.
FIRST IS LEVERAGING OUR
KNOWLEDGE AND TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE TO DEVELOP GUIDANCE
REGULATIONS- SO THAT EMPLOYERS
AND WORKERS WHAT I UNDERSTAND
THE COVER NINETEEN CRISIS.
NUMBER TO FIND WAYS TO EDUCATE
AS MANY OF THOSE EMPLOYERS AND
WORKERS AS POSSIBLE ABOUT HOW
TO. IMPLEMENT OVER NINETEEN
PROTECTIONS AND THEN THIRD
FIFTEEN YOU CAN FORCE WHEN
EFFORTS THAT WE HAVE THE
GREATEST IMPACT ON THE GREATEST
NUMBER OF WORKERS GIVEN OUR
FINITE RESOURCES RELATIVE TO
THE SCALE OF THE PROBLEM. FOR
THE FIRST STRATEGY LEVERAGING
EXPERTISE. WE FOCUSED ON TWO
THINGS. PRIMARILY IN MARCH WE
BEGAN DEVELOPING BECAUSE THE
NINETEEN GUIDANCE. AND TO DATE
WE HAVE ISSUED OUR CO ISSUES
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. MORE THAN WHAT KINDS
FOR MORE THAN FORTY INDUSTRIES
AS WELL AS A NUMBER OF OTHER
COMPLIANCE TOOLS. THESE ARE ALL
AVAILABLE ON THE WEBSITE OF
BOTH THE ADMINISTRATION AND-
AND- CALLOSUM. AND WE ARE
CURRENTLY DEVELOPING AN
EMERGENCY TEMPORARY STANDARD TO
ADDRESS COVE IN NINETEEN. IF IT
IF APPROVED IT WOULD MAKE
CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE FIRST
STATES IN THE NATION TO HAVE.
IN LAW WORKPLACE HEALTH AND
SAFETY REGULATIONS SPECIFIC TO
COPE AT NINETEEN. FOR OUR
SECOND STRATEGY EDUCATION OUT
REACH WE HAVE WORK TO
COMPLEMENT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
BROADER OUTREACH EFFORTS BY
FOCUSING ON THE WORKPLACE. FOR
EXAMPLE WE HAVE PARTNERED WITH
MEXICAN CONSULATES AND WORKER
ADVOCACY GROUPS TO. REACH LOW
WAGE AND IMMIGRANT WORKERS
WE'VE EMAILED- GUIDANCE AS THE
DIRECTOR HAGEN MENTIONED WE
FEEL THAT THOUSANDS OF CALLS
FROM EMPLOYERS TO ADVISE THEM
ON BEST PRACTICES. AND WE'RE
CONDUCTING WEBINARS THAT- THAT
ACCOMMODATE A THOUSAND PEOPLE
AT A TIME TO PROVIDE IN DEPTH
VIRTUAL TRAINING WE'VE ALSO
PARTNERED WITH OTHER AGENCIES
TO FOCUS OUT REACH. IN HIGH
RISK WORKPLACES SUCH AS
AGRICULTURE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES INTO PROCESSING. AS
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
STRATEGIC FACT TASK FORCE-
WE'VE MADE MORE THAN ELEVEN
THOUSAND IN PERSON COMPLIANCE
ASSISTANCE VISITS TO PLAYERS IN
THE STATE- AND AS A WHOLE THE
TASK FORCE IS MADE MORE THAN
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION CONTACTS
WITH EMPLOYERS. OUR THIRD
STRATEGY. STRATEGIC ENFORCEMENT
HAS MANAGED. TARGETING THE
HIGHEST RISK WORKPLACES AND
INDUSTRIES. FOCUSING ON
GEOGRAPHIC HOT SPOTS AS PART OF
THE STATE'S TASK FORCES. AND
COMMUNICATED OUR FORCE AND
EFFORTS TO THE PUBLIC TO
FURTHER INCENTIVIZE COMPLIANCE.
TO IMPLEMENT THAT WE'VE OPENED
CLOSE TO TWELVE HUNDRED COVER
NINETY INSPECTION SINCE
FEBRUARY. WE'VE ISSUED
CITATIONS THAT WILL HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT DETERRENT EFFECT
INCLUDING THE HIGHEST MONETARY
PENALTIES ISSUED IN ANY STATE
IN THE NATION FOR OVER NINETEEN.
AND WE HAVE ACTIVELY PUBLICIZE
OUR ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS TO
INCENTIVIZE COMPLIANCE. IN
TERMS OF OUR STRATEGIC FOCUS
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE OF OUR
INSPECTIONS ABOUT 25% HAVE BEEN-HEALTHCARE INCLUDING HOSPITALS
AND SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTEEN
INSPECTIONS ALMOST 20% HAVE
BEEN IN AGRICULTURE. BECAUSE
IMMIGRANT AGRICULTURAL WORKERS
ARE OFTEN UNAWARE FEARFUL ABOUT
FIND A FILING COMPLAINTS WITH
US THE MAJORITY OF THOSE
INSPECTIONS WERE STRATEGIC AND
NOT COMPLYING OR IN THE SPACE-
WE ALSO DID OVER ELEVEN HUNDRED
COMPLIANCE ASSISTANCE. ACT
WE'VE GOT ABOUT A HUNDRED FORTY
EIGHT INSPECTION INSPECTIONS IN
THE RETAIL TRADING LOOTING
GROCERY STORES. AND HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE IN MANUFACTURING
INCLUDING THIRTY THREE
INSPECTIONS AT TO PROCESSING
FACILITIES WHICH WERE ALSO- IN
MANY CASES FOR TEACHING
INSPECTIONS. IN ADDITION TO
THAT WORK WE'VE CONDUCTED IN
THE SAME TIME FRAME OVER TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED NON CODE
INSPECTIONS- BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE AND
CONTINUE TO CARRY OUT OUR OTHER
MANDATE TO INVESTIGATE
ACCIDENTS AND INVESTIGATE
COMPLAINTS THANK YOU MISTER
PARKER. THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO FINISH THE LAST- PIECE
WE CAN THAT WOULD BE GREAT AND
WE CAN MOVE ON SURE I WAS JUST
GONNA MENTION AND WE'VE ALSO
DONE COMPLIANCE CHECKS FOR
COVERT IN THOSE INSPECTIONS
WELL WE'RE ALWAYS LOOKING TO DO
OUR JOB BETTER WE BELIEVE OUR
APPROACH IS THE RIGHT ONE AND
IT'S MADE US HAS MADE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE FORMED MISTER
PARKER WE APPRECIATE THAT.
SKINNER LAST PRESENTER FROM OUR
FIRST PANEL TODAY WILL BE DR
BARBARA MATERNA OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND DR MATERNA HAS WITH
HER DOCTOR KATHLEEN JACOBSON AS
WELL. TO HELP ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AS WELL FROM OUR FROM
OUR SENATORS. WELCOME DR
MATERNA. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS HI
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH BRANCH IN
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE SOME
SOME OF WHAT CITY PAGES DURING
ON THIS VITALLY IMPORTANT
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE. I WILL
FOCUS MY BRIEF REMARKS ON FOUR
TOPICS I WAS ASKED TO COVER.
THE FIRST TOPIC IS COVER
NINETEEN OUTBREAKS IN THE
WORKPLACES HOW WE ARE NOTIFIED
ABOUT THEM AND WHAT WE DO TO
RESPOND AND ASSIST EMPLOYERS.
CDPH IS NOTIFIED ABOUT
OUTBREAKS THROUGH LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. I WOULD BREAK IT
IS DEFINED DIFFERENTLY
DEPENDING ON THE TYPE OF
WORKPLACE OR COMMUNITY SETTING.
FOR NON HEALTH CARE WORKPLACES
CDPH DEFINES AN OUTBREAK AS
THREE OR MORE COATED NINETEEN
CASES WITHIN A FOURTEEN DAY
PERIOD AMONG PEOPLE WHO ARE
FROM DIFFERENT HOUSEHOLDS. THE
DEFINITION FOR HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES HAS MORE DETAILED
CRITERIA AND IS OUTLINED IN OUR
OFFICE FACILITIES LETTER ISSUED
SEPTEMBER TWENTY SECOND. MOST
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WILL
ENTER DATA INTO THE OUTBREAK
MODULE OF THIS CD PH ELECTRONIC
INFECTIOUS DISEASE REPORTING
SYSTEM WE'RE CAL READY. WHERE
THEY CAN CHOOSE AMONG THE
LISTED TYPES OF WORKPLACE OR
COMMUNITY SETTINGS OR SPECIFY
OTHER AND ENTER THE REQUESTED
INFORMATION BREAKS IN HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES ARE ALSO
IDENTIFIED AND TRACKED BY
DIRECT EMPLOYER REPORTING FOR
EXAMPLE. SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES MUST REPORT CODE
NINETEEN CASES IN WORKERS OR
RESIDENTS DIRECTLY TO CDPH VIA
A DAILY SURVEY. OPRAH CHRIS
PINE IS TYPICALLY HANDLED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL WHERE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAD THE LEAD
ROLE THAT MAY REQUEST TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM CDPH. WHEN
REQUESTED BY LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WE CAN ASSIST
THROUGH OUR SPECIALIZED
INVESTIGATION TEAMS FOR HEALTH
CARE CORRECTIONS RESIDENTIAL
CONGREGATE SETTINGS AND NON
HEALTH CARE NON RESIDENTIAL
CONGREGATE SETTINGS. WITH
RESPECT TO WHAT OUR REGION
ASSISTANCE WE PROVIDE TO
EMPLOYERS EXPERIENCING AN
OUTBREAK. CDPH ALL FACILITIES
LETTERS AND OTHER GUIDANCE
DOCUMENTS ARE USED TO ADVISE
HEALTH CARE EMPLOYERS ON ALL
ASPECTS OF COOLEY NINETEEN
PREVENTION AND RESPONSE. CDPH
HAS ALSO PRODUCED A GUIDANCE
DOCUMENT RESPONDING TO CODE
NINETEEN IN THE WORKPLACE WHICH
VERSIONS FOR BOTH EMPLOYERS AND
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WAS
FIRST ISSUED. IN JUNE A REVISED
IN SEPTEMBER. THIS PROVIDES A
STEP CHECK TO ASSIST WITHOUT
PROGRESS IN ON HEALTH CARE NON
CONGREGATE SETTINGS. A CATEGORY
THAT INCLUDES FOOD MEAT OR
POULTRY PROCESSING WAREHOUSES
GROCERY STORES AT CENTER. CDPH
COLLABORATES WITH LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS EMPLOYERS AND OTHER
AGENCIES SUCH AS CAL OSHA TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL CONSULTATION
ON SPECIFIC OUTBREAKS. OUR
HEALTH CARE ASSOCIATED
INFECTIONS PROGRAM SENDS
INFECTION PREVENTION NURSE ON
SITE TO PROVIDE TRAINING AND
SUPPORT FOR INFECTION CONTROL
PRACTICES IN WORKPLACES
INCLUDING HOSPITALS SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AND LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES AND IN
SOME CASES CORRECTIONS. WE ALSO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL CONSULTATION
FOR EXAMPLE OCCUPATIONAL
MEDICINE OR INDUSTRIAL HYGIENE
EXPERTISE EPIDEMIOLOGY SUPPORT
AND GUIDANCE AND TESTING
STRATEGIES. THROUGH PHONE CALLS
INVOLVING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND AFFECTED
EMPLOYERS AND WE HAVE PROVIDED
ON SITE ASSISTANCE IN SOME HIGH
PROFILE PROFILE SITUATIONS. IN
COLLABORATION WITH CAL OSHA
WE'RE NOW BEING BEGINNING TO
PLAN FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE. THIS
WILL INCLUDE ORIGINAL PLAYERS
ON THE LOS REQUIREMENT THAT
THEY REPORT OUTBREAKS TO LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. OUR
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS ARE CURRENTLY
ANALYZING DATA IN THE OUTBREAK
MUNJAL PERTAINING TO WORKPLACE
SETTINGS AND THIS WILL INFORM
OUR EFFORTS TO IMPROVE THE
CLASSIFICATION OF OUTBREAKS BY
IN JUST INDUSTRY SETTING AND
THE REPORTING OF THAT
INFORMATION. THE SECOND TOPIC
WE ARE ASKED ABOUT IS WHAT WE
CONSIDER IN DEVELOPING EMPLOYER
GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS. CDPH SPEND
WORKING WITH BOTH CAL OSHA AND
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND DEVELOPING
INDUSTRY SPECIFIC GUIDANCE FOR
CORPORATE PER NINETEEN
PREVENTION. SOME OF THE
CONSIDERATIONS WE. THINK ABOUT
IN DEVELOPING THIS GUIDANCE OUR
GENERAL OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND
HEALTH PRINCIPLES ON HOW TO
CONTROL AEROSOL TRANSMISSIBLE
DISEASES THROUGH A RANGE OF
ENGINEERING WORK PRACTICE AND
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
CONTROLS. WE CONSIDER THE
EVOLVING SCIENTIFIC KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT KOBE NINETEEN INCLUDING
INFORMATION ON WHERE
TRANSMISSION HAS OCCURRED AND
HOW. WE CONSIDER THE GUIDANCE
FROM CDC THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE
FOR OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND
HEALTH FEDERAL OSHA OTHER STATE
AGENCIES HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROFESSIONAL ORGANIZATIONS AND
OTHERS. WE TAILOR THIS GUIDANCE
TO THE WORK PROCESSES AND
UNIQUE SITUATIONS IN SPECIFIC
INDUSTRIES WHILE MAKING AN
EFFORT TO MAINTAIN CONSISTENCY
ACROSS THESE DOCUMENTS. WE
FIRST PRODUCE GUIDANCE FOR
ESSENTIAL WORKER INDUSTRIES AND
THEN FOR SECTORS THAT WOULD BE
ANTICIPATING RE OPENING IN
ORDER TO HELP THEM TO PLAN
AHEAD. WE'VE ALSO SOUGHT INPUT
FROM STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
REPRESENTATIVES FROM BOTH
EMPLOYER AND WORKER
ORGANIZATIONS. AND A FINAL
CONSIDERATION IS THE
ACCESSIBILITY OF THESE
DOCUMENTS THROUGH OUR WEBSITES
BY MAKING THEM AVAILABLE IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES AND
DISSEMINATING THEM THROUGH
BROAD OUTREACH. THE THIRD TOPIC
IS PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT AND WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
AN EMPLOYER CANNOT PROCURE WHAT
IS NEEDED. CDPH ONLY HANDLES PP
REQUESTS FOR MEDICAL AND HEALTH
RESOURCES FROM HEALTH CARE
EMPLOYERS. SO REQUESTS FROM NON
HEALTH CARE EMPLOYERS ARE DEALT
WITH THROUGH THE STATE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES THANK YOU
DR MATERNAL WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO JUST WRAP UP IF YOU WANT TO.
FINALIZE THAT POINT. OKAY AND
THAT POINT WAS THAT THE MEDICAL
HEALTH OPERATIONAL AREA
COORDINATION PROGRAMMER MY WEB
PROGRAM IS HOW THESE RESOURCES
THREE. REQUESTED FROM THE LOCAL
LEVEL TO THE REGIONAL LEVEL AND
AFTER THIS COUPLE. AND I'LL
JUST CLOSE BY SAYING THE FOURTH
TOPIC WAS AROUND EMPLOYEE
TESTING AND- I HAVE A COLLEAGUE
WITH ME HERE TODAY DR. CATHY
JACOBSON WHO IS AVAILABLE TO
HELP ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
COME UP ON THAT TOPIC THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY WONDERFUL THANK
YOU SO MUCH DR MATERNA NOW-
THAT CONCLUDES OUR FIRST PANEL
AND WE WILL BE TAKING IT BACK
TO DISCUSSION BETWEEN MEMBERS
SO. THE FIRST NUMBER I HAVE IS
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU CHAIR
GONZALEZ- YES SOME QUESTIONS-
FOR- CAL OSHA AND DA R. NINETY
ONE I THINK I KNOW IF I HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH- MISTER
PARKER CHIEF PARKER. IN
CONJUNCTION WITH C. DPH ABOUT-
GETTING MORE SPECIFIC GUIDANCE
TO. THE TICKET BUSINESSES THERE
BY CAR CUSTOMER FACING STAFF
CUSTOMERS COMING IN LIKE
RESTAURANTS AND RETAIL AND SO
FORTH- BECAUSE THERE'S A- FOR
PLACES A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN.
ONES THAT MAY NOT- IN TERMS OF
THE LEVEL OF CONTROL AND OF
COURSE THAT INCLUDES GROCERY
STORES. I GUESS THE QUESTION I
HAVE HE SPOKE TO ENFORCEMENT
EDUCATION APPRECIATE THAT- DO
YOU DOES. HELLO SHOULD FEEL
LIKE THEY HAVE THE TOOLS
NECESSARY TO REALLY GET.
LAWYERS TO CHANGE THEIR
BEHAVIORS QUICKLY ALL RIGHT SO
THIS IS A CONTAGIOUS DISEASE IT
SPREADS EXPONENTIALLY. THERE'S
A TIME PRESSURED TO HAVE
SOMETHING DONE RIGHT AWAY NOT
LIKE WELL WE'LL GIVE YOU TIME
TO FIX THINGS AND SO FORTH SO
FOR EXAMPLE. DO YOU HAVE THE
ABILITY TO COME IN AND SHUT
DOWN A PLACE UNTIL IT'S
ACTUALLY RENDERED SAFE SO YOU
GO IN YOU SEE INSPECTION. IT'S
GREAT YOU CAN SEND OF A FINE.
CITATION BUT I MEAN CLOSE THE
WORKPLACE DOWN UNTIL IT'S FIXED
RIGHT AND WE TALK ABOUT FINES.
I APPRECIATE- YOU KNOW YOU TALK
ABOUT THE RECORD FINES. BUT
REALLY YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO
CHART TELL THAT BUSINESS YOU
HAVE TO CONTINUE PAYING ALL THE
WORKERS THEIR FULL SALARY WHILE
YOU FIX THE PLACE BECAUSE WE
CAN'T PEALIZE THE WORKERS. FOR
AN UNSAFE WORKPLACE AND THEN IN
ORDER TO SHUT THE PLACE DOWN
UNTIL IT'S FIXED SO CAN YOU
SPEAK TO YOUR STORY TO BE ABLE
TO DO THOSE TYPES OF THINGS. IF
NECESSARY TO ENSURE A SAFE
WORKPLACE- SO SPEEDILY BE ABLE
TO SHUT THE PLACE DOWN. REQUIRE
THEY MAKE THE CHANGES CONTINUE
TO BE REQUIRED TO PAY THE
WORKERS UNTIL AS THOSE CHANGES
ARE BEING MADE. DO YOU HAVE
THAT AUTHORITY OR DO YOU NEED
AUTHORITY FROM THE LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAM AUTHORITY
ALLOWS US TO ISSUE AN ORDER
PROHIBITING USE THAT WORD-
CLOSE AN AFFECTED AREA OF THE
BUSINESS IN THE EVENT OF AN
IMMINENT HAZARD SO IF THERE WAS
A YEAR OF AN IMMINENT THREAT OF
A HAZARD THAT WOULD HAVE NO
EFFECT LIFE FOR SERIOUS ILLNESS.
WE HAVE TO IN THE COURSE OF
DOING THAT. GATHER SUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE TO- TO SUSTAIN THAT IS
THE SAME THAT ORDER IN IN A
HEARING BECAUSE THE EMPLOYERS
HAVE. A RIGHT TO A HEARING AND
SO WE TYPICALLY GATHER EVIDENCE
ON THAT POINT. WE HAVE.
ACTIVELY EXPLORED A NUMBER OF
CASES IN WHICH WE CONSIDER
ORDERS- BUT IN THOSE CASES- WE
ACHIEVED. YOU KNOW COMPLIANCE
FROM THE EMPLOYER BEFORE WE
ISSUED ANY ORDERS BUT YES WE DO
HAVE THAT AUTHORITY- THERE WAS-
SOME AMBIGUITY BECAUSE IT'S
NEVER BEEN TESTED WITH RESPECT
TO COVER NINETEEN. IN
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING ON THE
COURTS- AND SO JUST TO CLARIFY
AND DISPEL ANY ANY AMBIGUITY
ABOUT THAT- WE'RE PROUD OF
WE'RE PLEASED THAT THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE.
WHICH IS SPECIFICALLY DEFINES A
COVE IN NINETEEN AS AN IMMINENT
HAZARD. IF WE- YOU KNOW I
IDENTIFY SITUATION WORKPLACE
WHERE WHERE THAT EXPOSURE IS
YOU KNOW MEET THE STANDARD- AND
SO WE DO HAVE THAT AUTHORITY
AND I BELIEVE UNDER CURRENT LAW
WHEN WE ISSUE ISSUE THOSE
ORDERS. THERE IS AN OBLIGATION
TO CONTINUE TO PAY WORKERS AT
LEAST TOP I CAN GET BACK. TO
YOU ON THE ON THE SPECIFICS OF
THAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER PAN AM NEXT I HAVE
CENTER COMING AT ALL WITH HER
HAND. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO ALL THE
PRESENTERS I APPRECIATE THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU PROVIDED
DAY AND I AM- IT. THE DETAIL IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO US I HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS- BEFORE WE
GET TO THE NEXT PANEL WHICH IS
GOING TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT I
WOULD I A WAS CONCERNED WITH
THE VACANCY- AT ISSUE THAT WAS
RAISED AND I THOUGHT WHAT I
HEARD IS THAT. THERE IS AN
EFFORT TO FILL SIXTY FIVE
VACANCIES. WITHIN THE NEXT I
THINK THREE OR FOUR MONTHS AND
THEN IT IT SOUNDED LIKE ANOTHER
SEVENTY VACANCIES AFTER THAT
AND I'M WONDERING IF YOU COULD
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT. HOW
MANY ARE WE TALKING ABOUT IN IN
WHICH UNIT ARE THESE AND WHY
ARE WE SO FAR BEHIND- AND IF
THIS IF THIS NUMBER IS TRUE-
WHAT KIND OF WHAT LED UP TO AS
BEING. SO FAR BEHIND IN IN
TERMS OF- IN TERMS OF FILLING
VACANCIES AND IN MAKING SURE WE
HAD. ENOUGH STAFF THEN HAVE A
SECOND. THEM QUESTION. THE
QUESTIONS ABOUT PROCESS. BURKE
SURE. THANK YOU SENATOR
GOVERNOR WITHOUT DIRECTED
TOWARDS- BELIEVE THAT IT'D
PROBABLY BE- DIRECTOR READY TO
HIT TAKEN OKAY YEAH YOU CAN CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN. RIGHT
M. THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION.
YES ARE THE NUMBERS DO YOU
INDICATED ARE ARE ACCURATE AND
THOSE NUMBERS REPRESENT AN
EXISTING VACANCIES- AT CAL
OSHA- THE SIXTY FIVE UP
POSITIONS THAT WE'RE TARGETING
TO FILL BY THE END OF THIS
CALENDAR YEAR. ARE SPECIFICALLY
ENFORCEMENT RELATED POSITIONS
SO WHILE WE BORROWED STAFF FROM
OTHER AGENCIES WE'RE WE HIRED-
A NUMBER OF TEMPORARY STAFF TO
HELP SHORE US UP UNTIL WE'RE
ABLE TO FILL. A NUMBER OF OUR
VACANCIES- SO WE'RE TARGETING
ENFORCEMENT AT PRESENT- AND
WE'VE HIRED- APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY THREE PEOPLE IN THE LAST
FEW MONTHS- THE MAJORITY OF
THOSE BEING IN THE ENFORCEMENT
AREA. THE OTHER SEVENTY
VACANCIES ARE A NUMBER OF
OTHER- POSITIONS ACROSS CALLOW
SINCE IT'S A FAIRLY LARGE
ORGANIZATION- ATTORNEYS-
ELEVATOR INSPECTORS- SUPPORT
STAFF YOU KNOW IT'S A WHOLE
VARIETY. BUT OUTSIDE OF THE
ENFORCEMENT AREA- WE- BUT YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT WHAT MY UP TO
THE BIG RATE IS A MORE
COMPLICATED- STORY THAT AT. YOU
MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH THAT A-
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO THERE WAS
AN AUDIT CONDUCTED- AT THE I.
R. WHICH LED TO- THEY'RE HIRING
IS THE WORD EAT BEING- HOLD AND-
WE CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE- WE
HAVE TO GO TO CONTROL AGENCY
FOR APPROVAL- FOR ALL OF OUR
HIRES- SO THAT. THAT IS ONE
PIECE OF IT WE HAVE-
IMPLEMENTED A NUMBER OF-
TACTICS AROUND FILLING NOT JUST
CAL OSHA VACANCIES BUT ALL THE
VACANCIES WITHIN D. I. R. WITH
CALLOSUM. BEING OUR PRIORITY
SINCE THEY'RE REALLY ON THE
FRONT LINES OF- CALLS IT.
FORSMAN AND OUTREACH. BUT THE
YOU KNOW EVERYTHING FROM JUST
PUTTING INTO PLACE A HIRING
PROTOCOLS TRAINING MANAGERS ON
APPROPRIATE HIRING PRACTICES-
CONDUCTING A NATIONWIDE
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS FOR SAFETY
ENGINEERS AN INDUSTRIAL
HYGIENIST- THERE WERE A NUMBER
OF EXAMINATIONS THAT HAD
EXPIRED DURING THIS PERIOD OF
TIME- BUT THE DEPARTMENT WAS
UNDER AUDIT AND SUBSEQUENTLY.
WE NEEDED TO RE ESTABLISH THOSE
EXAMINATIONS IN ORDER TO GET A
CANDIDATE POOL- SO THERE WERE A
NUMBER OF STEPS THAT NEEDED TO
BE TAKEN BEFORE- WE COULD BRING
ON PEOPLE PERMANENTLY INTO
THESE VERY PROFESSIONAL HIGHLY
SKILLED POSITIONS- AND- WE ARE
MAKING PROGRESS WE'VE GOT- IN
ADDITION TO THAT THE TWENTY
THREE HIRES THAT I MENTIONED WE
HAVE NINETEEN THAT ARE IN THE
FINAL STAGES OF HIRING AN
EASIER IN OUR ENFORCEMENT AREA
AGAIN. I'M IN THIRTY SIX AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTY SIX THAT ARE
IN THE RECRUITMENT FACE- SO WE
BELIEVE THAT AS LONG AS YOU
KNOW OUR CANDIDATE POOL REMAINS
HEALTHY WHICH IT HAS BEEN A
BEEN VERY ENCOURAGED BY THE
NUMBER OF QUALIFIED CANDIDATES
THAT WANT TO COME WORK FOR CAL
OSHA- AS LONG AS THAT MAINTAINS
WE BELIEVE WILL BE. OUR TARGET
FOR THE END OF THIS CALENDAR
YEAR. THANK YOU FOR THAT I
APPRECIATE IT AND- ON. THAT
SUBJECT FOR A LONGER DISCUSSION
I THINK JUST IN TERMS OF.
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
PRODUCING THE WORK FORCE IT CAN
WORK THE WORKFORCE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT CAN DO THE WORK
THAT WE NEED DONE SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND THEN. ON
THE OTHER THE OTHER. THE
QUESTION AND THEN YOU SEE IF I
CAN GET THIS OUT QUICKLY IS.
I'M I'M I'M CONCERNED BECAUSE
AS I HAVE- REPRESENT SIX
COUNTIES AND AS I WAS. TRYING
TO GET INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
WE WERE DOING TO PROTECT THE
WORK FORCE. IT WAS CONFUSING TO
ME EXACTLY WHERE THE REPORTING.
BOB BREAKDOWN OCCURRED. IT DID
NOT APPEAR TO ME THAT EACH
COUNTY WAS ASKING THE QUESTION.
ABOUT THE I BELIEVE IT WAS- AT.
THE END THE INFECTION RATE BY
INDUSTRY SETTING WHICH- WHICH
WOULD TELL US. OR WOULD IT IS
TRACED BACK TO A PARTICULAR
WORKPLACE- AND TELL US A LITTLE
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON AND SO WHEN I ASK
THAT. THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
OFFICERS WELL FIRST OF ALL THIS
WE HAVE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICES
THAT ARE GOING OUT IN ISSUING
ORDERS AND THEN ALSO THE
POTENTIAL FOR CAL OSHA. AND I'M
IT I'M INTERESTED IN IN THE
INTERPLAY BETWEEN THAT WHETHER
THAT THERE'S THEY WORK TAKE
WHETHER YOU WORK TOGETHER. IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO DO SOME OF
THE INSPECTIONS- I AND- AND R.
IS THE INFORMATION IS BEING
GIVEN OUT ABOUT HOW TO PROTECT.
THE WORKERS CONSISTENT BETWEEN
THE ORGANIZATIONS NUMBER ONE
AND THEN TWO IS- MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE. A BETTER A
REPORTING REQUIREMENT. FROM THE
EMPLOYER TO THE COUNTY OR CAL
COUNTY. THE INFECTION RATE BUT
ALSO THAT THE EMPLOYEE HAS AN
OBLIGATION TO REPORT THAT. AS
WELL BECAUSE MANY TIMES WHAT
I'VE HEARD FROM THE EMPLOYERS
PERSPECTIVE AS THEY FIND OUT
AFTER THE FACT IN SIGNIFICANTLY
AFTER THE FACT THAT AN EMPLOYEE
HAS BECOME SICK BECAUSE OF CODE
NINETEEN NUMBER ONE IS IT WAS
HARD TO GET TESTED SO PEOPLE'S.
DIDN'T GET THE TEST WHEN THEY
SHOULD HAVE AND THEN IT DIDN'T
GET RECORDED LIKE IT SHOULD
HAVE AND I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT'S THE MECHANISM. THAT
WE NEED IN PLACE MY MISUMI THIS
IS NOT GOING TO BE THE LAST
PANDEMIC WE HAVE TO FACE IT SO
WE NEED TO SET UP A SYSTEM
WHERE WE GET REALLY GOOD
REPORTING SO WE CAN SEE THINGS.
PROSPECTIVELY RATHER THAN
WAITING TILL AFTER THE FACT AND
THEN. HAVING TO TAKE A
COMPLAINT FROM. FROM FROM A
WORKER IF WE CAN SEE THINGS
AHEAD OF TIME IT WOULD BE A LOT
BETTER SO SOMEBODY COULD TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE-
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN. THE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS AND CAL
OSHA AND THEN AND THEN WHAT
KIND OF REPORTING GAPS WE HAVE
THAT WOULD HAVE ALLOWED US TO
CATCH SOME OF THESE- WORKPLACE-
ISSUES. AHEAD OF TIME. RATHER
THAN SEVEN MONTHS DOWN THE ROAD.
THANK YOU SENATOR COMING AT ALL
I THINK THAT IS DIRECTED
TOWARDS DIRECTOR HAGEN AND
MISTER PARKER. HE SAID THAT I
THINK THAT'S WHERE IT WOULD
WAIT AT. SO I CAN I CAN BEGIN.
WE DO RECEIVED A DIFFERENT
TYPES OF INFORMATION THE- THE
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS IN
CALIFORNIA- LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICERS DO NOT RECEIVED
INFORMATION ABOUT- BECAUSE THE
POSITIVE CASES- MY AND YOU MAY
WANNA ASK CDPH BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THIS
PRIMARILY RECEIVED FROM MEDICAL
PROVIDERS. WHEREAS WE RECEIVED-
REPORTS FROM EMPLOYERS HOWEVER
WE ONLY RECEIVED THOSE REPORTS
WHEN THERE IS A
HOSPITALIZATION. OR WHEN THERE
IS A FATALITY AND- SO YOU KNOW
TODAY WE'VE RECEIVED EIGHT
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX OF THESE ELSE
SERIOUS ILLNESS REPORTS AND TWO
HUNDRED FIFTEEN OF THESE
FATALITY REPORTS WHICH I
BELIEVE ARE VAST. BESIDES FAST
UNDER REPORTING- BY EMPLOYERS
AND IT MAY BE FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS. IN TERMS OF OUR WERE
WORKING TOGETHER WE'VE WORKED
TOGETHER ON A NUMBER OF CASES
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE DONE I DID EARLY ON WAS
TO REACH OUT TO ALL THE LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS IN THE STATE.
TO LET THEM KNOW THAT- HOW TO
REACH US THIS WAS ALSO PART OF
THE CDPH. AMPLIAR PLAYBOOK YOU
MAY RECALL AND- AND LET US KNOW
IF STAY- HAVE PRIORITIES IF
THERE'S INTELLIGENCE THAT THEY
WANT TO SHARE THIS INFORMATION
ONE SHARE THEY SHOULD REACH OUT
TO US ABOUT YOUR WORK PLACES
THAT THEY FIND PROBLEMATIC. AND
THEN THIS AND HAPPENING- I
THINK THAT IT'S FAIR TO SAY
SPEND MORE. FOR BEEN MORE AD
HOC THE SYSTEM. IT BASED ON
JUST THE PART LOCAL PRIORITIES.
ANALYSTS SAY THAT WITH EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY FIVE WE THINK THAT.
BRING ON A NEW REQUIREMENT
WHICH IS THAT EMPLOYERS HAVE TO
NOTIFY OCAL HEALTH OFFICIALS
OF COKE A CASES REGARDLESS OF
MAKING ANY KIND OF
DETERMINATIONS ABOUT. WHERE
THEY CAME FROM OR WHETHER THEIR
WORK RELATED IS GOING TO BE IN
A REALLY IMPORTANT TOOL IN
CUTTING DOWN THE- THAT TIME
LINE THE TIME IT TAKES TO
EFFECTIVELY RESPOND TO AN
INCIDENT WHICH I THINK. KIND OF
GOES TO THE CORE PROBLEM-
THAT'S SERIALIZER AND IF YOUR
QUESTION. WELL IF I COULD I
MEAN PART OF THE CHALLENGE THAT
I'M I'M HEARING IS THAT- IN
SOME OF THE BIG INDUSTRIES YOU
HAVE PEOPLE THAT- PEOPLE THAT
DECIDED THEY WERE GOING TO.
WORK WE'RE GOING TO WORK
ANYMORE BECAUSE THEY WERE HIGH
RISK FOR WILL BE THERE FOR
BECAUSE OF A MAJOR BECAUSE OF.
EXIST CONDITIONS AND YOU HAD
PEOPLE THAT WERE SICK BUT
DIDN'T HAVE COPING GONE AND SO.
EVEN THE EMPLOYER HAD NO WAY OF
BEING ABLE TO ASCERTAIN WHY
SOMEBODY WASN'T AT THE OFFICE
OR OR AT THAT LOCATION- AND IN
PARTICULAR IN SOME OF OUR RURAL
SETTINGS- THERE THERE THERE CAN
BE A REAL. HEAVY TURNOVER WITH
CONTRACT LABOR BEING USED AS
THAT AS THE AS THE BACKSTOP AND
SOME I GUESS I'M TRYING TO GET
TO HOW DO YOU SET UP AN
OBLIGATION FOR AN EMPLOYER TO
DO SOMETHING. IF THERE IF. IF
THERE ARE PROTECTIONS.
PROTECTIONS FOR EMPLOYEES THAT
MAKE IT DIFFICULT TO FIND OUT
EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING ON UNLESS
THAT EMPLOYEE IS FORTHCOMING.
AND I'M I'M JUST WONDERING IF
THERE'S- YOU KNOW HOW WE SET UP
THE SYSTEM. SO THAT THAT THERE
ARE MUTUAL OBLIGATIONS BETWEEN.
LADIES AND- AND THEN THEN IT
GETS REPORTED CONSISTENTLY TO
THE SAME. TO THE SAME ENTITY
BECAUSE I ALSO. HEARD AND I
DIDN'T GET IT DONE QUICKLY AND
BUT THAT THERE IS SOME
REPORTING THAT HAPPENS TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND
THEN THERE'S OTHER REPORTING
THAT HAPPENED TO THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND HOW HOW
WOULD. AN INDIVIDUALKNOW WHO
THEY SHOULD REPORT EITHER AND
ELLIS TWO OR AND DEATH. TO ON.
THIS IS IT HAS SO MANY HOLES IN
IT THAT THERE'S A POTENTIAL FOR
SOME SOME TO FALL THROUGH AND
WE DON'T GET A REAL CLEAR
PICTURE OF WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THE COMMUNITY. WELL IT IS TRUE
THAT- THAT I'M FOR CAN'T REPORT
WHAT THEY DON'T KNOW ABOUT- ONE
OF THE- WAYS THAT WE'VE
ADDRESSED THAT IN OUR GUIDANCE.
THAT WE'VE ISSUE WITH C. DPH IS
TO STRONGLY ENCOURAGE. WORKERS
TO REPORT ILLNESSES AND
SYMPTOMS AND ALSO. MAKE SURE
THAT EMPLOYERS EMPHASIZE THIS
IN TRAINING THAT THEY PROVIDE
TO EMPLOYEES TO SORT OF IMPROVE
THAT LINE OF COMMUNICATION SO
THAT. THESE ARE AWARE AND SO
THAT THEY CAN REPORT IN A
TIMELY WAY IN TERMS OF YOUR WHO
REPORTS TO WHO- I CAN ONLY
SPEAK FOR OUR AGENCY AND WE
HAVE LONG STANDING REGULATIONS
IN PLACE ABOUT REPORTING
SERIOUS ILLNESSES. AND
OBLIGATIONS THAT EMPLOYERS HAVE
TO ALSO RECORD THESE IN THEIR
OWN- LONG THREE HUNDRED FORMS
THESE ARE THESE ARE. THESE ARE
INTERNAL RECORDS THAT REPRESENT
EMPLOYERS MAINTAIN AND WE'VE
ALSO PUT FAQS ON OUR WEBSITE TO
HELP EMPLOYERS NAVIGATE THE
QUESTION OF HOW THEY DETERMINE
WHETHER TO REPORT. A CO THAT
NINETEEN ILLNESS AND AGAIN I
THINK THAT- WITH THE- WITH THE
PASSAGE O SB SIX A FIVE THAT
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO CLOSE
SOME OF THESE SIGNIFICANT GAPS-
I CAN'T SAY THAT WE WILL CLOSE
ALL OF THEM IN RESPONSE TO YOUR
QUESTION. WELL IT WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVED
SITUATION I BELIEVE. THANK YOU
FOR SHARING THAT. THANK YOU
SENATOR KABBADI AT ALL- NEXT
WERE GONNA MOVE ON TO SENATOR
JACKSON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS IF I MAY
UM AND I APPRECIATE HOW
DIFFICULT THIS IS BEEN WE GOT
THROWN INTO THIS CHAOS- WITHOUT
A PADDLE IF YOU WILL- AND IT
CERTAINLY DIDN'T GET MUCH HELP
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
SO WE KIND OF HAD TO. LEARN AS
WE GO BUT THAT BEING SAID YOU
KNOW I LOOK AT THE SITUATION
THAT HAPPENED AT FOSTER FARMS
THAT WAS ALLOWED TO CONTINUE
DAY AFTER DAY WEEK AFTER WEEK
WHEN BOTH THE COUNTY AND STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS KNEW
THERE WAS A SIGNIFICANT
OUTBREAK- THAT THE COMPANY
CONTINUED TO IGNORE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY RULES- AND
THAT WORKERS WERE IN DANGER-
BUT- IT TOOK I BELIEVE UNTIL
THE DEATHS OF EIGHT PEOPLE. ARE
TO SHUT THE PLANT DOWN AND I'M
WONDERING- WHAT TEST. SINCE FOR
WHAT YOU ARE DOING. TO AND THAT
KIND OF- NEGLIGENCE- ICE I
ASSUME THAT THERE ARE FINE
STATE YOU'VE GIVEN SO ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS I HAVE IS WHAT
ARE THE EXTENT OF THOSE FINES
HOW DO YOU DETERMINE THEM. AND
THEN ARE THOSE COMPANIES ALSO
SUBJECT TO POSSIBLE-
LITIGATION- BY THE FAMILIES OF
PEOPLE OF BOTH BEEN INJURED.
WITH THE ILLNESS OR DIED- AND
WHAT YOU THINK OF THE ABILITY
TO BRING- HAVE A PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION FOR THOSE FOLKS IN
ADDITION TO. AYE YOUR- ABILITY
TO- TO FIND HIM ARE THERE
LIMITS TO IT HOW DO YOU
DETERMINE WHAT THE FINE SHOULD
BE AND AGAIN AS SOMEONE WHO
REALLY. TAKES ENFORCEMENT
SERIOUSLY- WHAT MORE CAN OR
SHOULD WE BE DOING TO ENFORCE
THE PROTECTION SO THAT WE DON'T
END UP WITH THE PEOPLE DYING
BECAUSE A COMPANY DECIDES THEY
JUST DON'T WANT TO COMPLAIN
SOMEHOW OR OTHER. ARE ABLE TO
CONTINUE OPERATING YOUR
RESPECTIVE OF THE DANGERS
ASSOCIATED WITH DOING. SO
THAT'S ONE QUESTION. THANK YOU
SENATOR JACKSON. AND THAT WAS
DIRECTED TOWARDS. DIRECTOR
HAGEN AS WELL AS MISTER PARKER
PERHAPS DR-MATERNA AND DOCTOR
JACOBSON AS WELL CAN. ALSO
FOLLOW UP. I CAN I CAN BEGIN
FOSTER FARMS WAS A TRAGEDY. AND
SHOULD IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
PRESENT PREVENT IT I BELIEVE.
WE'RE CONDUCTING AN ACTIVE
INVESTIGATION THERE AND SO THAT
PUTS SOME LIMITS ON WHAT I CAN
SAY ABOUT THE CASE- HOWEVER I
CAN SAY THAT WE ARE- ACTIVELY
INVESTIGATING WHETHER THE
COMPANY VIOLATED THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS AND WHAT THOSE
MAY BE AND WE ARE ALSO
INVESTIGATING WHETHER OR NOT-
THE COMPANY VIOLATED THE LAW
AND NOT IMMEDIATELY REPORTING A
FATALITIES AND SERIOUS
ILLNESSES TO CAL OSHA- I DON'T
KNOW WHAT WILL COME OF THE
INVESTIGATION ULTIMATELY THERE
ARE AT LEAST SHOULDN'T
SPECULATE ON IT WHILE THE
INVESTIGATION IS OPEN- BUT I DO
BELIEVE THAT IF THERE HAD BEEN
BETTER AND FASTER INFORMATION
ABOUT THOSE DEATHS AND POSITIVE
CASES- THAT. WE COULD HAVE
INTERVENE MORE EFFECTIVELY. I
WOULD ALSO SAY THAT- THAT IT
AGAIN AB SIX EIGHTY FIVE
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS ARE
GONNA HELP SITUATIONS LIKE THAT
AND SPEED ACTION IN RESPONSE.
AND I CAN ALSO SAY THAT- WE ARE
YOU KNOW I HAVE MEETINGS IN THE
NEXT DAY OR WEEK DEPEND I WANT
TO GET SCHEDULED WITH- CDPH AND
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
TO SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS THE
ISSUES THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THAT AND HAVE SOME
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HOW WE CAN.
BETTER COORDINATE AND RESPOND
MORE QUICKLY TO SITUATIONS JUST
LIKE THAT AND AFTER THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE-
POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS ARE DONE
WE CALLAS YOU'RE GONNA DO YOU
KNOW A THOROUGH REVIEW OF THAT
A NUMBER OF OTHER INCIDENTS TO
SEE HOW WE CAN- RESPOND MORE
QUICKLY AND AGGRESSIVELY WHEN
WE- KARISA TUITION SUCH AS THE
WHITE FOSTER FARMS. I
APPRECIATE THAT I'M NOT TRYING
TO GET YOU TO DISCUSS YOUR
PARTICULAR CASE THAT WAS JUST
AN EXAMPLE THE FOCUS OF MY
QUESTION AND I WOULD APPRECIATE
IF YOU WERE OTHERS COULD
RESPOND IS- WHAT ARE THE
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS WHAT
KINDS OF- OF PENALTIES WHAT
KIND OF INCENTIVES FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES IF YOU WILL. OUR IT
YES IN ORDER TO GET THAT
EARLIER COMPLIANCE- IN ORDER TO
ASSURE THAT COMPANIES RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE IS A COST A DOLLAR
AND CENTS COST TO THIS CURRENT
BEHAVIOR DO YOU FEEL THAT YOU
HAVE THAT ABILITY AND IF SO HOW
DO YOU DETERMINE THE AMOUNT OF
THE FINES AND IF YOU DON'T HAVE
IT OR IF YOU THINK IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL IN GETTING COMPLIANCE-
TO HAVE. MORE STRINGENT ORIGIN
TO OF. LAWSUITS AND PENALTIES.
THROUGH FOR EXAMPLE A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION. AVAILABLE TO
PLAINTIFFS TO INDIVIDUALS
WHO'VE BEEN HARMED I'M LOOKING
TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT WHAT YOUR
INCENTIVES ARE WITCHER-
AUTHORITY IS ERIN AND IF IT IS
EXPANSIVE ENOUGH. AND WHETHER
OR NOT YOU ALREADY HAVE OR NEED
TO CREATE. MORE ACCESS TO THE
COURTS FOR JUSTICE IF YOU WILL
BY PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN HARMED.
WHEN WE SHOULD HAVE OF FINE
WHEN WE IDENTIFY A VIOLATION
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF FACTORS
THAT GO INTO THE SIZE OF THE
PENALTY THE MONETARY SIDE OF
THE PENALTY SO THAT LOOKS SET
TO YOU KNOW NEGLIGENCE THE SIZE
OF THE COMPANY. WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S A REPEAT OFFENDER HOW
SERIOUS THE VIOLATION IS- AND
WHETHER OR NOT. A VIOLATION WAS
A WAS WILLFUL WHETHER OR NOT
THE VIOLATION WAS ACCIDENT
RELATED THOSE ARE ALL OF FRIDAY
OF FACTORS THAT ARE THAT ARE
CONTAINED IN OUR- I REGULATION-
I BELIEVE THAT IS. THAT IT ON
AN OVERALL BASIS YOUR PROVIDES-
STRONG DETERRENTS THERE'S THIS
YOU KNOW THIS SOME OF THE
STRONGEST IN THE COUNTRY-
HOWEVER THERE ARE THEY ARE NOT-
YEAH THERE. AND I THINK THAT
THERE'S BEEN A LONG CRITICISM
OF- OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND ALL THESE. OUR
SYSTEM MASON WIDE WHICH IS THAT
YOU KNOW FOR SOME CASES AGAINST
VERY LARGE COMPANIES THEY ARE-
THEY PALE IN COMPARISON TO FOR
EXAMPLE PENALTIES- BY THE EPA
OR HER OTHER KIND OF
ENFORCEMENT. MECHANISMS I HAVE
NOT REALLY THOUGHT THROUGH UP-
YOU KNOW HOW TO DO WHAT WE
OUGHT TO BE DOING DIFFERENTLY-
BUT I CAN MAKE THAT
OBSERVATION- IN TERMS OF OUR
AUTHORITY WE HAVE AUTHORITY TO
ISSUE- IMMINENT HAZARD. ORDERS
PROHIBITING USES AYE AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE WE ALSO HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO ISSUE SPECIAL
ORDERS WHICH IS. AN ORDER FOR A
COMPANY TO COMPLY WITH A SENSE
OF STANDARDS THAT WE SET OUT
THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO THAT WORK
PLACE SO IF THERE IS NOT A-
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARD ON
THE BOOKS THAT'S APPLICABLES
SITUATION WE IDENTIFY. WE CAN
ISSUE A SPECIAL ORDER- AND YOUR
THOSE TOOLS ARE PRESENT FAILED
TO US AND- AND I BELIEVE CAN
CAN BE EFFECTIVE IN TERMS OF
PROPTHE PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT I HAVE. I HAVE. I STUDIED
AND I KNOW THAT- YOU KNOW
THERE'S CERTAINLY ALWAYS
SITUATIONS WHERE PEOPLE ARE
FRUSTRATED IF THEYARE LIMITED
TO THE WORKERS COMPENSATION
SYSTEM IN TERMS OF THEIR- IT'S
THEIR OF THEIR- GET IT OUT.
RIGHTS FAITH BUT THAT'S REALLY
S. I'M NOT REALLY QUALIFIED TO
OPINE ON THAT- AND I THINK THAT.
IT'S FOR THE BROADER DOES BUT
IT'S WORTH A BROADER DISCUSSION
ABOUT PRIVATE AG ACTIONS ON
SPECIFIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUES- YOU KNOW I DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT CONSISTENCY WITH
RESPECT TO WHAT WE DO VERSUS
WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN AND IN
PRIVATE RIGHTS OF ACTION BUT
THERE'S ALSO. SOME POSITIVES TO
AS WELL SO YOU KNOW WE WELCOME
A BROADER DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
PROS AND CONS THAT'S A QUITE
WHICH I'M TALKING ABOUT
APPRECIATE THAT LET ME GET TO
MY LAST QUESTION I'VE GOT
SEVERAL OF THE- I'LL JUST STOP
THE NEXT ONE. YOU KNOW WE ARE-
SIX MONTHS INTO THIS A LOT OF
THE- KNOWLEDGE- THAT WE ASSUMED
AT THE BEGINNING HAS BEEN- SORT
OF CHANGED I THINK WE'RE MORE A
LITTLE MORE SOPHISTICATED
LITTLE MORE IN WHAT WE KNOW AND
HOW WE UNDERSTAND THIS IS
MARCIN I'M WONDERING NOW THAT
WE ARE MOVING FORWARD. I AND
ARE GETTING INTO THE COLDER
SEASON WHERE BEING INSIDE OR WE
KNOW BEING OUTSIDE SEEMS TO
HAVE SOME POSITIVE IMPACT THE
PEOPLE ARE AGAIN MOVING BACK
INSIDE WE HAVE A FLU EPIDEMIC
COMING WHAT IS BEING DONE. TO
ADDRESS HOW TO DEAL WITH THIS
CODE SITUATION WHEN COMBINED
WITH THE FACT THAT THE FLU
SEASON IS UPON US OUR EFFORTS
BEING MADE TO ENCOURAGE OR TO
PROVIDE FOR EXAMPLE SLINGSHOTS-
FOR WORKERS PARTICULARLY IN A
CENTRAL- INDUSTRIES WHEN YOU
LOOK TO SEE WHAT THE SYMPTOMS
ARE CODE MANY OF THEM ARE
SIMILAR TO THE SYMPTOMS OF THE
COMMON COLD- SO ARE WE
ANTICIPATING THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE DOING MORE TESTING ARE WE
ANTICIPATING THAT THERE'S GOING
TO BE IN NEED. OF FOR ACCESS TO
BLUE CHANSEN ARE THOSE BEING
MADE AVAILABLE SO I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS MORE FOR- DOES KNOW.
THE ACTUAL PUBLIC HEALTH ARENA
CDPH AND ALL WHAT ARE YOU DOING
TO PREPARE. FOR THIS UPCOMING
FLU SEASON GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW
NOW ABOUT THE TRANSMITTAL OF
THIS VIRUS IT'S IMPACTS. AND
THAT AT INTO WITH THAT DEMO
THINK THE GOVERNOR BECAUSE IT
OFF. POSSIBILE WE THE FLU COME.
THANK THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION I'M WE HAVE. LONG THAT
WE YOU ADD FLUS ON TOP OF CODE
SYMPTOMS IT WILL COMPLICATE
THINGS GREATLY- AND- YOU KNOW
INCREASE THE DEMANDS OF
PROTESTING SORTING OUT WHO WHAT
WEAR DISEASE THAT PERSON REALLY
HOUSE AND ALL OF THAT. ON OUR
IMMUNIZATION BRANCH HAS BEEN
WORKING. FOR SEVERAL MONTHS
ALREADY- WITH US THE
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH BRANCH WITH
SOME CDC FLU EXTRA FLU FLU
GRANT MONEY TO OUR ROLL OUT OF
OUR REACH CAMPAIGN AND- I WORK
WITH. ON THE GROUND THEY THEY
EARLY ON RECOGNIZE THAT GETTING
FLU SHOTS- AVAILABLE AND
PROMOTED TO THOSE IN THE
ESSENTIAL WORKER JOBS IS REALLY
REALLY CRITICAL AND SO THEY
HAVE BEEN WERE ON ESTABLISHED
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS. COME UP
WITH A- WORKING WITH- OF THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AS
WELL WHO IMPLEMENT MUCH OF THE
FLU FLU VACCINATION I'M AT ALL
OF THIS WILL SERVICE WELL FOR
PLANNING FOR EVENTUAL
ADMINISTRATION OF THE COLORED
BACKS NATION AS WELL BECAUSE
IT'S GOING TO BE THE SAME.
WORKER GROUPS WHO ARE GOING TO
BE AT THE FRONT OF THE LINE OF
FOR THOSE VACCINATIONS ON. THE
TESTING FRONT. WE ARE ALSO ON
IN AS FAST CHANGING SITUATION
WHERE THE AVAILABILITY OF NEW
TASKS APID TESTS IT IS ALL
DONE DEVELOPING. AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT THEIR VERY CLOSELY-
STARTING TO- DETERMINE WHERE
INCREASED TESTING FOR
SURVEILLANCE PURPOSES IN
CERTAIN WORKER POPULATIONS WILL
BE WARRANTED AND- AND YOU KNOW.
WORKING OUT HOW THESE THESE
NEWER TESTS AS THEY GET
APPROVED BY THE FDA CAN BE USED
MORE IN WORKPLACES FOR- RAPID
IDENTIFICATION OF OUTBREAKS AND
PROBLEMS SO THAT WE CAN JUMP ON
THEM EARLIER. AND I HAVE
SOMETHING AS WELL AS BETTER
JACKSON AYE. IN TERMS OF YOU
KNOW ACTIONS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TAKING- WE
HAVE QUITE A BIT OF
COORDINATION HAPPENING BETWEEN
THE NUMBER OF STATE AGENCIES IN
TERMS OF PUBLIC AWARENESS AND
MEDIA CAMPAIGNS- YOU KNOW WE
WORK WITH CDPH EXTENSIVELY- AS
WELL AS LABOR AGENCY- CDSS IN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND- I
HAD THE FLU IS VERY MUCH ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT. WE ARE ACTIVELY
WORKING ON IT AS A PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION ACROSS ALL OF
OUR AGENCIES WILL BE
INCORPORATING THAT MESSAGE WITH
EXISTING MEDIA AND OUTREACH
EFFORTS. AND LET ME ASK POINT A
FOLLOW UP IF I MAY- THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER OR NOT WE
HAVE A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING
ABOUT. WHETHER GETTING THE FLU
MAKES YOU MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO
COLD IT- WHETHER IT EXACERBATES
IT WHETHER IT PRECLUDES IT DO
WE HAVE ANY SENSE OF WHAT THE
IMPACT COULD BE A PEOPLE- AGAIN
HAVING THEIR IMMUNE SYSTEMS- IN
ANYWAY MARGINALIZED OR
COMPROMISED. BY ONE OR THE
OTHER- DISEASES AND IF SO- HAVE
WE TAKEN STEPS- IN OUR HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES IN PREPARATION
FOR THE POSSIBILITY THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE SEEING MORE AND
MORE PEOPLE ARE HAVING SERIOUS
PROBLEMS AND BEING ADMITTED TO
HOSPITALS AND SO FORTH. THANK
YOU SENATOR JACKSON I THINK
THAT WOULD BE DIRECTED TOWARDS
OUR CD PH A DOCTOR MATERNA ARE
DOCTOR JACOBSON. I CAN I CAN-
STARTED OUT IN THIS COUNTRY HAS
ANYTHING TO ADD. PREPARING FOR
FLU SEASON IS IT IN OUR HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES IS SOMETHING
THAT IS. ALWAYS ALWAYS UNDER
WAY AT THIS TIME IN THE YEAR
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHAT AN IMPACT
IT CAN HAVE AND- FOR A COMBINED
FLUE PIPE PLUS COATED.
SITUATION OUR EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS OFFICE FOR EXAMPLE
WHICH OVERSEES ALL OF THE
DISTRIBUTION OF- MEDICAL AND
HEALTH SUPPLIES AND ALSO ON.
THE EFFORT TO IT TO. ENGAGE IN
WHAT THEY CALL SURGE PLANNING
ON IS ACTIVELY WORKING ON THIS
IT'S NOT AN AREA I'M AS
FAMILIAR WITH- YOU KNOW MY ROLE
WITHIN PAGE BUT I CAN TELL YOU
THAT THERE IS DEFINITELY
PLANNING THERE IS DEFINITELY
LOOKING AT THE METRICS TO.
IDENTIFY EARLY ON WHETHER THE
INCREASED IN ILLNESSES FROM
EITHER CALL IT OR FLU IS
IMPACTING OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM SO THAT IS DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT THAT- WE WILL BE
ON TOP OF. OKAY THANK YOU I
HAVE MANY MORE BUT I'M GOING TO
SEE TO MY NEXT CALLING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR EFFORTS THANK YOU SENATOR
JACKSON YES WE HAVE. ONE TWO
THREE FOUR MORE CENTERS THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK SOLVE- PASS
IT ON TO SENATOR MITCHELL AND
WE OF COURSE HAVE OUR NEXT
PANEL OF. WAITING FOR US SO
THANK YOU SENATOR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND WANT
TO JUST MAKE SURE THAT- SENATOR
JACKSON LIKE I HAVE ALREADY
GOTTEN HER FLU SHOTS WE CAN
LEAD BY EXAMPLE SENATE JACKSON.
DR JON SHAKING HIS HAND SO I'VE
GOT MINE ALREADY. ME TOO. GREAT
EXCELLENT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR JUST VERY QUICKLY AS I
LISTEN TO THE QUESTION FROM MY
COLLEAGUES AS I LISTEN TO- I
THINK WITH ANDREW JACKSON THAT
RAISED THE TRAGIC EXPERIENCE
WITH REGARD TO FOSTER FARMS
THAT THINKING ABOUT A
MANUFACTURING COMPANY IN MY OWN
DISTRICT. I'D LIKE TO KNOW.
ULTIMATELY WHAT STATE AGENCIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR INFORMING
WORKERS REGARDING THEIR RIGHTS
YOU KNOW- COLD ED AND WORKPLACE
SAFETY WORKPLACE SAFETY
EXPECTATIONS RUN COVERT ART ARE
NEW AND SO WHO HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WORKERS UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY SHOULD BE ENTITLED TO AND
WHO THEY- GO TO IF THOSE
PROTECTIONS ARE HAPPENING IN
THE WORKPLACE. I CAN I CAN TRY
TO ANSWER START TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION I THINK THE ANSWER IS
THAT D. A. R. PLAYS A LARGE
ROLE IN THAT- BUT- IT REALLY
IS- A COLLABORATIVE EFFORT
BETWEEN MULTIPLE AGENCIES
DEPENDING ON THEIR
JURISDICTION- WE HAVE IT KELLER
SAID. YOU KNOW WHO HAS A-
INCLUDES IN ALL OF THEIR
MESSAGING AROUND WORKER HEALTH
AND SAFETY- MESSAGING AROUND
EMPLOYEE RIGHT CENTER AND
DIRECTING THEM TO MORE
INFORMATION ON- VARIOUS AREAS
OF WORKERS RIGHT WE ALSO HAVE.
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
WITHIN THE I. R. THAT IS WHOSE
PRIMARY ROLE IS TO HAVE BY
SUPPORT WORKERS AND HOT AND
REPRESENTS THEM ON ON VARIOUS
ISSUES THAT THEY RAISED TO THE-
LABOR COMMISSIONER- THERE'S
RETALIATION UNITS- THERE'S
ENFORCEMENT UNIT WAGE CLAIM
ADJUDICATION SO WE HAVE- A
NUMBER OF FUNCTIONS THAT THEY
SUPPORT UNDER THE LABOR CODE-
SO WE HAVE. AGREES ROLES AND
TIED TO SPECIFIC JURISDICTION-
BUT FROM MY VANTAGE POINT-
LOOKING ACROSS THE STATE- YOU
KNOW EACH STATE AGENCY- HAS A
ROLE IN THIS AS WELL DEPENDING
ON THEIR OWN JURISDICTION- THE
END OF CV PH. ALSO WANTS TO
COMMENT ON THAT. I'LL JUST ADD
THE YEAH ALL OF THE GUIDE THE
WE'RE PUTTING OUT THERE PUTTING
UP ON OUR WAY. ENSURING THAT
WORKERS ARE INFORMED OF THEIR
RIGHTS IT IS BEING HIGHLIGHTED
ON IN THE INDUSTRY SPECIFIC
GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS WHERE WE
LIST OUT ALL THE- TRAINING-
THAT WORKERS HAVE TO DO. ABOUT
THE PLAYERS HAVE TO DO IT ALSO
INCLUDES- SOME OF THE NEW
RIGHTS UNDER THE COLLUDED-
FEDERAL LEGISLATION- FOR AND
STATE LEGISLATION THAT COVERS
SICK LEAVE AND THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS. HAVING WORKERS
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR RIGHTS
ARE IF THEY'RE IF THEY ARE TO
GET SICK IS REALLY CRITICAL IN
THIS. BATTLE AGAINST COATED. SO
I YOU KNOW I WOULD SAY WE ARE
ALL IN THIS TOGETHER WE ALSO
HAVE VARIOUS WAYS HOTLINES THAT
WORKERS CALL INTO AND THAT SORT
OF THING SO WE- DO TRY TO GIVE
OUT CONSISTENT MESSAGES AND
PLACES TO GO- TO. FILE
COMPLAINTS WITH THE
APPROPRIATE- AND TWO TEAMS
WHEN- THEY FEEL THEIR RIGHTS
AREN'T BEING ADDRESSED. IN IN
VERY QUICKLY- I THINK I
ANTICIPATED THAT ANSWER IT'S
AND IT LEADS TO A PART OF MY
CONCERN IN TERMS OF BECAUSE
THERE ARE SO MANY TOUCH POINTS
I HOPE THAT WORKERS DON'T
DIDN'T GET LOST KIND OF IN THE
SHUFFLE IF YOU WILL. LAST
QUESTION ON WHICH SHOULDN'T BE
A SURPRISE TO ANYONE COMING
FROM THE CHAIR THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. DO YOU THREE
AGENCIES FEEL THAT YOU ARE
APPROPRIATELY RESOURCE. GIVEN
THE NEW INTENSITY OF THE
RELEVANCE OF YOUR WORK
PARTICULARLY WITH REGARD TO
CALL OF IT EITHER IN THE-
WORKER. EDUCATION ELEMENT THAT
WE JUST TALKED ABOUT IN EVERY
ASPECT OF YOUR WORK DO YOU FEEL
YOUR PROPERLY RESOURCE. I'LL
START TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION-
I MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS- MY GRATITUDE TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND TO THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR. PROVIDING A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN- BOTH
STAFFING AND THE IN FUNDING- I
STARTED A D. I. R. AT THE TAIL
END OF THE BUDGET PROCESS AND-
AND- AT THE I GUESS THE
BEGINNING OF THE BUDGET CRISIS
AND- WAS CONCERNED THAT. WE
WOULD HAVE SIGNIFICANT
SHORTAGES IN RESOURCES BUT IN
FACT- YOU KNOW THE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT PUT FLOORS WERE.
REWARDED AND WE ARE I'M IN THE
PROCESS OF IMPLEMENTING- THE-
THE RESOURCES ASSOCIATED WITH
THE LAST BUDGET CYCLE- WE WERE
GIVEN ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
OUTREACH- OF THE LABOR AGENCY
ACTUALLY WHICH THE I. R. AS A
PART OF. BOB WAS GIVEN UP
SIGNIFICANT OUTREACH FUNDING
WHICH WILL BE HE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD- AND I WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS NOW OF PUTTING FORWARD-
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS TIED
TO. ALL OF THE BILLS THAT WERE
RECENTLY SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR- THAT RELATE TO OUR
JURISDICTION AT AT THE I. R.
THANK YOU. KIM IS TAKEN AND
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL FOR
THE QUESTIONS- NEXT WE'RE GONNA
GO TO WE JUST GONNA DO A LITTLE
BIT OF A LIGHTNING ROUND HERE
FOR OUR US SENATORS BUT THE
NEXT SENATORS CENTER TO RUSSELL
THANK YOU. I THINK ONE OF OUR
PANELISTS JUST O GIVE YOU SOME
pSECOND PANEL HAS TO LEAVE AT
THREE. THREE O'CLOCK. THANK
YOU- MADAM CHAIR. THE LATINO
CAUCUS HAS- ENGAGED A LOT WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT THE
DISPROPORTIONAL- SPREADING OF
THE VIRUS HAS BEEN IN THE
LATINO COMMUNITY BY TWENTY YOU
KNOW 1520% ABOVE THE
POPULATION- AND I JUST SO THIS
IS OF GRAVE CONCERN THE WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE WORKPLACE WHERE
THERE IS- AND INDUSTRIES AND
SECTORS THAT ARE ENORMOUS THE
ENORMOUSLY IMPACTED BUT WE ONLY
HAVE HEARD OF A FEW CASES. THEN
THOSE MEN AND WOMEN GO HOME TO
THEIR FAMILIES WHERE BECAUSE OF
THEIR LOW WAGES- FACE
OVERCROWDED NURSE- AND ARE
UNABLE IN THAT SITUATION TO DO
THE SOCIAL DISTANCING SO THERE
IS A- APPEARS TO BE I HAVEN'T
SEEN THE STUDY BUT IT APPEARS
TO BE A VERY DIRECT CONNECTION
BETWEEN WORKPLACE ENFORCEMENT.
AND BEING ABLE TO STOP THE
SPREAD IN OUR IN OUR
COMMUNITIES- SO. YOU MENTIONED.
MISTER PARKER ABOUT THE
REPORTING. THE REPORTING BY
EMPLOYERS AND IF THERE WAS TRUE
FREEDOM TO REPORT BY EMPLOYEES-
AND THAT TRUE FREEDOM TO
ENFORCE THE RIGHTS THAT THEY
KNOW THEY HAVE ON PAPER- THEN
THE NUMBERS OF THESE CASES THE
NUMBER OF POSITIVE CASES WE
PROBABLY WOULD BE MUCH HIGHER
YOU YOU SEEMED A LITTLE
SKEPTICAL AS TO THE NUMBERS OF
CASES THAT HAVE BEEN REPORTED-
IN YOUR OPINION SO AND I'M
GLAD- MISTAKEN- MENTIONED THE
ADDITIONAL- FUNDING THERE ARE
SOMETHING LIKE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS MORE TO DO WORKPLACE
EDUCATION AND WORKER
ENFORCEMENT SO. I HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS BUT CAN YOU JUST-
MAYBE MISS MISS HAGEN OR MISTER
PARKER DO YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS
WHATSOEVER ON HOW WE'RE GOING
TO INTENSIFY THE ENFORCEMENT
ASPECT OF- OF REPORTING AND
DOING SOMETHING ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE- THIS IS THIS IS MANY
MANY LIVES LIVES THAT HAVE BEEN
AT STAKE MANY MANY DEATHS AND
THEY'RE SPREADING IN OUR
COMMUNITY WE HAVE GOT TO TAKE
THIS AS MUCH MORE THAN A CRISIS
THIS IS A DOUBLE TRIPLE CRISIS
IN THE LATINO COMMUNITY SO. ANY
THOUGHTS ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE
GONNA DO TO REALLY UP THE ANTE
HERE WHICH IS WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE THANK YOU I CAN SPEAK TO
OUR RESPECT MAYBE- G. PARKER IF
I COULD ASK YOU TO SPEAK TO
ENFORCEMENT INITIALLY. START ON
TIME WELL FOR I'D SAY THAT I'M
A HUGE. IN THE IN OF EMPLOYEE.
UNEMPLOYED VOICE IN THE
WORKPLACE WHEN IT COMES TO
HEALTH AND SAFETY ISSUES WHEN
THEY ARE IN FACT YOU KNOW THE
KEY STAKEHOLDERS THAT THEIR-
THE MOST AT STAKE BY FAR WHEN
IT COMES TO- SOMEONE GETTING
INJURED OR KILLED ARE SAFE ON
THE JOB. AND SO- NO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I. DEFINITELY WANT
TO DO IN MY TIME HERE IS TO
EXPLORE HOW WE CAN. YOU KNOW
EXPAND THOSE- CONNECTIONS OF
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EMPLOYEES TO SPEAK UP. A WITH
RESPECT TO THE ISSUE OF-
INTENSIFICATION OF. OF
ENFORCEMENT- YOU KNOW WE HAVE.
TRIED TO FOCUS OUR EFFORTS ON-
INDUSTRIES WHERE THERE ARE LOW
WAGE IMMIGRANT WORKERS ONE OF
OUR CHALLENGES IS THAT. WE
OFTEN. DON'T GET GOOD
INFORMATION ABOUT THOSE
WORKPLACES FOR THE VERY REASONS
THAT YOU DESCRIBED- FOR EXAMPLE
WE'VE GOT WE'VE GOT MORE
INSPECTIONS IN AGRICULTURE.
THEN WE'VE RECEIVED COMPLAINTS
WHICH S AN INDICATOR OF THE
PROBLEM. AND SO- THAT'S AN
ISSUE WE'RE CONTINUE TO WORK ON
IT BUT I THINK WE'VE- NO
IDENTIFIED THERE IS A PROBLEM
WHEN EXPAND THAT- EXPAND THOSE
EFFORTS. THANK YOU MISTER
PARKER SENATOR GRASSO DID YOU
HAVE ANY OTHER FOLLOW UP. I DO
BUT I KNOW YOU'RE PRESSED FOR
TIME SO MAYBE AT THE END I
COULD- ADD SOME MORE YES WE CAN
ABSOLUTELY DO THAT- AND I WILL
MOVE THEN TO THANK YOU FOR
THAT. I WILL MOVE ON TO SENATOR
DODD. YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR- I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE SPEAKERS- AND THEIR
INFORMATION THEY GIVE US TODAY
AS A FORMER- EMPLOYEE YOU'RE A
BUSINESSMAN I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FIRST OF ALL SAY
STRAIGHT UP- THE EMPLOYEES HAVE
TO BE TAKEN CARE OF AND- I
APPRECIATE THE NEW ENFORCEMENT
THINGS ARE GOING ON. IN THAT
REGARD BUT I THINK IT'S THEIR
NEIGHBOR AND FRANKLY I HAVE NO
ROOM FOR COMPANIES THAT ARE
NEGLIGENT OR DO NOT COOPERATE-
WITH EITHER COUNTY STATE COUNTY
OR STATE. OFFICIALS BUT THAT
SAID I JUST KIND OF INTERESTED
IN WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT THE
FACT THAT LOOK AT THIS IS A
NEW. THIS EVERYTHING COULD NOT
BE SOLVED PARTICULARLY WHEN
WORD A PANDEMIC THAT WE'VE
NEVER GONE THROUGH THE PUBLIC
NEVER GONE THROUGH THIS BEFORE
THE GOVERNMENT'S NEVER GOT WILL
BEFORE THE GOVERNMENT'S NEVER
GOT THROUGH THIS CERTAINLY
STAND IN RECENT RECENT TYPES SO
WE DON'T THIS IS NOT LIKE AN
INDUSTRIAL ACCIDENT THAT YOU'RE
GOING OUT. AND INVESTIGATING IN
MY VIEW YOU KNOW WHERE WE ARE
TESTING YOUR TESTING SITUATIONS
WHAT WE HAVE TSTING BUT NO WE
DON'T HAVE IT FOR THESE
SITUATIONS. YEAH AND THIS
REALLY WENT ON THROUGHOUT THE
SUMMER AS WELL MA'AM WE HAVE
TESTING AND WE HAVE TESTING
TURN AROUND SIR CHIU IN THREE
OR. FOUR WEEKS LONG CURRENT
LAWS THAT. HAVE BEEN IN.
BETWEEN AND STATE CERTAINLY. A
FEDERAL BIG I ONLY THEY GOT IT.
IN YOU KNOW SO I REALLY
CONCERNED THAT. EASY TO TAKE
MIGHT BE SAY OKAY LET'S DOA
PRIOR PROPRIETOR RIGHT ACTIONS
OF THESE TYPE THINGS BUT- THE
REALITY IS- YOU KNOW. WHAT IS
LOOKED AT YOU IN THIS THE
SITUATION SEN YOUR FRANKLY FROM
A BUSINESS STANDPOINT TO GET
THOSE THAT ARE NOT DOING THE
JOB AND AB NEGLIGENCE. NO ROOM
FOR THAT BUT I IDEA I D. JUST
HARD FOR ME TO BELIEVE THAT-
EMPLOYERS. JUST ACROSS THE
BORDER JUST ABUSING THEIR
EMPLOYEES THE SITUATION BASED
ON WHAT I'VE SEEN OVER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS IN BUSINESS AND
TWENTY YEARS OF PUBLIC. THANK
YOU SENATOR DODD INDEED YOU
HAVE- WAS OUR QUESTION DIRECTED
TO A SPECIFIC PANELIST. WELL I
JUST THINK SOMEBODY LOGIN TO
YOUR SKIN MISTER PARKER YOU
KNOW I MEAN IT'S A NEW YEAR YOU
NEED AND YOU GOT TO BE LOOKING
AT THOSE TYPE OF THINGS TO. OF
COURSE YEAH SO- THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION SENATOR. THERE WAS
THERE'S BEEN A PROGRESS A
PROGRESSION OF OUR ACTIVITY.
YOU KNOW WE REALLY STARTED WITH
EDUCATING EMPLOYERS AND WORKERS
WE PUT OUT ALL THAT A GUIDANCE
INFORMATION. WE DID A LOT OF
OUTREACH TO EDUCATE- EMPLOYERS
TO ADDRESS THIS FUNDAMENTAL
FAIRNESS QUESTION THAT YOU-
THAT YOU ASK. YEAH FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN MY CAREER WE HAD
EMPLOYERS COMING TO US. SAYING
TELL US EXACTLY WHAT TO DO WE
WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE RULES ARE.
EXACTLY AND SO WE ENDEAVOR TO
DO THAT- WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
COMPLIANCE ASSISTANCE FOR THAT
VERY REASON YOU KNOW WE'VE
KNOCKED ON THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF DOORS TO OFFER MY
ASSISTANCE TO EMPLOYERS. AND
I'LL ALSO ADD THAT YOU KNOW
WHEN WE RESPOND TO COMPLAINTS
BY. A LETTER INVESTIGATION- IN
MOST CASES UNLESS IT'S VERY
SERIOUS. WELL WE GIVE THEM THE
OPTION ANY OF RESPONDING TO
THE- TO THE TO THE QUESTIONS
AND IT JUST SO WE CAN DETERMINE
WHETHER A CONDUCTOR COULD
ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATION. OR
THEY CAN CHOOSE COMPLIANCE
ASSISTANCE IF THEY HAVE OUR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE I GUESS
THE RIGHT WORDS CONSULTATION.
AND IN OUR VERNACULAR THAT THEY
CAN SEE COMPLIANCE ASSISTANCE
SHOCKINGLY FEW- TAKE THAT
OPTION MOST OF THEM. RESPOND TO
THAT- YOU TAKE THE AVENUE THAT
RESULTS. IN THE ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS. BUT WE'VE TRIED TO
ADDRESS THAT THE- KIND
PROGRESSION OF HOW WE I'M TAKEN
ON THIS ISSUE. I APPRECIATE
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD AND WE
HAVE SENATOR UMBERG NEXT. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST A TWO
QUESTIONS- I BELIEVE TO A
DOCUMENT TURNOUT CONCERNING
TESTING ONE IF WE'RE GOING TO
REQUIRE. ADDITIONAL TESTING IN
THE WORKPLACE TO INCREASE ITS
STATE WHAT'S ARE TESTING
CAPACITY NUMBER ONE AND THEN
NUMBER TWO IN TERMS OF THE
TURNAROUND TIME BETWEEN- THE
TIME THE TEST AND THE TIME OF
THE RESULTS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER QUARANTINING OR
ISOLATIONIST IS NECESSARY.
THANK YOU I THINK BOUNCE THAT
CAMPING JACOBSON IF SHE'S STILL
ON. YES DR JACOBSON. YEAH HI-
THANK YOU SENATOR I'M BURNED
I'M DOCTOR JACOBSON FROM THE
TESTING TASK FORCE AND YOUR
FIRST QUESTION WAS- WHAT'S ARE
TESTING CAPACITY AND- FOR
CALIFORNIA CAPACITY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY IS ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED. THOUSAND TELL US
THE DATE AND WE NEARLY REACH
THAT CAPACITY I ONCE OR TWICE
AT ABOUT A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND TESTS PER DAY- HOWEVER
I CALIFORNIA IS. DEVELOPING AND
PREPARING TO OPEN ITS OWN STATE
LOUD AND- THAT'S BEING DONE IN
COLLABORATION WITH PERKINELMER
AND THAT LAB IS SCHEDULED TO
OPEN IN THE BEGINNING OF
NOVEMBER. AT ABOUT FORTY
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL TESTS PER
DAY WITH THE ABILITY TO EXPAND
UP TO A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL TESTS PER
DAY- AND WOULD BE. EXPECTATION
THAT THAT EXPANSION OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND TONS
PER DAY. WILL OCCUR BY MARCH
AND NICK YEAR. HI IN.
COLLABORATION WITH THAT THERE'S
AN ARGUMENT TO THAT IS- BEING
REVIEWED AT THIS TIME THE TOP
THREE CANDIDATES LOOKING AT
CREATIVE MEANS FOR- SPECIMEN
COLLECTION. THAT WILL THEN BE
SENT TO THAT LAB IN THOSE
CREATIVE MEANS ARE TO ENSURE
THAT WE- CAN REACH AN ACCESS. I
SEE INDIVIDUALS MOST AT NEED
FOR TESTING. THAT WAS YOUR
FIRST QUESTION. I MEAN JUST ASK
QUICK FOLLOW ON TO THAT
QUESTION. I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE
NEED IS DO YOU HAVE AN
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT THE EMPLOYER
NEEDS WOULD BE AND THEN WHEN WE
WILL BE ABLE TO MEET THAT NEED.
THERE ARE GREAT SO. THE TESTING
TASK FORCE HAS BEEN. WORKING
AND WE'RE REALLY IN THE FINAL
STAGE. OF THE SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE BASED ON STRATEGIC
TESTING CLAMP. LOOKING AT OUR
TESTING FREQUENCY ON VARIOUS
WORKER CO COURTS AND THEN
ESTIMATING THE NUMBER OF BOTH
PCR TESTING. AND IMAGING
TESTING THAT WOULD BE NEEDED TO
MEET. ME AND I. TIMING AS TO
WHEN WE WILL. LIKELY MEET THAT
NEED. YOU KNOW I THINK THAT
WILL. IT BECAUSE THAT WOULD
NEED TO BE SOME GUIDANCE IS
WRITTEN TO. NEED TO THAT OUR
STRATEGIC PLAN. ONCE IT'S
APPROVED I THINK THAT ONCE THE
PERKINELMER LAB OPENS UP WERE
WILL ALREADY BE IN PRETTY GOOD
POSITION TO MEET MOST OF THE
NEEDS I'D SAY ABOUT. I DON'T
KNOW SOMEONE AROUND 75% OF THE
NEEDS COME NOVEMBER ONE ONCE WE
EXPAND TO. THE FULL CAPACITY OF
THE LAB WILL EXCEED THE PCR
NEEDS. IN ADDITION TO THAT ARE
JUST THIS WEEK HI WE BEGAN TO
RECEIVE. SOME OF THE NEW
ANTIGEN TESTS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA'S ANTICIPATING
RECEIVING. ON A PER CAPITA
BASIS EIGHT PERCENTAGE
PROXIMATE LI 10% OF A HUNDRED
MILLION TASKS- BETWEEN NOW AND
THE END OF DECEMBER- IMAGING
TESTS AND THERE'S AN ENGINE
TESTS ARE BEST USED FOR
SYMPTOMATIC INDIVIDUALS. WITHIN
A WEEK OF SYMPTOM ONSET SO
WE'RE ALSO ACCOUNTING FOR
WEARING WINDOWS TEST WOULDBE
USED WITHIN THAT TOTAL-
ESTIMATES OF. AN ENGINE IN PCR
TESTING. IF YOU'RE I HAVE WELL
I AS SOME BE TO DO FORM THERE'S
NO QUESTION WAS IN TERMS TURN
AROUND TIME WITH HITS SUCH
LENGTHY TURNAROUND TIMES IT
OFTEN THAT THE TESTS AREN'T
THAT USEFUL IN TERMS OF KEEPING
THE WORK. SAFE JUST WONDERING
IF THERE'S ANY. UPDATE ON THAT.
YEAH IS IT AND JUST TO SORT OF
BACK UP SOME OF THAT. I LONG
TURNAROUND TIME THAT WAS
HAPPENING IN JULY I WAS THE
RESULT I WAS- BASICALLY ACROSS
THE COUNTRY INCREASED DEMAND
FOR TESTING AND A LOT OF THE
TESTS BEING- SENT TO THE SAME
FEW LABS ACROSS THE COUNTRY'S
OF THOSE LARGE LABS WERE
EXCEEDING THEIR CAPACITY. BY
FORTY TO FIFTY THOUSAND JUST A
DAY ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND SO
THAT WAS PLAYING INTO SOME OF
THOSE FOR A LONG TURNAROUND
TIMES BUT THE TESTING TASK
FORCE HAS IMPLEMENTED THE
METRIC FOR TRACKING TURNAROUND
TIME. AND DEVELOP THE DASHBOARD
AND I CAN TELL YOU FOR THE LAST
WEEK- IN 92% OF OUR TESTS HAVE
A TURNAROUND TIME OF LESS THAN
TWO DAYS IN SIXTY NINE PERCENT.
IN LESS THAN ONE DAY- AND
THAT'S BEEN PRETTY CONSISTENT
FOR THE LAST FEW WEEKS NOW.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A DOCTOR JACOBSON CENTER-
BURKE PRESHEAF THAT AND SO- I
HAVE A QUESTION I WILL LEAVE IT
TO THE END BECAUSE WE ARE GOING
TO GET INTO OUR SECOND PANEL WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HEAR THE
VOICES OF OUR WORKERS- BUT JUST
TO PUT A PIN IN AND WHAT I WAS
GOING TO MENTION WAS THE
SPECIFICS ON INVESTIGATION
PERIOD- I JUST WOULD LIKE TO.
TO KNOW THAT AS TO WHEN IT
STARTS AND WHEN IT ENDS AND ALL
THE DETAILS IN BETWEEN SO WITH
THAT SAID WE WILL MOVE ON TO
OUR SECOND PANEL. AND THE
WITNESSES HERE HAVE BEEN
ALLOCATED ABOUT FOUR MINUTES
EACH FOR THEIR PRESENTATIONS
OUR FIRST PRESENTER IN OUR AND
OUR FINAL PANEL IS AMBER BAUER
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
U. OF C. W. UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS FOR WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL WELCOME IS
BARREN THANK YOU. FOR JOINING
US AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. THANK YOU SO FOR HAVE
ME I AM AMBER BALLARD. DIRECTOR
FOR YOU. STUDENT WORKERS
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL. I JUST
WHEN I THINK THE CHAIR AND THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING. DISCUSSES
VERY IMPORTANT AND INCREDIBLY
TIMELY TOPIC OF WORKPLACE
HEALTH AND SAFETY DURING THE
CALL THE NINETEENTH HAD DONE
THAT- AND JUST THANK YOU TO THE
ENTIRE PANEL- THAT JUST WENT
BEFORE. BECAUSE WE REALLY HAVE
WORKED CLOSELY TOGETHER WITH
DIRECTOR HAGEN CHIEF PARKER.
AND CDPH DR MATERNA WHO HAS
REALLY BEEN TIRELESSLY WORKING
TO PROTECT WORKERS DURING THIS
VERY UNPRECEDENTED- PANDEMIC- I
REALLY ALSO WANT TO. HIGHLIGHT
THAT AND APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION OUTLINING THE VAST
CHALLENGES THAT WE ARE ALL
FACING. IN PARTICULAR TO THE
DISCUSSION AROUND EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY FIVE WHICH UFCW
SPONSORED AND WE BELIEVE IT'S
CRITICAL. TO OUR WORK AND
PROTECTING WORKERS FROM
WORKPLACE ILLNESS- INCLUDING
KOBE NINETEEN. WE REPRESENT
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA-
NEARLY EVERY POINT IN THE FOOD
CHAIN. MANY OF THE SECTORS MOST
IMPACTED BY CURRENT NINETEEN
ARE AREAS WE REPRESENT WORKERS
INCLUDING GROCERY STORES MEAT
PACKING FOOD PRODUCTION
AGRICULTURE. HEALTH CARE. AND
FOOD DELIVERY DRIVERS. I'M WE
ALL KNOW THE ISSUE ARE HERE AND
THEY WERE DETAILED VERY CLEARLY
IN THE QUESTIONS FROM THE
SENATORS WORKERS ARE FACING A
HEALTH AND SAFETY CRISIS THAT
IS COSTING THEM THEIR LIVES AND
THE LIVES OF THEIR FAMILIES.
THESE ARE WORKERS TO KEEP OUR
GROCERY SHELVES STOCKED THEY
GROW AND PROCESS OUR FOOD AND
THEY KEEP OUR ECONOMY RUNNING.
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND OUR
MEMBERS ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY COULD NINETEEN
OUTBREAKS. AND ARE IN
COMMUNITIES LATINO BLACK
IMMIGRANT WOMEN IN LOW WAGE
WORKERS. THE PROBLEM HERE IS
NOT NEIL WORKERS LACK POWER IN
THE WORKPLACE. OFF THE BOARD
THEY LACK SUFFICIENT POWER TO
BE ABLE TO ASSERT AND ENFORCE
THE RIGHT. THIS IS HARD EVEN AT
UNION WORK SITE BUT IT'S ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE A NONUNION
WORKPLACE. PLACES WE'VE SEEN
THIS FIRST HAND IN EVERY SECTOR
AND NOTABLY IN MEAT PACKING
WHICH WAS DISCUSSED EARLIER.
WORKERS RIGHTS ARE NOT
MEANINGFUL IF THEY CANNOT BE
ENFORCED. THE PROBLEMS THAT
WERE SEEN EXACERBATED BY THE
COULD NINETEEN CRISIS- WE'VE
HEARD COUNTLESS STORIES OF
EMPLOYERS NOT FOLLOWING
PROTOCOL EMPLOYERS NOT
NOTIFYING WORKERS OF WORK PLACE
EXPOSURE WORK WORKERS NOT BEING
TOLD ABOUT THEIR SICK LEAVE
RATES EMPLOYERS NOT ENFORCING
DISTANCING. STANDARDS WORKERS
NOT HAVING PP PROPER
VENTILATION OR IN DURING
CROWDED AREAS LIKE THE TIME
CLOCK WHEN THEY PENSION OR
BREAK ROOMS AND A REMINDER THAT
WE ARE NOT SET UP TO BE ABLE TO
HANDLE MANY OF THESE.
REQUIREMENTS SO WE HAD TO
RESPOND AND THINK AND COLUSA
FOR REALLY GETTING GUIDANCE OUT
FAIRLY QUICKLY BUT WE HAVE TO
REALLY ENFORCE BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT LIKE- AT A HOSPITALOR
SOMEWHERE ELSE WHERE THE YOU
ARE USED TO EXPOSURE. THE LACK
OF ENFORCEMENT AND THERE HAS
BEEN SLOW AND FORCE MET WORKERS
NEED EDUCATION ON THEIR RIGHTS
IN THE WORKPLACE AND HOW TO
BRING FORWARD A COMPLAINT. YOU
NEED TO KNOW THEIR RIGHTS
REPORT VIOLATIONS TO CALIFORNIA
THE CHALLENGE HERE AND IT'S I
THINK THAT FOR MANY REASONS AS
DOUG MENTIONED BUT IT THE
PROCESS TAKES SO LONG SO WE
HAVE WORKERS REPORTING WORK.
WORKPLACE VIOLATIONS IN ISSUES
BUT IT HAS TAKEN MONTHS. I
THINK I'M AN ISSUE THAT WE
HEARD A LITTLE BIT- FROM
SENATOR DRAW ALSO IS
RETALIATION. WORKPLACE PROBLEMS
ARE COMPOUNDED BY THE THREAT OF
RETALIATION AGAINST WORKERS WHO
SPEAK OUT. WHICH HAS A CHILLING
EFFECT ON WORKERS SPEAKING UP.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN THE ENFORCEMENT
IT'S REALLY COMPLAINT DRIVEN
RATHER THAN TARGETED AND BASED
ON RISK FOR VIOLATIONS. AN
EXAMPLE OF THIS IS AT ONE OF
OUR STORES ITS STORE BY STORE
COMPLAINT DRIVEN INSTAD OF- AN
ISSUE THAT WE MAY SEE FOR AN
ENTIRE FOR AN EMPLOYER IN THE
STATE. SOME OF THE SOLUTIONS
THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED AND ARE
WORKING AND TO PROMOTE IS
REALLY EMPOWERING WORKERS THE
BEST WAY TO PROTECT THEM IS TO
EMPOWER THEM. THE NEW A TO KNOW
THERE WORK THEY KNOW THEIR
WORKPLACES BETTER THAN ANYONE
ELSE THEIR ON SITEDALY THERE
IMMEDIATELY IDENTIFY AND STOP
UNSAFE WORK CONDITIONS. THEY
CAN REPRT CASES AND DEVELOP
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
WORKPLACE AND THE INDUSTRY TO
PROTECT WORKERS AND THE PUBLIC.
WE NEED POLICIES THAT INCREASE
WORKERS ROLE IN THE WORKPLACE
WE NEED TO PUT IN PLACE LAWS
AND REGULATIONS THAT SUPPORT
WORKERS TAKING ON AN ACTIVE
ROLE AND HEALTH AND SAFETY AT
THE WORKPLACE. AND THIS REALLY
COMES THROUGH ORGAN ORGANIZING.
WE ALSO NEED A RAPID AND
EFFECTIVE ENFORCEMENT OF THE
EXISTING LAWS. WE NEED RAPID
ENFORCEMENT FROM KELLER SAID TO
CONTAIN OUTBREAKS AND PROTECT
WORKERS WE NEED IN PERSON
INSPECTIONS TO SHOW EMPLOYERS
COMPLIANCE IS IMPORTANT. WE
NEED TO INCREASE PENALTIES TO
CREATE TRUE DETERRENT FOR BOTH
VIOLATED HEALTH AND SAFETY LAWS
RETALIATION AGAINST WORKERS WHO
SPEAK UP. RAPID RESPONSE TEAMS
WHO EVEN OUR WE'LL JUST HAVE
YOU WRAP UP IF YOU DON'T MIND
THANK YOU- SHOULD WRAP IT IN
FOR AND RAPID RESPONSE THIS IS
AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT WE TALK
ABOUT TARGETED ENFORCEMENT
BASED ON SIX EIGHTY FIVE. AND
WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT THERE
THERE SHOULD BE NEW POLICIES
FOR WORKER HEALTH AND SAFETY-
STRENGTHEN ANTI RETALIATION
WITH WHISTLE BLOWING AND FORCE
SIX EIGHTY FIVE FORMATION OF
WORKERS COUNCILS FOR WORKERS TO
BE AT THE TABLE AND DESIGNING
INDUSTRY SPECIFIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY REGULATIONS. AND BE ABLE
TO ENFORCE THOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE THAT AS
WELL. NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM ANY
BETTER FERNANDEZ WITH THE
UNITED FARM WORKERS FOUNDATION
WELCOME MR FERNANDES. THANK YOU
HI GOOD AFTERNOON I'M I'M A BIT
OF AN AND THIS ON THE SIDE OF
PALMER. AND ALSO AN ADVOCATE
WITH THE UFW FOUNDATION. IT IS
SAID THAT THE CRISIS HIGHLIGHTS
THE BEST AND WORST IN PEOPLE
AND THIS IS TRUE FOR PEOPLE.
AND AS IT IS FOR LEADERS AND
OUR STATE AS A WHOLE.
FARMWORKERS SEE THAT KINDA MAKE
AYE SHEDDING LIGHT ON A TALE OF
TWO CALIFORNIA'S. THERE ARE
FARMWORKERS AND THEN. THERE'S A
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL. CAN IS LEAD.
THE LEADING AGRICULTURE STATE
IN THE- AND HOME TO THE LARGEST
NUMBER OF FARMWORKERS. BUT BY
THESE NUMBERS YOU MAY THINK
THAT CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURE
IS FLOURISHING. IT IS
FLOURISHING. BUT JUST NOT FOR
FARMWORKERS. HERE THE FACTS.
FARMWORKERS ARE UNDOCUMENTED-
ENDING IN THE STATE THEY DON'T
QUALIFY FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE THEY DON'T QUALIFY
FOR PERMANENT SICK PAY. OR FOR
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. FARMWORKERS ARE NOT
CONSIDERED FOR STATE HAZARD PAY
DESPITE WORKING ONE OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS JOBS IN THE COUNTRY.
A FORMER FAMILY MAKES TWENTY
THOUSAND TO TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND A YEAR. AND KIDS AS
YOUNG AS TWELVE YEARS OLD.
COULD WORK IN THE FIELDS JUST
LIKE I DID. MANY FARMWORKERS
ARE PAID UNDER THE TABLE AND
CHEATED OUT OF THEIR WAGES. AND
THEN WE AND THEN WE CONTINUE TO
ALLOW COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA
TO SHUT DOWN AND START OVER
WHEN THEY REFUSED TO PAY. UNDER
THE FEDERAL H. TWO A. VISA
PROGRAM GUEST WORKERS ARE AN
INDENTURED SERVANTS AND OUR
STATE'S HOUSING CODE ALLOWS FOR
ERIC STAAL HOUSING JUST
SUBSIDIZED THE OPPRESSION OF
PEOPLE. WELL PERFORMING
BACKBREAKING WORK TO FEED THE
NATION FARMWORKERS ARE EXPOSED
TO EXTREME HEAT DANGEROUS
PESTICIDES THE RISK OF KOBE
NINETEEN AND HARMFUL AIR NOW
BECAUSE OF THE WILDFIRES. THE
WORKING EVACUATION ZONES WITH
NO MASKS IN THE NAME OF SAVING
COMMODITY FROM THE FIRE WHILE
MANY FACE FOOD INSECURITY AT
HOME. NOW WE HAVE TO ASK
OURSELVES AND YOU HAVE TO ASK
YOURSELF. WITH ALL THE PUBLIC
STATEMENTS ABOUT WHAT HAS BEEN
DONE FOR FARMWORKERS. WIRE THE
STILL THE FAX. AS WE SIT HERE
TODAY. WHY IS THERE SUCH A
DISPARITY IN POWER IN INCOME
AND HEALTH COVERAGE IN WORKING
CONDITIONS AND IN THE LAWS NOT
THE GOVERNOR STATE'S
AGRICULTURAL SYSTEM. LIKE OTHER
HISTORIC INJUSTICES THE SYSTEM
IS NOT BROKEN. RATHER THE
AGRICULTURAL SYSTEM IS DESIGNED
TO KEEP FARMWORKERS FROM EVER
RECEIVING THE ECONOMIC
RECOGNITION THEY DESERVE. WE
OFFER THE FOLLOWING FARMWORKERS
NEED CHANGES IN THE EXISTING
STATE PROCESS FOR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING ELECTIONS SO THAT
WOULD FARMWORKERS ORGANIZED
THEY CAN LIFT THEMSELVES UP AND
GO SHOOT FOR THEMSELVES THE
CURRENT VOTING AND ELECTION
PROCESS IS MEANT TO SUPPRESS
VOTES AND THE NINE OUTCOMES ALL
TO PERPETUATE THE ECONOMIC
REPRESSION THAT HAS EXISTED
SINCE THE DAYS OF SLAVERY. IT
MUST CHANGE AND WE SHOULD BE
LEADING THE TRAINS THE CHANGER.
ADDITIONALLY FARMWORKERS ARE
CONSISTENTLY WRITTEN OUT OF
STATE LAWS THAT LEADERS
THEMSELVES NEGOTIATE. WE NEED
LEADERS AT PRIORITIZE HUMANS AS
MUCH AS THEY PRIORITIZE
COMMODITIES. THAT WOULD ALLOW
WORKERS TO BE PROTECTED WHILE
TAKING WINE GRAPES AND INSPIRES
ARMS WILL REVIEW THE LAWS THAT
THEY'RE NEGOTIATING AND ASK
THEMSELVES IF THESE LAWS ARE A
BENEFITS FARMWORKERS. AND WILL
ALSO ENFORCE CURRENT LAWS TO
ENSURE THAT THE FINES ARE.
COLLECTED NOT JUST ISSUE. THE
ESSENTIAL WORKER DESIGNATION
DOESN'T MEAN THAT FARMWORKERS
GET PROTECTIONS THE
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY HAS
RECEIVED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
KOBE NINETEEN LEGISLATION AND
YET WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR
MASKS FOR SAFE DISTANCING
PRACTICES THAT WORK FOR BASIC
SANITATION SUPPLIES FOR KOBE
NINETEEN SCREENING AND FOR
CLEAN PORTABLE BATHROOMS. WE
HOPE YOU CAN JOIN US AS WE LOOK
TO CHANGE THE SYSTEMIC
INJUSTICES BUILT IN OUR
EXISTING LAWS AND THINK AND-
THINK OF US WHEN YOU WRITE THE
NEXT SET OF LAWS THAT AFFECT
FARMERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR FERNANDES WE
APPRECIATE THAT. AND NOW WE'LL
HEAR FROM NOR HUNTLEY A
CERTIFIED NURSE ASSISTANT AT A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY IN
OAKLAND- MISS HUNTLEY. HELLO
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
NORMAN UNITED BEEN A CERTIFIED
NURSE ASSISTANT AT A SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY FOR OVER A
DECADE WHERE THE FRONTLINE
CAREGIVERS WHO PROVIDED THE
LION'S SHARE OF DIRECT PATIENT
CARE NURSING HOMES. FROM
ASSISTING WITH ALL ASPECTS OF
NUTRITION AND HYGIENE TO
MANAGING MEDICATIONS COMP
DISEASES AND INJURY PREVENTION
OUR WORK IS VERY DIFFICULT VERY
PERSONAL AND VERY HANDS ON AND
REQUIRES A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
COMPASSION AND CARE. FOR MANY
OF OUR RESIDENTS WE ALONG WITH
OTHER RESIDENTS OTHER STAFF OR
THE ONLY PEOPLE THEY WERE SO
THEY WILL SEE OR INTERACT WITH
AT ALL AND THAT'S CERTAINLY
BEEN TRUE FOR ALL THE RESIDENTS
DURING THE GOLDEN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. WELL I HAVE BEEN ON
MATERNITY LEAVE FOR SEVERAL
MONTHS AS A SHOP STEWARD I HAVE
KEPT IN CONTACT WITH MY DIRECT
COLLEAGUES AS AN ACTIVIST IN MY
UNION SEIU LOCAL TWENTY
FIFTEEN. I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
NURSING HOME MEMBERS ACROSS THE
BAY AREA IN THE ENTIRE STATE TO
STAND UP FOR OUR OWN IN OUR
PATIENTS RIGHTS AND OUR SAFETY.
TODAY I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES STORIES
AND EXPERIENCES DURING THIS
CHALLENGING TIME WHEN SO MANY
OF OUR RESIDENTS AND COLLEAGUES
HAVE BEEN STICKING. WORKERS IN
NURSING HOMES ARE ALL. WOMEN
PEOPLE OF. MANY OF THEM
IMMIGRANTS. THE OUR SOCIETY
VALUES US IN OUR- IS IMPORTANT
PART OF FIRST. IT'S WHY WE'VE
BEEN EXPOSED TO SUCH YOU DRESS
AND THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE. AT TWO
OF THE FACILITIES I'M
PERSONALLY CONNECTED TO MORE
THAN TEN NURSING HOME WORKERS
HAVE COULD. HAVE CONTRACTED
CALLED IN NINETEEN. ALL OF THEM
FORTUNATE ARE STILL ALIVE. BUT
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED A LOT OF
DISTRESS. YEAH SO ISOLATED FROM
THEIR FAMILIES THEY HAD A
LITTLE SUPPORT WHEN THEY WERE
MOST AFRAID. MANY OF THEM ARE
NOW REPORTING LONG TERM
EFFECTS. IN THE SAME FACILITIES
WORKERS REPORT REALLY
PROBLEMATIC AND INCONSISTENT
APPROACHES TO WORKERS AND
PATIENT SAFETY. IN ONE FACILITY
DEPARTMENT HAS ALWAYS HAD PP.
BUT C. N. A.'S WHO DIRECTLY
WORK WITH THE PATIENTS IN
CHARGE NURSES HOUSEKEEPERS.
FREQUENTLY WENT WITHOUT THEM.
TRAINING OF HOUSEKEEPING STAFF
FROM PP USE INSPECTION CONTROLS
AND CONSISTENT A LONG DELAYED-
ONE CALLING EVEN REPORTED THAT
WORKERS WHO STARTED THEIR SHIFT
IN THE MORNING AT SEVEN. WE HAD
TO WAIT UNTIL DEPARTMENT HEADS
CAME. IN AT EIGHT OR NINE AM.
TO GET PEOPLE AVAIL TO THEM.
OTHER CALL REPORT THERE WERE
ALL SHORTAGE OF REPEAT UNTIL
THE STATE UP. AND LIKE MAGIC
OKAY OF PETE. ONE OF MY UNION.
FROM BEACH MARIA. BASS WORK
THROUGHOUT THE KINGDOM UNTIL
HER. RESULTS CAME BACK POSITIVE
IN JULY. SHE AND HER COLLEAGUES
WORKING WITH ORDINARY SURGICAL
MASK NOT SUFFICIENT TO PROTECT
THEM. SHE HER HUSBAND HER SON
AND DAUGHTER IN LAW AND TO
BRING KIDS ALL GOT SICK. HER
HUSBAND ALMOST DIDN'T MAKE IT
HE WAS IN THE HOSPITAL FOR
TWENTY TWO DAYS INTUBATED AND
STRUGGLING TO HANG ON TO LIFE.
WONDER WHY SOME CALM ARE MORE.
THAN OTHERS. LOOK NO FURTHER
THAN THIS EXAMPLE MULTIPLE
GENERATIONS WAS STRICKEN BY THE
DISEASE CARRIED BY ONE
UNPROTECTED FRONTLINE WORKERS.
ANOTHER UNION SISTER NOBLE
NICOLE MARZANO WORSEN IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FACILITY
WHERE PP WAS RUSSIAN WERE COLD
AND ON CALL. PATIENTS WERE NOT
SEPARATED WILL WORKERS
INCLUDING HERSELF FORSAKEN.
DOES HAD SOMETHING SHE WAS TOLD
TO CONTINUE COMING TO WORK JUST
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE A FEVER.
MY COLLEAGUES REPORT CONFUSING
CONFLICTING AND CONSTANTLY
CHANGING RULES PROCESSES AND
PROCEDURES. OVERALL WE REPORT
FEELING THAT NURSING HOM
WORKERS AND RESIDENTS DON'T
HAVE THE BACK WE NEED FROM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ONE MANY HAVE BRAVELY
SPOKEN OF ABOUT CONDITIONS FOR
EACH ONE TAKES THAT RESTORED
DOZENS AND MAYBE EVEN HUNDREDS
WERE JUST TOO AFRAID. I KNOW
BECAUSE EVEN AS A SHOPS OR
WHENEVER I HAVE SPOKEN UP FOR
OTHERS. I GET PUT UNDER THE
MICROSCOPE GET WRITTEN UP FOR
THE TINIEST THINGS IN A GENERAL
SENSE A LOT OF ADMINISTRATIVE
PUSH BACK AND PUT. NOW MORE
THAN EVER WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WORKERS FEEL SAFE TO SPEAK
OUT. WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE STATE DOES A BETTER JOB-
FORCING THE STANDARDS THAT
ALREADY EXIST. IN CREATING NEW
ONES FOR THIS AND OTHER
PANDEMICS. AND FINALLY I DO
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THE ONLY
NURSING HOME WORKERS. OF
SOLVING THE CHALLENGES YOU
FACE. WORKERS ARE RESPECTED
PAID WELL AND HAVE BENEFITS
DON'T NEED TO WORK TWO OR THREE
JOBS JUST TO KEEP A ROOF OVER
THEIR HEAD. WE NEED GOOD JOBS
AND ALSO VOICE AT WORK. I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME YOUR
COMMITMENTS KEEPING NURSING.
HOME WORKERS IN OUR PATIENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
HUNTLEY. YOUR TESTIMONY AS WELL.
OUR NEXT PRESENTER IS AMY ARE
LINDY REGISTERED NURSE AT
KAISER FRESNO MS ARE LENDING
MADE BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS AMY ARLEN I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AT KAISER
HOSPITAL IN FRESNO AS WELL AS A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION UNION. I
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY FROM THE
TRENCHES. I HAVE BEEN AN ICU
NURSE ON NIGHT SHIFT FOR TWO
DECADES AND FOR THE LAST SIX
MONTHS I HAVE BEEN WORKING
EXCLUSIVELY IN A DESIGNATED
COGAN ICU UNIT. I HAVE EARNED
THESE DARK CIRCLES I'VE LEFT MY
HOUSE EXACTLY TWICE IN THE LAST
SIX MONTHS FOR NON WORK RELATED-REASONS. I AM NOT ALONE MANY OF
MY COLLEAGUES ARE STILL
ISOLATED FROM THEIR FAMILIES TO
KEEP THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES SAFE BECAUSE AFTER SIX
MONTHS. OF THIS PANDEMIC RAGING
ON WE ARE STILL NOT SAFE AT
WORK. WINTER IS COMING AND WITH
IT COMES THE FLU AND LET ME
TELL YOU WE ARE NOT PREPARED.
EVEN AFTER ALL THIS TIME THEIR
HOSPITAL STILL PRESSURING THEIR
NURSES TO REVIEWS AND NINETY
FIVE MASKS DESPITE COUCHES
PROHIBITION OF THIS IS
ANYTHING. EXCEPT A LAST DITCH
EFFORT. THEIR OWN PP WITH
ARGUMENTS FOR MANAGEMENT LIKE
YOU'RE SCARING THE PATIENTS AND
THIS IS NOT A DESIGNATED COPING
UNIT THEREFORE YOU DON'T NEED
ANY ADDED PROTECTION. IT IS ON
THOSE NON COATED UNITS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN REPEATEDLY. SURPRISED
WITH POSITIVE PATIENTS AND HAD
SOME. STAFF OUT. SINCE THE
RECALL OF MILLION OF AB
RESPIRATORS HOSPITALS ARE NOW
SCRAMBLING TO FIND ALTERNATIVES
ONE OF THOSE BEING B. Y. D.
THEY ONLY PROVIDE MEDIUM AND
LARGE SIZES SO THE NURSES WITH
SMALLER FACES. WHICH ARE THE
LARGEST NUMBER OF PETITE THEME
IN THE INTO. ARE FAILING FIT
TESTING AND NOT BEING PROVIDED
WITH ANY OTHER NECESSARY SAFE
SUBSTITUTE. THE CONSTANT
STRUGGLE ON THE FRONT LINES TO
SECURE THE NECESSARY SUPPLIES
WE NEED TO SAFELY DO OUR JOBS.
HAS ONLY ADDED TO THE STRESS
AND FRUSTRATION THAT WE
CONTINUE TO DEAL WITH DAILY.
LOSING DOZENS OF ICU PATIENTS
ONE RIGHT AFTER THE OTHER MONTH
AFTER MONTH. SOME OF THEM IN
THEIR TWENTIES THIRTIES AND
FORTIES WITH NO PRE EXISTING
HEALTH CONDITIONS HAS TAKEN A
SEVERE PSYCHOLOGICAL TOLL
ESPECIALLY ON MYSELF. WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN FORCED TO SUFFER
THROUGH HAS CAUSED MANY
FRONTLINE HEALTH CARE WORKERS
TO RETIRE MUCH EARLIER THAN
THEY HAD PLANNED OR JUST TO
ALTOGETHER QUIT RATHER THAN TO
CONTINUE TO RISK THEIR LIVES
UNNECESSARILY. THOSE OF US THAT
ARE TRYING TO STICK IT OUT ARE
SUFFERING FROM COLLECTIVE MORAL
INJURY PTSD DEPRESSION SOCIAL
ISOLATION AND THE PHYSICAL
STRESS FROM THE PROLONGED
EXCESSIVE WORKLOADS AND STRESS
THAT WE'VE BEEN UNDER. WE'VE
HAD AN INCREASING NUMBER OF
SERIOUS WORKPLACE INJURIES AND
MENTAL HEALTH LEAVES COUPLED
WITH HEALTHCARE WORKERS OUT
SICK WITH CODED IN SOME
HOSPITALS LAOS DURING A
PANDEMIC LEADING TO JOB IN
SECURITY. MANY HOSPITALS LIKE
MINE DO NOT HIRE NEW GRADS OR
TRAINEE NURSES AND THERE IS NO
LONG TERM PLAN TO REPLACE THOSE
WORKERS AND LESS IT IS WITH
TEMPORARY PER DIEM OR TRAVELER
NURSES. AND WE'VE ALREADY
EXHAUSTED THOSE POOLS OF
RESOURCES. SOME HOSPITALS EVEN
TRIED TO WAVE OUR NURSE TO
PATIENT RATIOS JUSTIFYING THOSE
REQUESTS WITH ASSERTIONS THAT
THEY WILL CLOSE DOWN THERE ARE
IN CANCEL ELECTIVE SURGERIES
BUT THEN DON'T DO IT. TESTING
FOR FRONTLINE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS IS STILL NOT HAPPENING
SIX MONTHS INTO A PANDEMIC. I
HAVE BEEN WORKING DIRECTLY WITH
HOPE AND POSITIVE INTENSIVE
CARE PATIENTS I'VE BEEN EXPOSED
TO THE FOSTERS FARM WORKERS I
HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO. THE
FARMWORKERS I'VE BEEN EXPOSED
TO THE SOCIAL EVEN NEEDS IN OUR
COMMUNITY. DAY AFTER DAY AND I
STILL HAVE NEVER BEEN TESTED.
NURSE'S REPORT THAT THEY ARE
ROUTINELY DENIED TESTING PER
CODE NINETEEN BY THEIR EMPLOYER
DESPITE HAVING KNOWN EXPOSURES.
AND THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN OUT
SICK ARE DENIED RETESTING TO
CONFIRM THAT THEY ARE NO LONGER
INFECTIOUS BEFORE THEY RETURN
TO WORK. IN MANY CASES
MANAGEMENT HAS SOME NARROWLY
DEFINED WHAT COUNTS AS AN
EXPOSURE. THAT EVEN WHEN NURSES
DO MEET THE THRESHOLD. THE END
AREN'T SHOWING OBVIOUS SYMPTOMS
THEY ARE STILL DISCOURAGED FROM
TESTING AS WELL. GIVEN THE
EXTREMELY HIGH PERCENTAGE OF A
SYMPTOMATIC TRANSMISSION AND
THE MOUNTING EVIDENCE THAT THIS
VIRUS IS AIRBORNE. C. N. A.
STANDS FIRM AND URGES OUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS TO
IMMEDIATELY ADOPT A WIDESPREAD
TESTING IN ISOLATION PROTOCOL.
AS WELL AS MORE TRANSPARENT
REPORTING OF DATA TO HOSPITALS.
TO DO ANYTHING LESS AND
CONTINUE RE OPENING IS A DEADLY
MISTAKE. THE CONSTANTLY
CHANGING SAFETY GUIDELINES FROM
THE INSTITUTIONS THAT WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO TRUST TO KEEP US
SAFE AT WORK. ARE NO LONGER
ALIGNED WITH THE SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE AND IS LED TO THE
COMPLETE LACK OF CONFIDENCE IN
OUR EMPLOYERS. OUR HEALTH CARE
INDUSTRY AND OUR GOVERNMENT TO
DO THE RIGHT THING TO PROTECT
OUR HEALTH CARE WORKERS. OUR
FAMILIES AND OUR CMMUNITIES.
AND DON'T GET ME STARTED ABOUT
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY OUR
NURSES ARE STILL STRUGGLING TO
GET WORKERS COMP AND.
DISABILITY PAY WHEN THEY DO
TEST POSITIVE. WE HAVE HAD
STRUGGLE THE COPY DISSONANCE
CREATED WHEN OUR COMMUNITIES
OUR OWN FAMILY MEMBERS AND
SOMETIMES EVEN OUR OWN CO
WORKERS. STILL DO NOT TAKE THIS
PANDEMIC SERIOUSLY AND DO NOT
PRACTICE SAFE BEHAVIORS WEARING
A MASK AND SOCIALLY DISTANCING
IS NOT A POLITICAL PLOY IT IS A
MORAL IMPERATIVE. WE'VE HAD
OVER SEVEN MONTHS TO WATCH OKAY
THANK YOU THE WATCH LEARNING
COLLECT OBSERVATIONAL DATA FROM
THIS PANDEMIC RESPONSE AROUND
THE WORLD WE NEED TO TAKE THAT
INFORMATION TO PREVENT MASS
CASUALTIES AND USE THAT
INFORMATION TO GUIDE OUR
ACTIONS MOVING FORWARD. WE NEED
TO DO WHAT IS RIGHT NOT IS NOT
WHAT IS EASY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIS ARLEN WE APPRECIATE
THAT. OUR NEXT SPEAKER IS
SANTIAGO PLAQUE WHO IS A
GARMENT WORKER IN LOS ANGELES
AND HE'S ACCOMPANIED BY DAISY
GONZALEZ OF THE GARMENT WORKER
CENTER WHO'LL TRANSLATE FOR
HIM. THAT I SAYS WHAT IS THAT
GOING SO THERE'S A NOTE WITH A
SYMPATHETIC. YOUR NUMBER IS
FROM CANADA WHAT. IS SIMPLE
REQUEST UNANIMOUS. I DON'T
REMEMBER REPORTS DIRECTLY
ESPECIALLY SALAS. IN ORDER TO
MAKE ENOUGH THAT WHEN I LOOK.
THE CORRECT YES OKAY I WILL PUT
THIS. ALBEIT OF YOUR SHE SHED
CARE NORMS IF THE PRODUCT. YOU
ARE YOU EXPECTING. STUDENT YOUR
YOUR THE RESTAURANT HAS IS
THERE. TO MEDICINE WAS
TRADITIONALLY THE WAY YEAH
AUTOMATIC FIFTY YOUR UNDERSTORY
POLICE. THEN WITH A SIMPLE.
YOUR ACCESS FOR RECORDING
SERVICE. NINETY THREE ACOSTA
AND CAL IS REPORTING WE HELLO
THIS NOT MY IDEA SON IN THE
GROUND THIS. GRAHAM I AM AND
IT'S ONE THAT THAT IS FROM
CREEK. ABOUT RECONDITION
AFFECTS PROGRESS YOU DON'T. I
YOU SEE I WANT US AFTERNOON IS.
AWAY AS RESPUESTA COUNTY. ONE
THERMOSTAT THE ENDING. I'M NOT
SURE. LOST MISTER MOST RUNNING
SO. MY NAME IS GOKU WITH GARMIN
WERE AND I'M A GARMENT WORKER I
OFFER THE SAME NEEDLES MACHINE
AND EVERY PIECE I MAKE FOR TEN
OUR A DAY AND BEEN DOING THIS
FOR. YEARS I'M AN EXPERT IN MY
AND ME ANOTHER WE'RE DESERVE
THE THINKING OF THE ABLE TO
CALL THIS ARE OUR CAN OF THE-
THANK YOU FOR. THAT THE
CALIFORNIA GRAHAM INDUSTRY
CONSISTS FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
WORKERS MOST OF US ARE
IMMIGRANTS AND MOST OF US WORK
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE WORK
IN SWEATSHOP CONDITIONS THE
GOOD EMPLOYERS DO EXIST THEY
STRUGGLE IN COMPETITION AGAINST
THE BAD ONES WERE MORE
PROFITABLE BECAUSE THEY STEAL
OUR WAGES. GENTLEMAN'S
PROGRAMMABLE. THURMOND
SEXUALITY. TWENTY FIVE OR FORTY
S. R. YOU CAN SEE ON. ACTUALLY
I AM A SINGLE SIMPLE ACQUIRED
PERCENT FOR YES I THANK YOU A
COMPANION KIDDING MUST IN THE
WILL BE ASKED TWENTY DI<c.cyan></c>
CRISTINA AND I WANT TO TRY AND
DIDN'T MEAN. RESPECTIVE OWNERS
COMING PARTY AND IMPRESSIVE MAN
NOT. THIS IS MARIA. ARE SEEKING
NOT FROM. ONCE WE ARE NOT X.
QUICKLY. S. C. K. YEAH TO STAND
MIXED BAG BELOW. AND MY MOST
IMPRESSIVE AND SINGLE CHRISTIAN
PERSICA PLACING RUNNERS. ASM
FRAZIER REPORTED. FROM YOU.
HELLO NUMBER FOUR IF THE ANIMAL
COLLECTIVE. WE ARE ALWAYS PAID
LESS THAN MEN WAGE BECAUSE OF
THE PIECE RATE HERE IS HOW THE
PIECE RATE WORKS I AM PAY
BETWEEN FIVE AND FORTY FIVE
CENTS PER PIECE. EVEN WHEN THE
COMPANY KNOWS THAT THE FASTEST
GROWING WORKER CAN'T MAKE
ENOUGH PIECES IN AN HOUR TO
CONSERVE TO MINIMUM WAGE. THEY
OFTEN CHANGE THE RATE WITHIN
THE WEEK OR EVEN WITHIN THE DAY
SO I NEVER KNOW HOW MUCH I'M
ACTUALLY MAKING AND TELLING
PAGE. THERE ARE NO PUNCH CARDS
SO THEY DON'T KEEP TRACK OF THE
HOURLY RATE WE ARE PAID WE MAKE
BETWEEN THREE DOLLARS AND
SEVENTY FIVE CENTS. AND SIX
DOLLARS- PER HOUR. IN SEVENTEEN
YEARS. IN THIS INDUSTRY I'VE
ONLY FOUND ONE JOB WHERE I WORK
THAT FOR TWO MONTHS THAT DID
PAY MINIMUM WAGE. FOR GARMENT
WORKERS OVERTIME PAY DOESN'T
EXIST. IN FACT IF I STOP TO GO
TO THE BATHROOM OR TO CLEAN MY
MACHINE OR CHECK ON A FAMILY
MEMBER THAT'S MONEY I LOSE.
ELEVEN DANYA. NOT GETTING
CORPORATE EARNINGS IS A JANICE.
WHAT KC ONE MUSKERRY SQ DOCTOR
PRODUCT REPRESENTED WILL BE.
VETERINARIANS YES AND OPEN
SOURCE ITS BEEN. FORTY
PROHORMONES SEQUENCE BASED
ORDERS EXISTENCE WATER ARE I'M-
TRYING TO GET YEAH. SYMBOLIZE
YOUR. REMEMBER SEEKING
MANCHESTER ON THE YEAH OKAY
HERE THE S. FINANCING. ASSEMBLY
IN THE- MATH IDEAS. AND BEEN
ABANDONED GONNA BE HAVING THIS
ORDER. IT'S TIME BRANDS
OCCASIONAL. YEAH ENTER IN
PORTALS IN SEQUENCE AND I THINK.
DURING THE PANDEMIC WE WERE
DEEMED ESSENTIAL AT AS WE MADE
AND OTHER P. P. FOR THE PART
BUT NO ONE SURE THEY WE WERE
PUT. WE WORK FOR FIVE HOURS TO
SIXTY HOURS A AND CRAMPS.
WITHOUT INTO. THE FIRST FIVE OF
THE PLAN I WORKS DAYS A- I WAS
MAKING A THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
MASKS PER DAY BUT TOWARD THE
END OF THE WEEK. I'D BE SO
EXHAUSTED THAT I MADE A LITTLE
LESS ON FRIDAY AND SATURDAY. MY
WEEKLY PAY WAS BETWEEN THREE
HUNDRED AND FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS. ESTROGENIC A
SIMPLE YOU KNOW SINCE THE END
OF THE COLD WAR. IN IRAQ PRESS.
RELEASE DATE SEP. EXPRESSED A
CIRCLE. AROUND HARM REDUCTION
TARGETS. FOR CRIMINAL SANCTION
THIS. KNOWN AS A KID. WAS ADAM
THAT HE- YEAH I TORRENT OF THIS
YES AND COULD MY KIDS. LOS
BANOS NORTE TROUBLE THIS ORDER
SUBJECT. NOT IN A TEMPERATURE
TO ATTRACT. YOU KNOW CHECK IN
CITY AND SEEM TO. RAINSTORM
ASSUME ESTAS IN THE LAST. YOU
KNOW AREN'T. YES THEY HAVE THAT.
WORKERS IN FACT THAT LA ARE
ASKED TO WEAR AND MAINTAIN
THEIR MATH THESE BACK ARE
USUALLY HAZARDOUS WORKPLACES
FULL OF DUST AND RAT FECES AND
THE POTENTIAL EXPOSURE TO COLD
IT MAKES THEM MORE DANGEROUS
THERE'S NO SIX FOOT DISTANCE
BETWEEN STATIONS BATHROOMS
DON'T HAVE SO THERE'S NO HAND
SANITIZER THERE'S NO
TEMPERATURE CHECKS NO SYMPTOM
CHECKS. INFORMATION IS ONLY IN
ENGLISH AND THERE IS NO PAID
SICK LEAVE. YOUR CLOSING MY PS
ARE. WHAT GIVE ME PEPPERONI
NEXT HERE MUSCAT A- THE OTHERS
PLAYERS NUMBERS TO THE ONES YES
WHAT ABOUT. ASSEMBLY YOUNG
CARERS WHEN THERE ARE YOUR M.
SONG. RELATE PRODUCTS HERE I
WAS UNANIMOUS. GUESSING RENDON
AND TALKED. OKAY WHERE DOES THE
LAST INNOVATIVE PRODUCTS YOU
OKAY AND ROBATA AND NINETY FOR
ME AND THAT LEAVE TELLING
PARCEL YES SIR. I DON'T NEED A
LOT OF. RENDON YES INTERNET ARE.
ARE YOU WILLING IN THE AND GET
A ON THE LEFT IN. YOUR ANSWER
WHAT IS THE CHAIRMAN. ECONET
NEXT. LAST I WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT I'VE A RECENTLY MY
AND DOES REQUIRE MASS THE DAY
AFTER THE- WORKERS WERE ASKED
TO WEAR THE SOLUTION THAT WE
ASKING FOR OUR THE GOVERNMENT
WORKER PUTS I TO PASS PROTECT
WORKERS ENSURE OF THE BY THE OF.
BECAUSE THE WAGE STARTS AT THE
TOP WE WANT TO AND PIECE RATE
TO THE PLAYING FIELD FOR ALL WE
WENT THROUGH PAID LEAVE AND-
ENEMY. RELEASE AND RENT
FORGIVENESS THANK YOU FOR HERE
ME AND HAVING. I JUST WANT TO
ASK VERY QUICKLY SORRY. THAT
YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT SOME
INFORMATION OF OUR SAID OF
TWENTY- FROM THE L. A. COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF. PUBLIC HEALTH
THERE WERE TWELVE OUTBREAKS
HAVE BEEN DOCUMENTED
SPECIFICALLY IN APPAREL
MANUFACTURING SECTOR. WITH A
TOTAL OF FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINETY FOUR OUTBREAK ASSOCIATED
CASES- SO THESE CASES ARE ONLY
AS PARTS OF OUTBREAKS SO THAT'S
BETWEEN THREE AND A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THREE CASES PER
OUTBREAK- AND MANY INFECTIONS
IN GARMENT- AS WELL AS THAT
SCHOOL AND REPORTED IT BUT
WORKERS ARE VERY AWARE OF THEM
AND INFORM THEM. INFORM US OF
THEM ALL THE TIME- CURRENT
CALIFORNIA LAW ALLOWS THIS
WIDESPREAD EXPECTATION TO
BECOME EVEN MORE ENTRENCHED
DURING THIS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC CRISIS. LIKE THE ONE
THAT WE'RE IN NOW. BRANDER NOT
HELD LIABLE FOR PRICING MODELS
FOR THE WORKING CONDITIONS- IN
SMALL BUSINESSES COMPETE FOR
ORDERS THAT ARE NOT PRICED MEET
MINIMUM WAGE REQUIREMENTS. THIS
IS WHY FIFTY FIVE HIGH ROAD
BUSINESSES SUPPORT THE
GOVERNMENT WORKER PROTECTION.
ACT AND THAT'S TO LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD. THE RATED THE
PEACHTREE DECREASE AS THE
ORDERS ARE NEED RATE THEY GO
FROM THE BRAND TO THE
MANUFACTURE AND THEN
SUBCONTRACTED OVER TO
FACTORIES. AND THAT RATE IS SO
LOW THAT IT DOESN'T ALLOW
WORKERS TO BE PAID MINIMUM
WAGE- THE P. THREE IT THIS
INCENTIVIZE WORKERS FROM TAKING
HEALTH PRECAUTIONS LIKE
REGULARLY WASHING YOUR HANDS OR
EVEN TAKING BREAKS- AND THIS IS
WHY WE NEED THE GARMENT WORKER
PROTECTION ACT. WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY FELL TO BE
BROUGHT UP TO ROLE IN THE
ASSEMBLY THIS YEAR SO WILL BE
RE INTRODUCING THE LEGISLATION
NEXT YEAR- THIS EXPECTATION IN
GARMENT IS NOT SOLVABLE JIM
FORSMAN ONLY. IT HASN'T WORKED
WE RECORDED HUNDREDS OF
BUSINESSES I THINK. EIGHT
NINETY THREE SB EIGHT AND OFTEN
THE STATE PUTS THE BILL FOR
THESE UNPAID WAGE CLAIMS THANK
YOU MISS GONZALEZ I APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH- I
THINK YOU FOR HAVING THE
GARMENT WORKER CENTER TODAY
THANK YOU IMMEDIATE ACCESS
SANTIAGO BUT SO THAT'S THE BONO.
OKAY YOU IN THE NEXT AND LAST
PANELIST TODAY WILL BE ROSA
MILLION OF THE LAW ANGELES
COUNTY LAY FED. THANK YOU MARIE.
THANK YOU- MY NAME IS ROSE
MARIE MOLINA I'M THE ORGANIZING
DIRECTOR OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FEDERATION OF LABOR AND
I'M HERE TODAY TO PROVIDE
INSIGHT ON HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUES IN THE WAREHOUSING
INDUSTRY. ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT
HAVE BEEN EXACERBATED BY
CORPORATE NINETEEN. WAREHOUSING
AND DISTRIBUTION IS A KEY
SECTOR IN CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
WELL OVER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE WORK IN
WAREHOUSES IN CALIFORNIA. AND
MANY OF THE ESSENTIAL
OPERATIONS OF COMPANIES LIKE
AMAZON ARE GROWING AND CONTINUE
TO OPERATE AT FULL CAPACITY
THROUGH THE SHUTDOWN. DURING
THIS PANDEMIC THE WAREHOUSING
INDUSTRY HAS X. TO WEAKEN DO
FOR INCREASED ARRAY OF PRODUCTS
AND SHORTEN DELIVERY TIMES.
SOME COMPANIES PROMISED GOODS
WITHIN THE SAME DAY OF PURCHASE
WHILE OTHERS WITHIN HOURS IN
THE LA AREA WE'VE SEEN SOME
COMPANIES NEARLY DOUBLE THEIR
WAREHOUSING AND DELIVERY
CAPACITY SINCE MARCH BECAUSE OF
THIS DEMAND. BUT MEETING THIS
DEMAND COMES IN THE STATE. COST
TO WAREHOUSE WORKERS AND IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
TAKE NOTCE TO INTERVENE IN
WAREHOUSING SAFETY DURING THESE
TIMES. ONE OF THE BIGGEST
HEALTH AND SAFETY ISSUES WE ARE
SEEING IN WAREHOUSING DURING
THIS TIME IS THE INABILITY OF
WORKERS TO TAKE BREAKS AND
SANITIZE THEIR EQUIPMENT AND
STATIONS. IT WAS HARD FOR
WORKERS TO TAKE BREAKS BEFORE
THE VIRUS AND CURRENT HEALTH
ORDERS CALL FOR MORE BREAKS TO
ENSURE THAT PROPER SANITATION
AND SAFETY IS BEING MET. THAT
WORKERS DON'T HAVE THE ROOM WE
DON'T FEEL THAT THEY HAVE THE
ROOM TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THESE
PROTOCOLS. THE EMPLOYERS ARE
TELLING WORKERS TO TAKE BREAKS
WORKERS FEEL THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE THE LIBERTY TO TAKE THEM
IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T COUNT
AGAINST OUR PRODUCTIVITY AT THE
END OF THE DAY. AND THIS
ULTIMATELY RESULTS IN PENALTIES
FOR WORKERS AND THIS IS CENTER
VISINE THE USAGE OF BREAKS. A
FORMER AMAZON WORKER IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY DESCRIBED HOW
DIFFICULT IT WAS FOR HER TO
TAKE A BREAK UNDER THEIR TIME
OFF TASK SYSTEM AND HIGH
DEMANDING POTUS DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THERE WERE INSTANCES
WHERE SHE WOULD HAVE TO HAND
HER SCANNER OVER TO A COWORKER
TO KEEP SCANNING WELL SHE RAN
TO THE RESTROOM THAT WAS NEARLY
SEVEN MINUTES AWAY FROM HER
STATION. A CURRENT WALMART
WAREHOUSE WORKER AND SABATINO
COUNTY TOLD. US THAT EVEN WITH
COBIT THE CODE IS STILL THE- WE
HAVE NOT STOPPED AT ALL TO WASH
YOUR HANDS MORE. HOWEVER OUR
WORKERS TO STOP THEY'RE STILL
DEMAND TO MAINTAIN THE QUOTA
TWO. ITEM AND TO PICK MORE
EVERY HOUR. WORKERS DON'T WANT
TO SLOW DOWN OR STOP BECAUSE
THEY'RE SCARED. AND THEY'RE
ALSO TERRIFIED OF BEING CALLED
HOME TO THEIR FAMILY. TALKING
TO A WAREHOUSE WORKER ADVOCATE
HERE IN LA WE FOUND THAT WHEN
COMPLAINTS WERE FILED. WITH
STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES THEIR
RESPONSE WAS SLOW OR ARE SIMPLY
INADEQUATE. AND ONE AMAZON
DELIVERY STATION IN LOS ANGELES
OVER FORTY CASES HAVE BEEN
REPORTED IN EVEN ONE DAY. AND
LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH INVESTIGATED THE
COMPLAINT. BUT ONLY TALK TO
MANAGEMENT AS PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION. THE INVESTIGATOR
FOUND THAT SANITATION EQUIPMENT
HAD BEEN SET UP SIGNAGE PUT OUT
AND SIX FOOT MARKERS PLACED
ALONG THE FLOOR. IN AUSTIN GOOD
AND WELL THEY CLOSE THE CASE.
HOWEVER BECAUSE THAT
INVESTIGATOR FAILED TO SPEAK TO
WORKERS. THEY DIDN'T FIND THAT
SHARED EQUIPMENT WASN'T BEING
SANITIZED. THAT WORKERS DIDN'T
HAVE MATERIALS OR THE TIME TO
SANITISE STATIONS IN BETWEEN
SHIPS. AND THAT THESE PACKAGES
THAT COME TO OUR DOORSTEP SAME
DAY OR PASSING BETWEEN FOUR TO
FIVE WORKERS. WITHOUT PROPER
PROTECTION. AS ADVOCATES WE
WELCOME THE EXPANSION OF WORK
IN THE WAREHOUSING INDUSTRY BUT
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IT'S SAFE
AND SUSTAINABLE. SO IN LOS
ANGELES WERE FINDING CREATIVE
WAYS TO STOP THE SPREAD OF
KOBE. THIS MOMENT CALLS FOR
QUICK INNOVATION. USING THE
TOOLS WE HAVE NOW IN CREATING
SOME MORE. WE'VE INTRODUCED A
POLICY INITIATIVE THAT WOULD
ALLOW FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
COUNCILS. THEY WANTED RISK
CONTEXTUALIZES SITUATION DOWN
HERE IN LA. WORKED AT TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND POSITIVE CASES JUST IN
OUR REGION. AND SIX HUNDRED.
SIX THOUSAND EIGHTY ONE DEATHS
THAT'S NEARLY SEVEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T COMING HOME
TO THEIR FAMILIES. AND IN PARTS
OF CALIFORNIA STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT HALF OF TRANSMISSION
COMES FROM THE WORKPLACE WE
HEARD ABOUT THIS TO DATE WITH
THE OTHER PANEL. THIS MEANS
THAT STOPPING THE SPREAD ABOUT
BREAKS. TO THE PUBLIC STARTS IN
THE WORKPLACE. LOS ANGELES PUT
HEALTH CARE CALL WITH A WORKERS
AN ESSENTIAL WORKPLACES TO FORM
COMMITTEES TO ENFORCE THE
COUNTY HEALTH BORDERS. THIS
MEANS WORKERS WOULD BE ABLE TO
ENSURE THAT STANDARDS ARE MET.
INCLUDING STANDARDS AROUND
SOCIAL DISTANCING PP AND OTHER
OTHER COVERT RELATED MEASURES.
WE KNOW THAT THE CAPACITY OF
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES IS AN
ISSUE. WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
COUNCILS THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH CARE LOCALLY
COULD DEPUTISE THIRD PARTY WORK
ORGANIZATIONS TO HELP TRAIN
WORKERS. ON THE COUNTY HELP
ORDER AND COULD HELP REFER
WORKERS TO THE DEPARTMENT.
ABOUT COMPLETING CASES OF NON
COMPLIANCE. THIS POLICY COMES
FROM A NEED TO ENSURE THAT
COMPLIANCE IS BEING MET SO THAT
THE PUBLIC OUR COMMUNITIES AND
OUR FAMILY STOP GETTING SICK.
EARLY INVESTIGATIONS FOUND THAT
WE HAVE 50% NONCOMPLIANCE IN
SOME INDUSTRIES EIGHTY PERCENT.
AND WHERE HOUSING CONTINUES TO
BE AN INDUSTRY WITH HIGHER
OUTBREAKS HERE ELLIE. THANK
WORKERS ARE YOU MAKING THE
VIRUS BACK TO THEIR FAMILIES.
AND AS WE CONTINUE TO REOPEN WE
KNOW THIS GREATER PUBLIC RISK
WE DON'T WANT THE ECONOMY TO
SHUT DOWN AGAIN- WE WANT TO
WORK WITH MANAGEMENT WORK WITH
WORKERS AND THE DEPARTMENT TO
STOP THE SPREAD. I APPRECIATE
YOU GIVING ME THE TIME TO SPEAK
AND I HOPE THE STATE MAKES ALL
THE- THE RIGHT DECISIONS
INCREASING HEALTH AND SAFETY
FOR WAREHOUSE WORKERS. FOR THE
PUBLIC FOR ALL WORKERS. WE'RE
TIRED OF BURYING OUR MEMBERS
AND WE KNOW THAT GREATER
PREVENTIVE MEASURES CAN BE
TAKEN ESPECIALLY FROM THE
STATE. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS MOLINA. WELL THAT WAS
A GREAT PANEL- OF THE
CALIFORNIA WORK FORCE FRONTLINE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S TIME- IN
PROVIDING US MORE INSIGHT ON.
ON EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOUR
ROLES WE- I MUCH APPRECIATE THE
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO MEMBERS.
AND COMMENTS I'D LIKE TO INVITE
THE PUBLIC WANTING TO
PARTICIPATE ONCE AGAIN TO CALL
AND NOW. A PLEASE DIAL THE TOLL
FREE NUMBER. ONE EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIX THREE
SIX FOUR WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE
USE THE ACCESS CODE. SEVEN SIX
TWO. ONE TWO SEVEN NINE SO I'LL
ACTUALLY START THE FIRST ROUND
OF QUESTIONS THEN I'LL KICK IT
OFF TO A FEW OF OUR- MEMBERS
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE WHO HAVE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AND IT WAS
GOING BACK TO THE- QUESTION OF
INVESTIGATION PERIOD- WE CAN
USE THE FOSTER FARM EXAMPLE I
KNOW IN MY DISTRICT I HAVE THE
CITY OF VERNON. WHICH HAS BEEN
VERY CONCERNING IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY A MEAT PACKING INDUSTRY-
WITH FARMER JOHN'S- IN MY
BACKYARD AND- I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS WHEN DOES THE
INVESTIGATION PERIOD START. AND
WHAT OF WHAT- THAT'S KIND OF
STEPS ALONG THE WAY WITHOUT
GETTING TOO TECHNICAL ON ON A
SPECIFIC SITE. BECAUSE WE KNOW
YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT THAT AND
THEN WHEN. IT IS FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND IT'S A SIX MONTH
PERIOD. DO WE NEED TO SHORTEN
THAT TIME BECAUSE SIX MONTHS IS
A VERY LONG TIME ESPECIALLY
THIS CODE ENVIRONMENT. I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO KICK THAT OFF THAT
QUESTION OFTEN I WILL ASK
EITHER DIRECTOR HAGEN OR CHIEF
PARKER. I CAN ADDRESS THAT
QUESTION- SO THAT THE- THE SIX
MONTH PERIOD JUST SO YOU KNOW
IS OUR IS OUR STATUE
LIMITATIONS IT'S- HOW MUCH TIME
WE HAVE LEGAL DATA- TO- ISSUE A
CITATION FROM THANK YOU BOTH
YOU KNOW. BEFORE EMPLOYER CAN
RAISE THE DEFENSE THAT WE ARE
OUT OF TIME TO ISSUE THE
CITATION SO I WOULDN'T I WOULD
NOT YOU KNOW I WOULD NOT-
SUGGESTS SHORTENING THAT- BUT I
AM. EAGER TO EVALUATE OUR
SYSTEMS AND FIGURE OUT WAYS
THAT WE COULD SHORTEN OUR
PROCESS OVERALL. TO ADDRESS THE
KIND OF PROCESS- NAY AN
INVESTIGATION COMMENCES- THAT
TYPICALLY- YOU KNOW IT WHEN
THE- IN RESPONSE TO A SERIOUS
COMPLAINT FOR EXAMPLE WITHIN
THREE DAYS OF THE COMPLAINT.
BEING RECEIVED BY THE
KALOGEROPOULOS- THE
INVESTIGATION ITSELF BEGINS
WITH- WHEN OPENING CONFERENCE
WITH THE EMPLOYER THERE'S OFTEN
ALSO- REQUEST FOR DOCUMENTS-
WE'RE WE'RE WE- INTRODUCED THE
ISSUES GO OVER WHAT THE FACTS
AND ENTAIL- RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL PROCEDURES RELATED
TO COVER NINETEEN PROTECT OUR
EMPLOYEES. AFTER THAT IS THE
PHYSICAL INSPECTION- SOMETIMES
RETURN VISITS ARE NECESSARY-
SOMETIMES- TESTING AND
MONITORING IS NECESSARY
DEPENDING ON THE TYPE OF
INVESTIGATION IT IS AND THEN
OCCASIONALLY WE DON'T GET
COOPERATION AND WE HAVE TO GO
AND SEEK WARM OR TO PHYSICALLY
ENTER THE PROPERTY- AFTER THAT
THERE'S THE REVIEW OF HE
DOCUMENTS- PLANS RECORDS INJURY
AND ILLNESS REPORTS- THERE
SOMETIMES DISPUTES OVER I
DOCUMENTS THAT TAKE TIME YOU
KNOW ATTAINING DOCUMENTS-
THERE'S THE INTERVIEWS OF
WITNESSES. SO WE ARE REQUIRED
TO INTERVIEW BOTH MANAGEMENT
AND EMPLOYEES WITNESSES
CURRENTLY A LOT OF THAT IS
HAPPENING OVER THE PHONE SO
THAT'S YOU KNOW ARRANGE TO
REMOTELY SYSTEM REDUCED RISK OF
IT- OUR OUR EXPOSURE I SHOULD
SAY- THEN WE OF COURSE VARIOUS
INTERNAL PROCEDURES RECORD
KEEPING WE HAVE TO IDENTIFY YOU
WITH THE EVIDENCE THERE'S A
REVIEW BY MANAGERS- SHE-
REVIEWED BY LEGAL. TIME AND
COURSE ALL OF THAT IS GOING ON
WITH CODE NINE BECAUSE IT
DISNEY TO US TO WE DON'T A
CLEAR. ON IT AND WE HAVE TO BE
VERY CAREFUL AND MINDFUL AS WE
ARE DIVING IN THE CASES TO PUT
THEM TOGETHER- AND THEN WE'RE
ALSO REVIEWING FOR CONSISTENCY
AS WE HAVE. SEVENTEEN DISTRICT
OFFICES IN FOUR REGIONS-
ACTUALLY FIVE REGENTS INVOLVE
ACTIVELY AND- RIGHT NOW IN THE
OCTOBER NINETEENTH. AND SO. A
FEW ARE YOU KNOW I THINK THE
YOU KNOW THE AVERAGE CASE
TAKES- ABOUT AND AROUND NINETY
DAYS FROM START TO FINISH-
BECAUSE THE CASES ARE TAKING
AROUND SEVENTY FROM THE
INITIATION INVESTIGATION. WHEN
THE CITATION IS ISSUED- YOU
KNOW. ONE OF THE THINGS WHEN I
CAME HERE AND I'VE BEEN HERE
ABOUT A YEAR WAS TO. REALLY
EVALUATE WHAT. YOU KNOW HOW HOW
WE CAN SHAVE TIME OFF OF THAT
PROCESS- AND- YEAH WE'VE DONE
WE'VE DONE A NUMBER OF WAYS IN
THE CO THE CONTEXT YOU KNOW
WE'VE USED. SOME OF THESE
SWEEPS LIKE WE'VE DONE IN
AGRICULTURE WHERE WE SET A GOAL
OF. ISSUING A CITATION AND- THE
GENERAL CITATION THIRTY DAYS
ARE A SERIES LOCATION FORTY
FIVE DAYS- BUT YOU KNOW THAT OF
COURSE TAKES TIME AWAY FROM
OTHER INVESTIGATIONS- WE ALSO
RIGHT NOW HAVE. A RELATIVELY-
LOW NUMBER OF INDUSTRIAL HIGH
JANICE AND OTHER. SPECIALIST IN
INFECTIOUS DISEASE. AND SO-
THAT CREATES SOME BOTTLENECKS.
IN THE REVIEW PROCESS AS WELL.
WE CLEAR MORE COME CASE. AND SO
YOU KNOW WE THERE'S A NUMBER OF
WAYS THAT YOU KNOW THERE'S A
NUMBER OF THINGS WERE EAGER TO
LOOK AT- YOU KNOW I CERTAINLY.
RIGHT MY JOB. MY LAST JOB IN
GOVERNMENT WAS THAT. AT THE
FEDERAL MINE SAFETY HEALTH
ADMINISTRATION AND NO. WE WERE
ABLE TO ACT PRETTY QUICKLY
UNDER THE SOUTH LOSS THAT WE
HAD THEIR PROCEDURES WE GET
THERE. YEAH WE HAVE A BIG
WORKLOAD HERE WE HAVE A LOT OF
EXTENSIVE PROCEDURES WE HAVE A
RELATIVELY FORMAL ADJUDICATION
PROCESS- THAT REQUIRES YOU KNOW
THE WAY WE GATHER EVIDENCE.
THAT SORT OF THING TO BE PRETTY
THOROUGH- BUT- YEAH. AS I SAID
I'M VERY EAGER TO EXAMINE HOW
WE SHORTEN THAT PROCESS BUT
THERE IS A LOT IN THERE THAT WE
HAVE TO DO RIGHT NOW. MOST
CERTAINLY CHIEF OF PARKER AND I
THINK YOU FOR THAT AND I THINK-
FROM WHAT I'M GATHERING HERE IS
THAT WE- WE WOULD WANT TO
ENSURE HOW WE- CAN CONTINUE
WORKING TOGETHER WITH YOU TO
SHORTEN THAT PROCESS AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. GIVEN THIS TESTIMONY
AND GIVEN THE SEVERITY OF MANY
OF THESE ISSUES WHICH HAVE
RESULTED UNFORTUNATELY AND
WORKER DEATHS- THE SECOND
QUESTION I HAVE AND THEN I WILL
SEND IT OFF TO A- SENATOR. WHO
DOCILE. IS ABOUT HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN BECOME A
LITTLE BIT MORE PRE OP
PROACTIVE AS- MANY OF THE- WORK
FORCE IS MENTIONED. A LOT OF
THE COMPLAINTS ARE DRIVEN BY
EMPLOYEES OR RELIANT ON
EMPLOYEES TO. TO FILE A
COMPLAINT. I KNOW WE ONLY HAVE
SO MANY RESOURCES TO YOUR POINT
AND I KNOW YOU ALL ARE WORKING
VERY VERY HARD BUT- WHAT OTHER
THOUGHTS DO WE HAVE IN THE
PIPELINE ABOUT HOW TO BECOME A
LITTLE BIT MORE PRO ACTIVE.
ESPECIALLY IN THESE AREAS THAT
WE KNOW ARE HARDEST HIT. AND
WORKING WITH THE COUNTY IS TO
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE ALSO
PROACTIVE- ON WITH MANY OF
THESE ISSUES OF. THIS DISTURBED
DESCRIBED HERE TODAY. I CAN
START TO RESPOND TO THAT
QUESTION I I'VE MENTIONED-
THAT. OUTREACH A COUPLE OF
TIMES AND- LIKE DOUG. I'M ALSO
A NEWCOMER AT THE A. R. AND SO
STILL LEARNING THROUGH THIS
PROCESS BUT MY OBSERVATIONS
HAVE. BEEN THAT- ENFORCEMENT IS
ONLY AS GOOD AS- YOU KNOW.
FOLKS UNDERSTAND- THAT THERE
WITH THE RULES AND THE
GUIDELINES THAT WERE FACED WITH
AND SO. HUGE EFFORT HAS BEEN
UNDERWAY. WITHIN D. I. R.
WITHIN THE AGENCY AND ACROSS
THE STATE TO. REALLY CONDUCT A
LOT OF OUTREACH- BUT YOUR
QUESTION IS WHAT WHAT CAN WE DO
GOING FORWARD- WE HAVE- AS A
RESULT OF SB ONE FIFTEEN- WE
RECEIVED A- A FUSION OF
FUNDING. FOR OUTREACH EFFORTS A
SPECIFIC TWO. OCTOBER NINETEEN
AND- WE HAVE A PUBLIC AWARENESS
MEDIA CAMPAIGN PLANNED- IS A
MULTI TIERED- STRATEGY- USING
PAID MEDIA. BOB AND IT'S-
INDUSTRY TARGET SO. YOU KNOW WE
HAVE BEEN FOCUSED- EXTENSIVELY
ON AGRICULTURE WILL CONTINUE TO
BE TO BE- FOCUS ON AGRICULTURE
BUT AS WELL AS FOOD PROCESSING-
INCLUDING MEAT PACKING-
JANITORIAL- INCLUDING
HOUSEKEEPING AND HOSPITALITY.
FOOD SERVICES OUR RESTAURANT
AND GROCERY WAREHOUSE AND
LOGISTICS AND MANUFACTURING
INCLUDING THE GARMENT INDUSTRY-
IN OUR PRIMARY MESSAGES- ARE ON
EXISTING AND NEW LABOR RATES-
INTENDED TO SLOW THE SPREAD OF
THE VIRUS AND NOT AND- THAT'S
WORKPLACE HEALTH AND SAFETY
WHICH- IS ENFORCED BY
CALIBRATION. HEAT SICK LEAVE-
WORKERS COMPENSATION AND ANTI
RETALIATION PROTECTIONS. IN
ADDITION TO THE PUBLIC
AWARENESS MEDIA CAMPAIGN- OUR
AGENCY IS LEADING OUR EFFORTS
THAT AND LABOR AND WORKFORCE
AGENCIES LEADING EFFORTS IN.
ESTABLISHING A WORKER AND
EMPLOYER TRAINING PROGRAM- AND
ALSO INCLUDED- WITH WERE ABLE
TO AND- IMPLEMENT THIS AS A
RESULT OF THE RECENT FUNDING-
YOU KNOW WE HAVE BEEN DOING
WEBINARS- AND DEVELOPING ONLINE
MATERIALS BUT- WE'RE LOOKING AT
WAYS TO- ENHANCE THAT- ADD MORE
INDUSTRY SPECIFICTRAINING-
PARTICULARLY IN THOSE AREAS
WHERE WE HAVE A HIGH INCIDENCE
OF CODED- INJURIES REPORTED-
AND I WILL. LEAVE IT AT THAT IN
CASE THERE'S ANY OTHER COMMENTS
ON THIS THANK YOU DIRECTOR
HAGEN I APPRECIATE THAT AND I
THINK- ALTHOUGH I WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT APPRECIATE THE PUBLIC
RELATIONS CAMPAIGNS I THINK WE
DO NEED TO DO MORE IN TERMS OF
ACTUALLY ENFORCING. I KNOW WE
ARE AGAIN I JUST WANT TO
CONTINUE REITERATING THAT- IT
IS VERY CONCERNING TO HEAR FROM
THIS WORK FORCE THAT THERE ARE
STILL ISSUES THAT REMAIN- AND
THE LACK OF AN FORSMAN OR THE
FASTER FOR SOME IT'S I'M I'M IN
LOVE M. INSPIRED WHEN. CHIEF
PARKER SAYS THAT WE WILL LOOK
AT OTHER WAYS TO FIND HOW TO
MAKE THE PROCESS OF
INVESTIGATION MORE EXPEDIENT SO
I'M- YOU KNOW I THINK THERE'S
OTHER WAYS THAT WE CAN LOOK AT
THAT COULD. PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
ENFORCEMENT AND IN THAT SENSE.
WITH THAT I SAY THANK YOU AND
I'M GOING TO SEND IT OFF TO
SENATOR TO RUSSELL THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. I AM. YOU KNOW
AFTER HEARING ESPECIALLY ALL
THE TESTIMONY FROM OF THE MEN
AND WOMEN IN THESE VARIOUS
INDUSTRIES- ONE THING THAT
KEEPS COMING COMING BACK AND I
KNOW THIS FROM MY OWN
EXPERIENCE IN SEVERAL OF THOSE
INDUSTRIES IS THAT THERE IS
ENORMOUS FEAR. HIS FEAR AND-
THE PUBLIC AWARENESS OR THE
PUBLIC EDUCATION- NOTICES IS A
GOOD THING TO DO NOT OPPOSED TO
IT BUT THERE'S GOTTA BE SOME.
COME BACK- SORT OF LIKE I'M
WATCHING YOUR BACK OF MR WORKER
MISS WORKERS- THAT BY. FOURTEEN
THESE CONDITIONS I'M NOT GONNA
LOSE MY JOB. I MEAN THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY OF A BOTTOM LINE
PEOPLE'S LIVES LIFE IS AT STAKE
BUT THEIR LIVELIHOOD IS AT
STAKE AND VERY FEW OF US EVER.
GO THROUGH THAT IN LIFE- SOME
MORE THAN OTHERS SO. I GUESS
THE- WE HAVE THIS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THAT I'M REALLY
GRATEFUL TO. THE LEADERSHIP TO
THE GOVERNOR TO HAVE INCLUDED-
OF THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS TO DO
MORE OF THIS WORK IN THE
WORKPLACE- SO. I REALLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S USED IN THE
RIGHT WAY IN THAT IT
EFFECTIVELY ADAM IN THE RIGHT
WAY THE EFFECTIVE WAY- AND I'M
I'M CONCERNED THAT. WHAT WE GET
COULDN'T ADVISE TO DO IS A LOT
OF BILLBOARDS AND COMMERCIALS
AND ADS AND THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS AND THAT JUST DOESN'T
WORK THAT THAT JUST IT'S PART
OF IT. BUT IT'S NOT THE BULK OF
IT SO I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S
ANY MORE MORE THOUGHTS- BY
MISTAKEN OR MISTER PARKER ALL
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES. IS THERE
A WAY OR LET'S FIND A WAY WHAT
ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON FINDING A
WAY. TO SPEED UP THE PROCESS
PUT MORE PEOPLE IN PLACE SO
THAT THE TIMING AND IT AND IT
SHOWS THAT GOVERNMENT IS REALLY
GOING TO PROTECT THOSE MEN AND
WOMEN. AS THEY PUT THEM
THEMSELVES ON THE LINE ON ON
THE HEALTH CARE FRONT. ANY MORE
THOUGHTS ABOUT THAT. THANK YOU
AND THAT WOULD BE MY ONLY
QUESTION MANAGER. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUSSELL. DO WE HAVE ANY
OF THE PANELISTS THAT WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT ON SENATOR
DEDUCTIBLES. QUESTIONS. OKAY I
CAN I CAN ADDRESS PART OF IT
WHICH IS THE- YOUR CONCERNS
ABOUT HOW WE EFFECTIVELY
CONDUCT OUTREACH AND I AGREE
WITH YOU AND ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF TAKING CARE AND
pTHAT WE ARE IN FACT. TARGETING
AN AFFECT OF WAY OUR EFFORTS TO
REACH THE MOST VULNERABLE AND
HARD TO REACH WORKERS- IT
BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE MOST IN NEED AND- YOU
KNOW WE SPEND ENGAGE WITH. YOU
KNOW WITH THE LABOR CENTERS
AND- AND I APPRECIATE THAT HELP
HEALTH AND SAFETY CENTER- I
MEAN AT UC BERKELEY AND
BERKELEY AND THIS WHILE. THE
WANTED UCLA- FOR THE SPECIFIC
PURPOSE OF. IDENTIFYING THOSE
TYPES OF STRATEGIES SO- YOU
KNOW IT'S IT IS AN IMPORTANT
PART OF- SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
GOING TO. BUILD INTO OUR
COMMUNICATION STRATEGY- AND-
YOU KNOW WITH THE RECOGNITION
THAT IT'S NOT EASY AND WE ARE
GOING TO NEED- YOU KNOW
ADDITIONAL GUIDES FROM FROM.
PEOPLE MORE MORE FAMILIAR WITH.
THE SPECIALLY WORKERS ARE TO DO
IT. GREAT THANK YOU CHIEF
PARKER. I WILL THEN MOVE ON TO
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU TERRY
GONZALEZ AND THE FIRST OF I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND
REPRESENTATIVES TESTIFIED AND-
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
TESTIMONY. I DID HAVE A FIRST
CLASS QUESTION MAINLY FOR CD P.
H. AND THEN A FOLLOW UP FOR
ALSO- I CAL OSHA SELF STARTING
WITH C. PH. THIS IS WE'VE HEARD
FROM THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS. YOU
KNOW WHEN THINGS WILL BE FUN
THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT IS
TESTING AND I KNOW THAT C.
PEACHES MENTIONED THAT- AS
THEY'RE DEVELOPING GUIDELINES-
THERE MAY BE CERTAIN PLACES
WHERE THEY WILL CALL FOR
SURVEILLANCE TESTING. AND SO IT
GETS PART OF MY QUESTIONS ABOUT
ACCESS TO TESTING AND ALSO IS
THERE A MANDATE IF THE TEST IS
DONE IN A WORK PLACE ESPECIALLY
IF YOU USING SOME OF THESE.
TESTS THAT CAN BE DONE LET'S
SAY A UNIT THAT CAN BE DONE IN
THE WORKPLACE SO IT'S NOT
ACTUALLY SENT FORMALLY TO A
LAB. GEN OBLIGATION BY
WORKPLACES REPORT THE RESULTS
OF THOSE TESTS TO THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT SEEKING WHAT
THE RESULTS ARE. AND CERTAINLY
I THINK RECENT EVENTS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE HAVE SHOWN THERE
ARE CERTAIN THE LIMITATIONS THE
TESTING ITSELF. AS A STRATEGY
BUT CERTAINLY TESTING AS PART
OF THAT SO WE WILL BE SURE THAT
WE GET ACCESS TO THE RESULTS OF
ALL TESTS. ARE PERFORMED
RELATED TO THE WORKPLACE SO I
CAN YOU COMMENT ON THAT- AND
THEN FOLLOW UP TO THAT. IS A
SAID TESTING ALONE IS NOT
ENOUGH CONTACT TRACING. SO WHAT
IS OUR CONTACT RAISING
CAPACITY- SO WHEN AS WE GET
RESULTS AND SPECIALLY IF WE
HAVE A POSITIVE RESULT IN THE
WORKPLACE ARE THEY ALL BEING
CONTACTED TRACED. US SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT- WE NEED TO BE
SURE IS HAPPENING AS WELL SO
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THESE
POSITIVES ARE BEING CONTACTED
SNOW WHAT DEGREE. IS THERE. AN
EXPERIENCE OF THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT'S. IT'S OUR
COOPERATION FROM THE WORKPLACES
IN THE CONTACT RACING EFFORTS-
NOT ONLY OF COURSE FOR THE
WORKERS BUT THEY HAVE CUSTOMERS
OR OTHER PEOPLE IN THEIR SITE
AS WELL. SO BASICALLY FIRST OF
ALL TESTING ESPECIALLY
REQUIRING FOR SURVEILLANCE.
TESTING THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
BOTH ACCESS TEST. THAT CAN BE
DONE. AS WELL AS REQUIREMENTS
FOR TEST RESULTS BEFORE TO THE
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. AND THEN
FOLLOWING THAT TO THE CONTACT
RACING EFFORTS SO. IT WHICH IS
ALSO PERHAPS ONE THE WAYS THAT
WE CAN THEN IDENTIFY. WORKPLACE
THAT NEED TO BE REFERRED TO
CARLOS IS I GUESS THE THIRD
PART IF YOU ARE DOING CONTACT
TRACING ARE YOU REPORTING THOSE
RESULTS IN ADDITION.
RECOGNIZING THAT THE MAINTAIN
PATIENT CONFIDENTIALITY TO
CALLOW SHOW FOR WORKPLACE
INVESTIGATION. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAT AND I THINK THAT'S
DIRECTED TO- THE CVHS CORRECT
YES. AND THEN I HAVE A FOLLOW
UP FOR COLLISION YOU WANT TO
START ON THE TESTING ISSUES AND
THEN I CAN FOLLOW UP ON CONTACT
TRACING. SURE YEAH. SO I THINK
THE FIRST QUESTION WAS IN
REGARDS TO- ACCESS TO TESTING.
AND I. BASICALLY I COUPLE OF
WAYS FOR ACCESSING TESTING
FIRST AND I THINK YOU ALSO
ASKED ABOUT SURVEILLANCE
TESTING SO. IN REGARDS TO THE
STRATEGIC PLAN THAT WERE BURDEN
NEAR FINALIZING IT. BOOKS THAT
ARE VARIOUS WORKER COHORTS IN
IN HOUSE. LOOKS AT. WHERE IT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR AND I'M GOING
SCREENING. I'M TESTING WHICH
SHOULD BE WHERE YOU'RE TESTING
TO LOOK FOR. INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE POSITIVE BY A SYMPTOMATIC-
RESPONSE TESTING WHEN THERE'S
AN INDIVIDUAL IDENTIFIED WHOSE
POSITIVE TO THEN. RESPOND TO
THAT ADDITIONAL TESTING- AND- I.
SURVEILLANCE TESTING AS A WHOLE
ISN'T JUST LOOKING TO SEE WHAT
SORT OF THE OVERALL POSITIVITY
RATE IN A GIVEN. POPULATIONS TO
HELP MAKE PLANS FOR. BOARD
TESTING IN THE FUTURE. THE
STRATEGIC PLAN IS LOOKING
PREDOMINANTLY AT. SCREENING
TESTING IN RESPONSE TESTING. D.
AS FAR AS TESTING ACCESS
AMINATION OF THINGS I KNOW
YOU'RE AWARE OF THE STATE RUN
TESTING SITES CURRENTLY I'M
OVER A HUNDRED I EIGHTY TO
EIGHTY FIVE OPTUM SERVES SITE
AND ARE. SIXTEEN SIXTEEN SIX
WELL BY ALL OF THE SITES WHERE
WORKERS CAN GO AND GET TESTED
THEIR NECKS AND SOME NOT SO
THAT SOMEONE'S AT A WORKPLACE
YOU'RE ACTUALLY SAYING GOES
SOMEWHERE ELSE THEY WON'T GET
TESTING ON SITE BUT STILL. PART
OF WHAT WE'RE WORKING ON AS
WELL- WHAT'S BEING REVIEWED
RIGHT NOW- R. D. I REQUEST FOR
INNOVATION. WE'RE IN THE FINAL
PHASE OF REVIEW OF THAT. TODAY
AND THROUGHOUT THIS WEEK AND
THOSE ARE LOOKING OUT MORE I'M
CREATIVELY USE WHERE. THERE MAY
BE. SOME OPTIONS FOR A MOLE BY
TEAMS OR UNITS I'M TERRY GO TO.
VARIOUS LOCATIONS ARE
POTENTIALLY INCLUDING WORKER
LOCATIONS OR TEAM. COULD GO OUT
AND TEST. A WORKER AND WE'RE
LOOKING FOR CREATIVE WAYS
INDUSTRY WE'RE ALSO AT IT
REALLY. HOME SO THAT FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO DON'T WANT TO
COME OUT TO BE TESTING LOCATION
THEY COULD ACCESS TESTING AT
HOME. THOSE IN COMBINATION WITH
THE STATE LAB THAT'S SCHEDULED
TO OPEN I THINK WILL OPEN
ACCESS TO TESTING. IN ADDITION
TO THAT WE'RE- THIS WEEK
RECEIVING THE- BY NOW NOW
IMAGINE TEST AND ARE
ANTICIPATING- GETTING
RELATIVELY REGULAR HI
ALLOTMENTS OF THOSE TESTS AND-
THOSE TESTS ARE BEING GIVEN TO
STATES BASED ON A PER CAPITA
BASIS A HUNDRED MILLION- SPLIT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY SO
CALIFORNIANS ANTICIPATING ABOUT
TEN MILLION OF THOSE- AND THOSE
WILL. BE CENTER COUNTY IS BASED
ON. POPULATION IN CASE RATE
INITIALLY- AND THEN AFTER THE
FIRST ROUND OF THOSE TESTS GO
OUT THEN WE'LL ADD THE EQUITY
METRICS WE TRIED TO ADD THE
EQUITY METRIC INITIALLY BUT IT
MEANT THAT. WHEN WE ADDED THAT
THAT SOME COUNTIES WOULD END UP
WITH NO TESTS THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE. YEAH RIGHT. THE
START THAT OUR ON COUNTIES IT'S
OF THESE IMAGES TEST AND THEN
THE SUBS SUBSEQUENT ROUND OF
ONE. EQUITY HAS. AND THOSE
TESTER BEST YOU FIRST.
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN A WEEK OF
SYMPTOM ONSET SO FOR THOSE.
WORKERS WHO ARE SYMPTOMATIC I'M-
THE IMAGE TEST ALSO BE A GOOD
TEST FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
OKAY LINDUP ARE WORKPLACE SO
THAT OUR WORKPLACES OBLIGATED
TO REPORT RESULTS OF TESTS
THEY'RE DONE RELATED TO THE
WORK PLACE. I THINK BARBARA CAN
YOU ANSWER THAT QUESTION. YEAH
SO CURRENT. CURRENTLY WORK
PLACES ARE NOT REQUIRED WITH
VERY FEW EXCEPTIONS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO DO ONGOING
SCREENING OF WORKERS RUN
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES ARE
WE ARE STARTING TO LOOK AT
OTHER HEALTH FACILITIES TO
IMPLEMENT THAT KIND OF
SCREENING. BUT WHEN PCR TESTS
ARE DONE THERE THEY HAVE TO
HAVE TO BE ANALYZED BY
LABORATORY AND THOSE
LABORATORIES ARE REQUIRED TO
REPORT TO THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT IT MIGHT BUT I GUESS
THE QUESTION I HAVE AND IT'S
GOING TO GET A CLEAR ANSWER IS
THAT. CURRENTLY YES IF YOU HAVE
A TESTING GOES TO A LAB THE LAB
IS RECORD REQUIRED TO TAP TO
REPORT THAT THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT BUT ALSO HEARING
THINGS LIKE ANTIGEN TESTING
THERE'S OTHER TYPES OF TESTING
MODALITIES THAT. MAY NOT
NECESSARILY MEAN YOU HAVE SENT
TO A LAB YOU CAN JUST SORT OF
DO IT RIGHT THERE WITH THE
CHECK. AND SO I JUST WANT TO
KNOW THAT IF THE WORKPLACE USES
TO DO THAT AND I'M NOT SURE THE
ENGINE TEST YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE MIGHT DISTRIBUTE. IF ARE
THOSE RESULTS ALSO MANDATED TO
BE REPORTED TO THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT SO THEY KNOW WHEN
SOMEONE'S POSITIVE. YES THE
CARD TO THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT INTO CAL RANDY .COM
THANK YOU THAT'S RIGHT AND THEN
WE CAN NOW MOVE ON TO CONTACT
TRACING CAPACITY. SURE SO LET
ME JUST EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HOW ABOUT HOW IT WORKS IT
BEGAN WORKS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WHEN A POSITIVE CASES REPORTED
TO A LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
THEY HAVE THEIR TEAMS IN PLACE
TO DO CONTACT TRACING. THE
STATE IS SUPPLEMENTING THAT
I'VE HEARD A LOT WE HAVE A
LARGE NUMBER OF C. T. PAY TO
FORTIES WHO HAVE BEEN DETAILED
TO WORK FOR COUNTIES ACROSS THE
STATE TO HELP SUPPORT THEIR
CONTACT TRACING EFFORTS- BUT-
ARENA LIKELY AND THAT'S A GOOD
THING APPRECIATE THAT. ARE YOU
AND I REALIZE IT IS THE ROLE OF
THE LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT TO
DO MOST OF THAT ARE WE TRACKING
HOW YOU KNOW HOW OFTEN THEY'RE
ABLE TO DO CONTACT TRACING
EIGHT SO I APPRECIATE OF GUNS
AND INFORMATION RIGHT NOW WE
CAN BY CONTRACTORS NINETY
PERCENT. BUT SPECIFICALLY FOR
WORKPLACE OUTBREAKS ARE OR WERE
AGENCY OUTBREAKS BUT FOR PART
OF THE CASES THAT MAY AFFECT
THE WORKPLACE IS THERE- ARE WE
HITTING. A 100% INCOME. ASING
ONES THAT AFFECT WORK PLACES.
LIKE ALL RIGHT THAT'S WHAT I
WANT TO KNOW LIKE ARE WE
TRACKING THAT. I CAN'T ANSWER
THAT AND I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
GET MORE INFORMATION ON TO GET
BACK TO YOU ON THAT- ONCE IT
BECOMES AN OUTBREAK I HAVE TO
SAY AGAIN THAT THERE'S SORT OF
SHARED RESPONSIBILITIES BETWEEN
THE EMPLOYER AND THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT- SOMETIMES
THEY THEY- THE EMPLOYER HAS A
CAPACITY LIKE FOR A LARGE
EMPLOYER WITH THE HAVE
OCCUPATIONAL MEDICINE EXPERTISE
THEY CAN TAKE ON THE CONTACT
TRACING PART OF THIS- AND THEN
THAT ALL LEADS INTO WHO ELSE
NEEDS TO BE TESTED AND FOLLOWED
UP SO SOME OF THAT
pRESPONSIBILITY CAN BE BORNE BY
EMPLOYERS THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT IS THERE TO ENSURE
THAT IT'S- STILL BEING. YOU
KNOW CARRIED OUT PROPERLY THERE
SHOULD BE A PARTNERSHIP THERE
AND THAT'S ALL PART OF WHAT OUR
GUIDANCE ON WORKPLACE FOLLOW UP.
I SAID BE HELPFUL IN YA
PRECIADO THE FOLLOW UP IS
GETTING THAT IN. HEALTH STATUS
TRACKING- CONTACT TRACING- IN
TERMS OF AND I KNOW YOUR PRIDE
TALKING MORE HEALTH FACILITIES
WHICH HAVE THAT CAPACITY BUT
I'M ALSO CONCERNED YOU KNOW NOT
HEALTH FACILITIES. AND THEN
FINALLY MY THIRD PART OF THE
QUESTION AS I SAID EARLIER. A
WHAT POINT DOES THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS YOU'RE
GETTING THESE POSITIVES AND YOU
DURING THE CONTACT A SENIOR
REALIZING THAT IT'S NOT
AFFECTING WORKPLACES. THE WHAT
POINT DO YOU CONTACT A CALLOW
SHOWS THAT THEY KNOW. THAT HEY
YOU KNOW WHAT WHERE DID CONTACT
FACING NOW. WITH SOME OF THE
PEOPLE CONTACT TREES. THERE AT
THESE WORKPLACES AND WE NOW
NEED CAL OSHA TO GO IN AND TAKE
A LOOK AND SEE WHAT'S GOING ON
THERE. SO YOU KNOW EARLY ON IN
THE PANDEMIC WHEN WE FIRST
STARTED WORKING WITH LOCAL
DEPARTMENTS GIVING THEM
SUPPORT. IN OUTBREAK
SITUATIONS- A LOT OF THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. YOU KNOW
MAY NOT BE SO USED TO
INTERACTING WITH KELLER CHAU
AND MAKING REFERRALS LIKE THAT
WE HAVE TRIED TO IN THE
OUTBREAKS WERE WE SUPPORTED
THEM BRING TOGETHER ALL OF THE
AGENCIES INCLUDING CAL OSHA-
COURT. IS PRESENT TO THEM THAT
AN OPTION ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE
NOT GETTING COOPERATION FROM
THE EMPLOYER ON HOW TO FOLLOW
UP THE OUTBREAK APPROPRIATELY.
ON SCENE HELP THEM MAKE A REFER
TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO MAKE A
REFERRAL OR IN SOME CASES WHAT
WE DO WE CAN DO IT AS WELL SO
THAT IS SOMETHING WE'RE YOU
KNOW SUPPORTING. THOSE LOCAL
ENTITIES TO MAKE THAT DECISION
ABOUT- AND I THINK WITH AB SIX
EIGHTY FIVE IN PLACE WHERE. YOU
KNOW PART OF THE PART OF THE
INTENT BEHIND THAT IS TO HAVE
MORE COOPERATION AND MORE
TRANSPARENCY- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
THE OBLIGATION TO POST ON OUR
WEBSITE WHERE THESE OUTBREAKS
ARE ARE. ARE GOING TO BE OUR
WILL BE OCCURRING ON I THINK
THE INTENT THERE IS TO HAVE US
WORK EVEN MORE CLOSELY BETWEEN
CITY PAGE COLORS AND LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. TO TRY TO
ENSURE THAT THESE OUTBREAKS ARE
BEING JUMPED ON FASTER I THINK
THAT'S- PART OF THE INTENT TO.
THANK YOU. TO ALL TO LEARN AND
DO BETTER WITH THIS THAT'S GOOD
TO HEAR I HOPE THE STATE WILL
MONITOR. EACH LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT WHILE I HAVE A LOT
OF FAITH IN OUR COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICERS. UNFORTUNATELY SEEN IF
YOU RESIGN BECAUSE OF POLITICAL
PRESSURE SO WE NEED TO TRACK TO
BE SURE ARE COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS HAVE THE FREEDOM TO
DO THIS. AND THAT WHEN THEY
MAKE REFERRALS THAT THEY DON'T
GET INTO TROUBLE BUT THE LOCAL
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS- SO THAT'S
SOMETHING AGAIN TO MONITORING
FUNCTION SO I REALIZE THAT THE
ACTUAL ACTIVITIES TAKES PLACE
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL BUT THE
STATE DOES NEED TO MONITOR.
ENSURE THAT THIS IS HAPPENING I
THINK THIS IS CRITICAL TO BE
SURE THAT WE GET THAT.
INFORMATION TO CALLOSUM ACCOUNT
OSHA CAN ACT AS WELL NOW MY
QUESTION IS FOR CAL OSHA AND
AGAIN APPRECIATE THOSE ANSWERS.
SO THE DATA HIGH HAVE HERE FROM
THE BACKGROUND PAPER ACTUALLY
ENCOMPASSES FAVORITE FIRST TO
SEPTEMBER TWENTY SEVEN SO YOU
MAY HAVE TO COMMENT WHAT'S
HAPPENING MORE RECENTLY VERSUS
WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN EARLIER ON.
THE PANDEMICS BUT- I WOULD NOTE
THAT- IN THIS REPORT THAT.
THERE WERE ALMOST SEVEN
THOUSAND CODE RELATED
COMPLAINTS HOWEVER ONLY. ELEVEN
HUNDRED SO ABOUT ONE IN SIX
WERE ACTUALLY ON SITE
INSPECTIONS SO THE REST OF
THEM. THE OTHER FIVE SIX WERE
NOT AND AGAIN I DON'T KNOW THE
DETAILS ARE EACH ONE. I WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT OF THOSE ONSITE
INSPECTIONS- YOU KNOW YOU HAD.
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED ALMOST FOUR
HUNDRED WERE EITHER FATALITY
INVESTIGATIONS AND SOMEONE
DIED. FOR ILLNESS SIGNS ON RY
GOT SICK IN FACT THAT NUMBER IS
LARGER COMBINED THEN THE NUMBER
OF COMPLAINTS THAT WERE FILED
SO I THINK IT GOES BACK TO WHAT
WE HEARD FROM THE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. HE SAID YOU KNOW
COMPLAINING IS DANGEROUS IN
ITSELF SO YOU YOU GOT TO
DANGERS YOU GOT I COMPLAIN I
GET FIRED. I GET SECOND OR DIE
RIGHT- I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
THE REFERRAL BASED INSPECTIONS
IS FAIRLY SMALL SO I THINK WE
HAVE MORE WORK TO DO IN TERMS
OF REFERRALS- PERHAPS- CAL OSHA
CAN- CAN YOU JUST COMMENT. ON
PARTICULAR WHAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING MORE RECENTLY SO I
WOULD SAY THAT THE NUMBER OF ON
SITE INSPECTIONS IN RELATION TO
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF CODE OR
PLAY IT SEEMS TO BE VERY FEES
YOU KNOW. ONE IN SIX SEEMS TO
BE A FAIRLY SMALL PERCENTAGE.
IS THAT PERCENTAGE REFLECTIVE
OF WHAT'S CURRENTLY HAPPENING
OR IS THAT MUCH HIGHER NOW THAN
IT WAS IT PERHAPS AT THE
BEGINNING THE PANDEMIC. AND
THEN ALSO- HOPEFULLY- WE ARE-
YOU KNOW THE NUMBER OF TARGET
CELLS AND THEN PERHAPS TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. WHAT'S
TRIGGERING THESE AND THAT SORT
OF THE FALL TO MY QUESTION THE
C. P. H. THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN TALISA AND- HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS FROM. YOUR
PERSPECTIVE IN TERMS OF GETTING
REFERRALS. EIGHT THANK YOU
DOCTOR. AND I THAT IS TO
DIRECTOR HAGEN OR CHIEF PARKER.
YES THANK YOU YES- GOOD DR
GRANT HELLO- THE. THE ELEVEN
HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR- WHICH IS
THE NUMBER I HAVE IN FRONT OF
ME THE WHICH MAY BE A WITH NO
MORE THAN WHAT YOU HAVE A
NUMBER OF- COBIT NINETEEN
INSPECTIONS THAT WE'VE DONE
RELATES TO- YOU KNOW ALL
CATEGORIES OF INSPECTIONS-
WHETHER IT'S FROM A COMPLAINT
WHETHER IT'S FROM DUE TO A
FATALITY ARRANGED FOR ILLNESS-
AND SO- THE NUMBER OF.
COMPLAINTS WERE COMPLAINTS THAT
HAVE RESULTED AN ON SITE
INSPECTION IS ACTUALLY. LOWER
THAN OUR YOU KNOW I'M A HIGHER
RATIO FEWER- THAN TO HELP THEM
THE WANTED SIX THAT YOU
MENTION- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE ARE. DID AT THEY ARE OUTSIDE
OF THIS- IN PREPARATION FOR
WHAT WE EXPECTED TO BE AN
ONSLAUGHT OF COMPLAINTS WOULD
BE TO SET UP A TRIAGE SYSTEM
WHERE WE INITIALLY RESPONSIBLE
TO COMPLAINTS WITH- NONE EXCEPT
IN THE MOST SERIOUS CASES- WITH
LETTER INVESTIGATIONS WHICH
MEANS THAT WE SENT A LETTER TO
THE EMPLOYER TO GATHER EVIDENCE
TO GATHER INFORMATION TO GET
THEIR RESPONSE AND THEN WHICH
WE USE THAT AS A AS A SOURCE OF
INFORMATION A TRIGE AND THEN
WE MAKE A DECISION ABOUT
WHETHER THE- WHETHER THE
RESPONSE IS SATISFACTORY WE TRY
TO. CONFIRM THAT WITH THE
WORKER IF WORKERS MADE A
COMPLAINT AND IDENTIFY. A HER
OR HIMSELF. AND THEN YOU KNOW
PROCEED ON THAT BASIS. THAT
WE'VE- YOU KNOW WE'VE RESOLVED
ABOUT FOUR OR MORE THAN FOUR
THOUSAND OF THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS THREE OF A-
LETTER INSPECTION PROCESS- WE
SENT MORE LETTERS AND THEN A
NUMBER OF OTHER ARM CANDY- YEAH
THIS WAS A STRATEGY THAT WE-
TRANSFER KIND OF BECAUSE WE
KNEW THAT WE WERE GONNA GET A-
YOU KNOW. IT'S ACTUALLY HAVE A
HIGH NUMBER OF FATALITIES AND
ILLNESSES THAT WE WERE GOING TO
HAVE TO INVESTIGATE- WHICH ARE
MANDATED BY. THERE'S
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE THERE AND-
YEAH AND- WE- THOUGHT THAT THE
USE OF THESE LETTER INSPECTIONS
WERE NOT AS EFFECTIVE AS AN IN
PERSON INSPECTION. WAS GONNA
ALLOW US TO TRIAGE AND THEN
REACHED OF MOST WORKERS THAT WE
POSSIBLY COULD BECAUSE WE KNEW
THAT IF WE DID COMPLAINTS IN
THESE- CASES ARE YOU KNOW WE
SIMPLY WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
RESPOND TO A- LOTS OF. MOST OF
THE MOST OF THEIR COMPLAINTS
AND SO THIS WAS A WAY OF
MAXIMIZING OUR REACH- IT'S NOT
A NEW PROCEDURE WE'VE BEEN
DOING. LETTER INSPECTIONS FOR
YEARS. WE ACTUALLY DO- FEWER
LETTER INSPECTIONS AND FEDERAL
OSHA AS A PERCENTAGE OF THOSE
THAT WE- WHERE WE USE THAT
PROCESS. SO I THINK THAT SOME.
TELL TO MAYBE I CAN JUST FOLLOW
UP YEAH YOU'RE A BRIEFLY- AND
YET I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU HAVE
LIMITED RESOURCES AND WE HAD
THAT WE'VE HAD SOME
CONVERSATION ABOUT RESOURCES.
YOU DO A LETTER INSPECTION
AGAIN WE I THINK YOU'VE HEARD
FROM PEOPLE ABOUT THE TIME
SENSITIVE NATURE THIS IS A
CONTAGIOUS DISEASE IT'S
SPREADING EXPONENTIALLY- HELLO
WHEN YOU ASK WHEN YOU DO IT. I
GUESS A LETTER INVESTIGATION RE
SEND THE LETTER SAID PLEASE
RESPOND EXPLAINS THE FROM THE
EMPLOYER WHAT'S THE TIME FRAME
IN WHICH YOU GIVE THE EMPLOYER
TO RESPOND AND THEN HOW DO YOU
CONFIRM THAT THOSE RESPONSES
ARE ACCURATE. SO WHAT'S THE
TIME FRAME FOR BOTH THE
REQUIREMENT FOR THE EMPLOYER TO
RESPOND. AND ALSO YOUR
VERIFICATION PROCESS. FOR IT IN
A LETTER TO- INVESTIGATION.
THAT THAT- WITHOUT WHAT'S BEEN
REPLIED TO IS A- I GUESS IS A-
CONCURRENT WITH THE WHAT I
NEEDED AT WORKPLACE. SO WE GIVE
THE EMPLOYER- US THREE DAYS TO
RESPOND FOR A SERIOUS VIOLATION
AND WE GET FOURTEEN DAYS FOR A
GENERAL ARE LESS SERIOUS
VIOLATION- AND THEN WE EVALUATE
THE EVIDENCE THERE'S TYPICALLY
A BACK AND FORTH PHONE CALL
PARTICULARLY FOR THE SERIOUS
VIOLATION. IF WE HAVE A- IF WE
HAVE A COMPLAINANT WHO IS NAMED
OFTEN THEIR ANONYMOUS THAT IF
WE HAVE A- YOU KNOW FORMAL
COMPLAINT FROM UNNAMED
COMPLAINANT- WE- OUR PROCEDURES
REQUIRE THAT THE INFORMATION BE
VERIFIED AND THEN THE- AND THEN-THE EMPLOYER IS REQUIRED TO.
POST BOTH OUR LETTER AND THEIR
RESPONSE IN THE WORKPLACE SO
THAT EMPLOYEES CAN VIEW- BOS
AND SO YOU KNOW THAT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET FOLLOW UP
COMPLAINTS FROM UP FOR WORKERS
YASUMI NAME CLERK COMPLIANCE
WITH THAT REQUIREMENT. IN IN
TERMS OF THE OVERALL TIMING
THAT PROCESS. TAKES ABOUT.
THIRTY TO FORTY DAYS IS AS
OPPOSED TO THE EIGHTY TO NINETY
DAYS FOR A TYPICAL INSPECTION
AND THE AND SEVENTY DAYS THAT.
IS TYPICAL FOR COMPLETION OF A
WITH NINETEEN INSPECTION. AND I
SHOULD SAY WHEN I SAY SEVENTY
DAYS SUMMER QUITE QUICK BECAUSE
THEY'RE PART OF SWEEPS. SUMMER
LONGER BECAUSE THEY INVOLVE
MORE COMPLEX WORKPLACES LIKE
HOSPITALS OR CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY. THIS IS WHY VARIATION
AFTER THAT'S THE AVERAGE OKAY
BLOOD PRESSURE YOUR ANSWERS I
THINK PERHAPS SAID I KNOW WE
HAVE LIMITED TIME HERE SO I'M
GONNA STOP HERE BUT- I WOULD
LIKE TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON
SOME MORE SPECIFICS ABOUT.
ABOUT ABOUT THIS AD EXACTLY
WHAT WE CAN TRY TO DO TOO. YEAH
EXPECTING THE AVAIL. OF AN
INSIGHT TESTING AND ALSO AGAIN
I DID CLOSE THE QUESTION BUT NO
WILL FOLLOW UP ON THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND CAL OSHA. BE
SURE THAT WE'RE WORKING
TOGETHER- TO I TRIED IT BOTH
INTENSIFIED BUT THEN ADDRESS
WORKPLACE. SAFETY WHEN IT COMES
TO COATED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CHEAPER PRINT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
QUESTION SENATOR PAN WE ALWAYS
APPRECIATE YOUR VALUABLE
BACKGROUND AND EXPERIENCE- AND
WE DO HAVE ONE OTHER QUESTION I
BELIEVE FROM ONE OF OUR
PANELISTS. ON THE SECOND PANEL-
REGISTERED NURSE AMY ARE
ARLAND. SO I CAN PASS IT ON TO
HER IF SHE'S STILL ON THE LINE.
TO ASK A QUESTION. YES I'M HERE
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU MAY
PROCEED GO RIGHT AHEAD. BEING
INVOLVED AND CALLUM CHAU
COMPLAINTS AND INVESTIGATIONS
AND MY OWN FACILITY I DO HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
TIMELINE. LATELY EVERY SINGLE
INTERACTION THAT WE HAVE HAD
WITH A COUCH INSPECTOR HAS BEEN
PRACTICED WITH THE SIX MONTH
RULE WE KEEP BEING REMINDED WE
HAVE SIX MONTHS TO MAKE A
CONCLUSION. WELL LET ME TELL
YOU OUR FIRST FATALITY HAPPENED
IN MAY THAT NURSE FILED A
COMPLAINT HERSELF IN APRIL
ABOUT WORKPLACE HAZARDS AND
EXPOSURES. WE HAVE HAD SEVERAL%
ENGINEERING CONTROL FAILURES
THAT WE HAVE RECORDED- AND THE
IDEA THAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE
SIX MONTHS TO DRAW A CONCLUSION
IN A HEALTH CARE FACILITY THE
SIZE OF MINE. ONLY MEANS THAT
PATIENTS ARE GOING TO BE AT
RISK AND I'M GONNA LOSE MORE CO
WORKERS- SO- AS FAR AS
PRACTICING EVERY INVESTIGATION
WITH THE SIX MONTH TIMELINE.
KIND OF SETS THE PACE
ESPECIALLY FOR THE HOSPITALS
AND THE PEOPLE THERE PROVIDING
YOU WITH THE INFORMATION THAT
THERE REALLY IS NO RUSH. THAT
THERE IS NO HURRY TO WRAP THIS
UP AND TO ACTUALLY FIND
SOMETHING WRONG I MEAN WE ARE
NOT AS NURSES SO MUCH CONCERNED
WITH THE MONETARY CITATIONS. AS
WE ARE FOR ACTUAL ENFORCEABLE
ACTIONS IN THE FACILITIES TO
IMPROVE. THE WORKPLACE SAFETY
ISSUES- STARTED LIKE YOU TO
PLEASE- IF YOU CAN ADDRESS THAT
SIX MONTH. WINDOW FOR ME. THANK
YOU AMY. AND I'M I. YES I KNOW
I ASKED A LITTLE BIT EARLIER
BUT IF WE CAN TOUCH ON THAT
SPECIFIC TO HER. COMMENTS THAT
WOULD BE GREAT SURE. YOU KNOW I
HAVE TO ADMIT THAT I'VE ON X. I
BEEN CAN THAT WELL- IT'S KIND
OF CONFLATION OF THIS ACTUALLY
LIMITATIONS WHICH IS THE LEGAL
TIME YOU HAVE TO ISSUE A
CITATION- AND THINKING OF IT AS
A AS. A PERFORMANCE DEADLINE
WHICH IS NOT NICE THEY'RE NOT
AS THE SAME THING- AND IT'S- AN
EIGHT AND EIGHT. IT CAN HAVE A-
IT IT CAN COME HOW TO PUT IT A
KIND OF. UNDERMINE THE URGENCY
OF THE SITUATION WITH IF THAT
IS THE MINDSET AND SO- I
CERTAINLY CAN I TAKE THAT
FEEDBACK BACK TO OUR STAFF
TOMORROW WHEN I MEET WITH A
DISTRICT MANAGERS AND JUST.
REMIND THEM OF THAT FACT. SOME
OF THESE- SOME OF THESE- YOU
KNOW INSPECTIONS ARE TAKING THE
TIME THEY DO BECAUSE IT'S A
REFLECTION OF. OF WORKLOAD BUT-
I DO STE I DO AGREE WITH YOU
THAT WHERE I. WORK INSPECTION
CAN JUST BE COMPLETED- YOU KNOW
IT IT NEEDS TO BE NEEDS TO BE
COMPLETED BY THE WORK STUFF.
RATHER THAN THINKING IN TERMS
OF THE SIX MONTH TIME FRAME.
THANK YOU CHIEF PARKRUN THANK
YOU AMY FOR THE QUESTION WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT- I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO CLOSE THIS SECTION
AND THEN WE WILL GET ON WE
WATCH TO TAKE A SHORT. BRIEF
PAUSE TO GET TO OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT BUT I THINK THERE WERE
A FEW THINGS THAT WE HEARD FROM
OUR MEMBERS AS WELL AS OUR WORK
FORCE- OF COURSE THE STATE LAB
COMING ONLINE IN NOVEMBER AND A
PRIORITY FOR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AND- JUST OUR ESSENTIAL
WORKERS TO BE PRIORITIZE FIRST.
SOMEHOW WITH A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND. NEW TESTS
COMING ONLINE EVERY SINGLE DAY
THERE'S NO REASON WHY WE ARE
AND SHOULD BE WAITING FOR. THAT
EVEN BEING TESTED AT THE
HOSPITAL SITE- AND THEN IN SOME
CASES WE DO HAVE A DOUBLE
CRISES AND THE CASE OF OUR
FARMWORKERS BOTH WILDFIRES AND
COVERT NINETEEN. SO PERHAPS
THERE COULD BE A REASSESSMENT
OF. THESE POTENTIAL OF THESE
WORKERS SPECIFICALLY AS THEY
ARE DEALING WITH- DUE TO THE
FARM WORKING THAT THEY DO
WITHIN THIS CONTEXT TO FIGHT
WILDFIRES AS WELL WHICH IS
UNFORTUNATE AND WE DID TALK
ABOUT A MORE PROACTIVE APPROACH
ESPECIALLY AS IT PERTAINS TO
THE INVESTIGATION PERIOD. AND
PERHAPS SHORTENING THAT. AS
WELL AS AS TO SENATOR PAN'S
POINT BETTER COORDINATION
BETWEEN LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH AND
CAL OSHA. SO WITH THAT I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU AGAIN TO OUR
PANELISTS WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
BRIEF PAUSE SO WE CAN GET TO A
PUBLIC COMMENT SECTION. THANK
YOU.
MODERATOR CAN YOU CHECK
PLEASE THE LINE ONCE AGAIN TO
BE SURE WE'VE EARD- I'M SORRY.
I'M SKIPPING AHEAD. SO AGAIN
WOULD LIKE TO INVITE THE PUBLIC
THE TOLL FREE NUMBER EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. THE ACCESS CODE. SEVEN
SIX TWO ONE TWO SEVEN NINE. THE
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE CHECK
TO SEE WHO IS ON THE LINE. YEAH
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW. AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW.
WE DO HAVE ABOUT NINE IN THE
QUEUE. OKAY WELL FIRST GOAL
TIMELINE SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS COUNTY
DELGADO ONE TWO THREE NURSES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING OVER
SIX THOUSAND NURSES FOR
CALIFORNIA I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION.
AND THE DISCUSSION OF WHAT
PRESENTED TODAY- JUST WANTED TO
SAY WITH THE ONSET OF THE CALL
THE PANDEMIC WE SOMETHING
CHALLENGES. TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS WE RECEIVE THAT
PRACTICES AND HEALTHCARE IN A
MISSION IS TO ADVANCE EXCELLENT
LOOK AT THE NURSES WANT YOUNGER
CALIFORNIA PENSION THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. BACK TO A TIME
FORTY FOUR WE'VE GOT. HI MY
NAME IS AN ESSENTIAL PART BACK
I NEED ORGAN WITH THE DOMESTIC
WORKERS HOLDING. WE HAD HE- IS
ON THE LINE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
GET MAN AND I'LL BE. WRITING
FOR. BEFORE THEY GET STARTED WE
JUST WANTED TO BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION AS MANY OF THEM
ARE WORKING CLEANING AND
MINIMIZE. READ AND THEY DO NEED
AND ALSO CARING FOR THOSE
VULNERABLE DOING THE WORK MUCH
LIKE THAT AND HEALTH CARE
WORKERS. AND YET THERE HE DID
FROM CAL OSHA AND DO NOT HAVE
GREAT PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT OR INFORMATION ON
EXPOSURE. LIKE I MANY OF THE
OTHER. LOW WAGE IMMIGRANT
INDUSTRY WORKERS WHO SPOKE
EARLIER THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO CLEAN. DRINKING AND WE
REALLY THAT THAT THAT PREVENTED
IT THAT. TO PROTECT THE CAR
WORK WORKING. WE JUST HAD A
CANTEEN AND WE APPRECIATE ALL
THE SENATORS WHO SUPPORTED US
ALONG THE WAY BUT
UNFORTUNATELY. THE GOVERNOR HAS
VETOED HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROTECTIONS FOR THE INDUSTRY.
AND SO WE JUST WANT TO BE PART
OF THE POTENTIAL WORKER
CONVERSATION. AND I OUT AWAY
FROM TO. THE IMPACT OF THE
TANDEM IN OUR ENDED. IN THE
WORKER CARE AND WHICH EMPLOY.
AND YOU KNOW FINDING A WAY TO
IDENTIFY. THE THREE. SO WE'RE
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED. ADELANTE AT THE
BEGINNING HE'S JUST HELLO WE'RE
SORRY THE LINE MY NAME IS SIXTY
NOW BROWN FILIPINO ADVOCATES
FOR JUSTICE PLEASE ENTER
CALIFORNIA NINE BERKELEY ON A
GIVER FOR ALL I DON'T. I THINK
YOU WHAT CARPOOL CARE. WELL YOU
KNOW BOTH OF YOU SEE DURING THE
FINAL DALY. I HAVE THE- B. FOUR
THANK YOUNG UNDER ONLY YEAH. NO
I AM. TO ONE. HE HAD THE.
THOUSAND WE NEED TO BE A COMPLY
WE'LL- GET WORKERS AND GIVEN
YOU A REALLY REGARDING NOT.
THAT BE. DID YOU SEVENTY NINE.
RIGHT I THANK YOU THE WRONG
DECISION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CALL SIGNALED THINK YOU VERY
MUCH ANOTHER REMIND HAS ABOUT
ONE MINUTE TO TESTIFY IN SO
TAKE THE COMMENT. THE NEXT
LEVEL TO SAID FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI AM THIS IS. MCGANN
AND I'M READY TO COME MOMENTO
WITH THE INSURANCE. SORRY ABOUT
THAT. AND WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
DOMESTIC WORKERS ON THIS ONE
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO DO
INTERPRETATION SO I WANTED TO
AND INVITE COCOA THE END TO
SPEAK WE HAVE- WILL HAVE SEVEN
DOMESTIC WORKERS SPEAK ON THE
SAME LINE- BECAUSE ARE ALSO
ENABLING TECHNOLOGY ACCESS AS
WELL AND MANY DO NEED AND
TRANSLATION. SO GO AHEAD SO
CALDERON. RIGHT AND I THINK.
NUMBER HELLO. ELEVEN I TODAY
SEVEN HUNDRED O'CLOCK. YEAH PET
DANDER. BUT THEN. I'M NOT THAT
I'M NOT THE ONE REMEDY ABLE
HAVE A THE LOCAL LEVEL WILL NOT
INDEPENDENT TABLE ANOTHER OF IT
HAVE A LOOK AT THAT AND THEN AT
THE I LOST THE PLANET I'M NOT
ELECTED I'M NOT CONNECTED TO
THE BALLOT BOX A AND. AND THEN
WE CAN GO AHEAD ON TO THE NEXT-
YES DOMESTIC WORKER THANK YOU.
I MEAN WE'VE GOT. YES YOU CAN
GO AHEAD. HELLO WE MAY HAVE
LOST THEM YET EIGHT OUT GO HEAD.
YEAH WE WERE HERE OKAY GOOD YOU
CAN GO AHEAD AND PROCEED. RIGHT
PHOTO IS FROM ONLINE OF THE
GREEN DAY LABOR CENTER AND
SHE'S BEEN WORKING AS A
DOMESTIC WORKER FOR NUMBER OF
YEARS CLEANING HOMES AND SHE
SAID THAT WE ARE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS THAT CONTINUE TO WORK
DURING THE PANDEMIC I WANTED TO
KEEP MY CALM BRIEF BUT WE- BEEN
FROM PROTECTION BUT THE FACT
THAT OUR HOUSE THE GOVERNOR HAS
VETOED THE POSSIBILITY OF
PROTECTION UNDER ACCOUNT OSHA.
BUT WE NEED. CAPTION AS
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. TODAY WE
HEARD A THEIR- THAT EXIST IN
OTHER. AND IT'S NOT FOR US. AS
WELL TO BE ABLE TO COUNT ON
THIS TYPE OF PROTECTION. I'M
WHAT. I'M WE BELIEVE THAT WHAT
GOVERNOR WOULD LIKE YOU DO WHEN
YOUR MICROPHONE YOU CAN PRESS
STAR SIX TO ONE. CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY
AND- SHE ADDED THAT I'M
DOMESTIC WORKERS ARE NOT SECOND
CLASS WORKERS AND MADE HIS
THURMOND PROTECTION JUST LIKE
ANY OTHER WORKER AND NOTHING
LESS. I WILL GO AHEAD WE'RE
HAVING SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES ON THE FINE BUT
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND BELIEVE BY
FACTOR DAILY HEARTBURN YES AND
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY MORE WE
HAVE LEFT ON THIS PARTICULAR
LINE I KNOW WE HAVE ANOTHER A
FEW FOLKS WAITING ON THE LINE
AS WELL SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND-
BUT A FEW MORE. AT DOMESTIC
WORKERS BEGIN THANK YOU YEAH.
AT LEAST WE DON'T HAVE. I LOVE
RIDING MY OF THE YOU KNOW WHAT.
MY BUT THE- THANK YOU LOVE YOU
KNOW IN THIS MOMENT I AM IN
LADY BY IT BOB NOT GET YOUR AND
BECOME EMAIL. WHAT NOW BUT. I
DO NOT DOUBT. IT BUT YOU CAN
THE OF THE JOURNEY. IN ORDER TO
BE MADE AND THAT. WHAT IT IS A
PARTNER AT THE END OF THAT
FIGHT THAT. I FELT THAT IT WAS
AT THE END. I NOT BE WORKING
AND THEN THE DOCTOR RIGHT AND
NOW. ABOUT THIRTY FIVE BUT I
THINK YOU VERY MUCH IT HAS TO.
I LIKED. THANK YOU ALONG WITH
THAT WHAT THEY THE MOMENT YOU
BYE BE THINKING MORGAN TO HAVE
TO MOVE ON TO THE TEST BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. CONNECT TO
A LOT TO FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI BEING ON BEHALF OF THE K.
MATT ASSOCIATION. WORKSAFE
WORKPLACES AND RE OPENING
CALIFORNIA SAFELY TOUCH RESULTS
MUST CONTINUE TO BE TIMELY WITH
ADEQUATE TESTING CAPACITY
AVAILABLE IN PROVIDER OFFICES
CLINICS ARE MOBILE TESTING
LOCATIONS WITH ADEQUATE
SUPPLIES TO MINISTER THOUGH TAP.
THE TESTING MODEL MOVING A MORE
LONG TERM SOLUTION USING THE
EXISTING HEALTHCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE. MINISTER A
HIGHER VOLUME OF HAVE.
HEALTHCARE SETTING WILL
PARTICIPATE AND SHOULD HAVE THE
MATERIALS THEY NEED. THIS
INCLUDES THE CAPTAIN CARE THE
PP NEEDED TO ADMINISTER EACH
TAB. AND TIMELY PATIENT RESULTS
REPORTED BACK TO PROVIDERS.
EMAIL WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE CAN TAKE THE
NECESSARY STEPS. TO ENSURE THE
SUPPLY CHAIN OF PPP AND PARKING
PROVIDE ADEQUATE AND RESILIENT
TO SUPPORT SAFE WORKPLACES AND
I THINK CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
THAT TIELINE NINE PEOPLE HAVE.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DEBORAH ABOUT THE OF ALLEN I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF LAW
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
COULD SERVE CLOSE 210% OF
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR SCHOOLS TO BE
CONSIDERED IN THE BROADER STATE
LEVEL DISCUSSIONS RELATED TO
CALL THE NINETEEN RESPOND. OUR
COMMITMENT OF ENSURING PUBLIC
SCHOOLS ARE ABLE TO RESUME IN
PERSON CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION AS
SOON AS THE DATE. COULD DO SO.
AS WE CONTINUE TO PLAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS NEED TO STATE THE
COURT INTO SPECIFIC WAIT. FIRST
WE NEED ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
COVERT NINETEEN RESPOND. WATER
OVER OCTOBER NINETEEN
EXPENDITURES ARE ESTIMATED AT
ONE POINT FOUR BILLION. TO JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED WILL SPEND MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
FOR FOOD. FOR THOUGH THEY NEED.
COMPUTERS AND INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY STUDENTS. AND
COVERT NINETEEN PACKING FOR ALL
IN SCHOOL. WE ALSO ASK YOU TO
TAKE IMMEDIATE LEGISLATIVE
ACTION BY PROVIDING DISTRICT
THE TEMPORARY LIMITED LIABILITY
PROTECTION FROM LAWSUITS THAT
MAY RESULT RECALL THE NINETEEN
INSPECTION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. OF THE URGENT
REQUEST. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN
FACT WE ARE NOW SUBSEQUENT FROM
THIS. OVERSIGHT HEARINGS. FROM
THIS COMMITTEE WILL BE ON JUST
THAT- EDUCATION AND DISTANCE
LEARNING SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS. NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. THANKS CAROLINE TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SENATOR GONZALEZ AND MEMBERS
THIS IS MITCH SNIDER WITH A
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
PUSH IT UP TO THE TESTIFIED WE
REALLY DO WANT TO COMMEND
CALLAS OF FOR ALL THE GOOD WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE SO FAR RELATED
TO. THE GUIDANCES THE NEW
STANDARD LIKELY COMING IN
NOVEMBER THE HOPEFULLY
STRENGTHEN THOSE GUIDANCES ANY
EFFORTS TO FIX THE STAFFING US
DESCRIBE ODAY'S SOUND REALLY
PROMISING. BUT I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
HOW FAR AT THIS AGENCY HAD TO
GO PART OF THE PANDEMIC FOR
EXAMPLE WITH THE STAFFING ISSUE
THAT 2225% VACANCY RATE HAS
PERSISTED FOR. AT LEAST A
DECADE THAT WE'VE BEEN
FOLLOWING THE ISSUE AND THAT
CAUSES A LOT OF DOWNSTREAM
EFFECTS THAT REALLY AND WITH
WORKERS BEING LESS SAFETY
INSPECTORS ARE TO RUSH TO
CONDUCT INSPECTIONS IT'S
ENCOURAGING AN OVER RELIANCE ON
LETTER INSPECTIONS AS COVER
TODAY THAT. ESSENTIALLY ALLOW
EMPLOYERS SECURE THE VIOLATION
M. IT'S REALLY HARD TO THINK OF
ANY OTHER LAW THAT WORKS THAT
WAY ESPECIALLY ONE THAT IS
THAT'S CLOSELY RELATED TO YOU
SO MANY ILLNESSES AND SO MUCH
DEATH AND SOMETHING THAT IS THE
SERIOUS. WE REALLY DO THINK
THAT THAT STAFFING ISSUE NEEDS
TO BE FIXED HOPEFULLY THE
CURRENT EFFORTS AS DESCRIBED
WILL BE EFFECTIVE- AND THAT
WHATEVER THE PROBLEMS THAT HAVE
BEEN OVER THE PREVIOUS YEARS
GET ADDRESSED BUT THERE'S ALSO
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT WE THINK
REALLY NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
NOT RELATED TO OUR CULTURE. WE
THINK NEEDS TO CHANGE WHERE WE
STRONGLY BELIEVE THIS AGENCY
EXISTS TO KEEP WORKERS SAFE
GOING EARLY AND NOT TO SAY HELP
SOME OF THE MOST DANGEROUS
EMPLOYERS AVOID PENALTIES WE
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING THE
COMPLIANCE ASSISTANCE PLEASE
SAYING THAT YOU'RE JUST ONE OF
THE CALIPHATE THAT MORE OF
THOSE IN PERSON VISITS IN JULY.
THANK YOU TO HAVE TO MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT AVAILABLE ARE REALLY
AT ALL SHE WANTED BY MANY TO WE
CLING THE BILL TO DO THINGS
THERE WHEN THEY HEAR WHAT IF
ANYTHING GIVEN HOW MANY WORKERS
ARE DYING WE THINK WE NEED TO
BE MORE STRICT THAN WE'VE EVER
BEEN AND REALLY HOPE THAT. THE
CALENDAR CAN FOCUS WE HEAR. YOU
LOUD AND CLEAR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THAT CAN. SAID ONE
PLEASED AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIRMAN HIS IS RON
SPEAKING ON THE OF THE FEDERAL
OF TEACHERS WHICH WERE A TWENTY
CERTIFICATE AND SCHOOL ON
ACROSS THE- WE'D LIKE TO
CERTAIN ABOUT HOW CURRENT
SCHOOL REOPENING GUIDELINE
NUMBER OUR CALL FOR A STATE
WIDE APPROACH THAT IS BY POLICY
CONSISTENT WITH THE BEST
SCIENTIFIC KNOWLEDGE AVAILABLE.
FOR THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
ALL OUR STUDENTS AND SCHOOL
STAFF HE BELIEVES THAT SCHOOLS
SHOULD NOT BE RE OPENED IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION UNTIL THE
ENTIRE STATE HAS REACHED
STRICTER BENCHMARKS AND
COLLEAGUES AND SHOULD SCHOOLS
BEGIN TO REOPEN WITH EXTREME
CAUTION SURE THOSE BECHMARKS
ARE LINED WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS GUIDANCE
ONE IS IN PERSON INSTRUCTION AT
SCHOOLS MUST BE PROHIBITED
UNTIL THE NUMBER OF NEW CASES
DECLINES FOR AT LEAST FOURTEEN
CONSECUTIVE DAYS. AND A SECOND
ONE IS THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
RESOURCES TO TASK TRACE AND
ISOLATE NEW CASES IN OUR
SCHOOLS MUST BE READILY
AVAILABLE- FOR BOTH SCHOOL
STAFF AND STUDENTS THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU AS WELL AND I
HAVE JUST BEEN TOLD THAT WE
HAVE FROM DEPT OUR NEXT-
OVERSIGHT HEARING OF AGAIN
OCTOBER TWENTY SEVENTH JOINTLY
WITH THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AT ONE PM SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THOSE DISCUSSIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
MATT TO SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
OUT. THIRTY XIN WE APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION TODAY AND JUST
WANT TO REMIND THE COMMITTEE
THAT TEACHERS AND SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ARE ALSO ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AND I HOPE MAYBE PART
OF THE CONVERSATION AROUND
WORKPLACE SAFETY EVERYONE WANT
KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL INCLUDING
TEACHERS ABBOTT ETA BELIEVES WE
MUST DO THAT BASICALLY. MANY
SCHOOLS ARE OPEN WE OPENING
WITHOUT THE BASIC SAFETY
PROTECTIONS AND HAD BEING
REQUIRED TO PREVENT THE SPREAD
OF CODE NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT I
DON'T RECOMMEND THAT TEACHERS
ARE TESTED EVERY TWO MONTHS.
ASSEMBLY NOT ADEQUATE OUR
SCHOOLS EDUCATE OVER SIX
MILLION STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
TOUCHING AN ESTIMATED EIGHTEEN
MILLION PEOPLE POLITICALLY AND
STUDENTS SHOULD BE PASSED AND
MUCH MORE FREQUENTLY TO PREVENT
THE SPREAD OF KOBE NINETEEN AND
THIRTY G. A. ASKED AND ANSWERED
LEVEL RESPOND TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE TESTING AND TREATING
AND OTHER SAFETY MEASURES IN
OUR SCHOOLS THANK YOU THANK YOU
AS WELL. NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
ACTOR OF THE LINE FOR SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FORTY
SEVEN YOU MAY BE NEEDED. HI
THIS IS STEVEN KNIGHT THANK-
WITH WORKSAFE I WANT TO THANK
JUERGENS SENATORS FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. KELLY SHE WAS
HARDLY THE ONLY GOVERNMENT
AGENCY UNDER PREPARED FOR THIS
NOVEL CONCURRENT A VIRUS. WITH
FULL RESPECT FOR THE
PROFESSIONALS HARD AT WORK AT
THE DEPARTMENT AND CALIBRATION
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY'S GOING
TO LOOK BACK ON THE FIRST EIGHT
MONTHS OF TWENTY TWENTY AND
HOLD IT UP. AS A MODEL FOR
PROTECTING WORKERS FROM THE
NEXT PANDEMIC. BUT FOR THE
WORKPLACE BOTH RECEIVING AND
GENERATING CASES SPREADING
INFECTIONS AND SENDING WORKERS
HOME TO THEIR FAMILIES AS WE
HEARD WITH POWERFUL WORKER
TESTIMONY ON THE PANEL. WE HAD
NO PUBLIC ENFORCEMENT FOR EIGHT
MONTHS NOW WE'VE SEEN A FEW
DOZEN CITATIONS IN RECENT
WEEKS- THIS IS IN RESPONSE TO A
GLOBAL TRANSMISSIBLE DISEASE
OUTBREAK THAT'S BEEN KNOWN-
FROM THE- VERY EARLY DAYS TO BE
HAVING AN OUTSIZED IMPACT. ON
OUR STAGE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
THE POWER ENFORCEMENT IN
CREATING COMPLIANCE IS VERY
WELL UNDERSTOOD. A SINGLE
WIDELY REPORTED CITATION EARLY
IN THE PANDEMIC. AND EMPLOYERS
TENSION ACROSS THE STATE AND
SAVED LIVES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ME TO BE HONEST ABOUT. HOW
IT SHOULD- OUR CONCERNS GO WELL
BEYOND THE PANDEMIC RESPONSE
WITH A WORKFORCE OF NEARLY
NINETEEN MILLION AND A MILLION
WORKFORCE PLACES KALLUS HAS A
HUNDRED NINETY THREE
INSPECTORS. AND THERE ARE MANY
VACANCIES DISCIPLINE TO
INSTANTLY WE'RE GOING. TO MOVE
ON TO TWITTER ACCORDING ON AND-
THANK YOU. MAXIMO LINE SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
SIXTY SEVEN YOU MAY BE NEEDED.
TWO OR MORE BONTA LINE EIGHTY
WHAT HAD. HI THIS IS CATCHY
BURKE WITH THE HELP OF THE
CERTIFICATION OF CALIFORNIA
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THIS HEARING AND THANK DR
PAMPER HIS QUESTIONS ARE ON
TESTING AND CONTACT TRACING
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
RECEIVED THOSE TEST RESULTS.
WAIT HELPED OFFICERS KEY TRACK
OF THE IN THEIR QUEUE IF THE
GROUP THE TRUCK SYSTEM.
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS IN LAB TO REPORT
TO THE LOCAL HELP SIR ANYTIME
THEY SEE ONE OF ABOUT NINETY
REPORTABLE DISEASES. UNTIL THE
NINETEEN IS ONE OF THOSE. THE
RECENTLY PASSED AB DICTATED BY.
GAMES HELP OUT THE THIRTY ONE
MORE TOOL TO USE WHEN THEY'RE
CREATING AN OUTBREAK BECAUSE
REQUIRES EMPLOYERS TO REPORT.
FINALLY WE RELY ON THE REPORTS
FROM LABS AND PHYSICIANS AND
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS THANK YOU
FOR CALLING ATTENTION TO THAT.
AND WE'RE ALWAYS HAPPY TO WORK
WITH ANY LEGISLATOR WHO HAS
QUESTIONS ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH
WE KNOW THAT THE VERY FROM
COUNTY TO COUNTY. THAT'S
BECAUSE PUBLIC HEALTH
FUNDAMENTALLY A LOCAL ACTIVITY
CONDITIONS CAN VARY GREATLY
FROM ONE JURISDICTION TO THE
NEXT IN TERMS OF DISAGREED
SPREAD AND LOCAL CONDITIONS.
WHICH IS WHY EACH COUNTY HAS
ITS OWN POSITION HEALTH OFFICER
AND THREE CITIES ALSO HAVE
THEIR- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
MODERATOR CAN YOU JUST REMIND
US HOW MANY MORE. LINES WE HAVE
OPEN. SURE WE FOR MORE IN THE
QUEUE. GREAT THANK YOU NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. MATAMATA LINE
EIGHTY ONE IF I HAD. I CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN HELLO. I
HAVE NOT TAKEN BACK ON THE LINE
HE IS GOING TO BE INTENTIONALLY
TRANSLATING FOR HIM THE NEW
YORK THAT COULD BE WHEN I GOT
OUT ON THE- FURTHER BUT BOTH.
THAT HAS NO MEDICAL. CARE YES
THEY ARE THEY'RE NOT. A LOT OF
BUT I THINK YOU HAVE A OPINION.
ALL THREE OF YOUR TOTAL ONE ON
THE CUIDADO THE STATE YOU TALK
AND. HERE'S A- SUMMARY OKAY.
PICKED UP FROM OR A COULD NOT
PARKER. YEAH PROTECTION ON THE
U. SO LONG. I GET ON THE MAY
ALSO LONG CONFIRMED ON THE U.
S. RUN THE NEWS. HELLO I'M JEFF
KAMAL. BECAUSE OF THE DIED
BURKE. THE MONEY FOR THE MUSEUM
BY LOCAL. MY LOOK AT ALL THE.
YEAH OKAY OPERATOR WILL CONTACT
AND. ALL CONTROL A LOT IN
APPEARS TO AND THINK YOU COULD
ACCESS HERE. OKAY I'M MY NAME
IS DAN WORKING I'M GONNA HAVE
THEM PREVIOUS WORKING AGAIN I
HOPE NOT HAPPENS TO ME I AND
REFORM FOR MAKING SURE I AM
SAFE. AGAIN I'D I'D TAKE CARE
OF MYSELF. REMOTE ONLINE EIGHTY
TWO VEHICLE I HAD. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
RUNNING VERTICAL HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. INFORMATION
PRESENTED TODAY WANTED TO SHARE
SOME BRIEF THOUGHTS ON A FEW OF
THE ISSUES RAISED. AS WE ALL
KNOW THE UNPRECEDENTED NATURE
OF THE NOVEL CORONAVIRUS
PRESENTING MANY UNFORESEEN
CHALLENGES. SALY AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC AND
WHILE GLOBAL SHORTAGES THE PP
CONTINUE TO PERSIST.
CALIFORNIA'S HOSPITALS HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO AVOID MORE DIRE
SHORTAGES BY SECURING PP.
THROUGH TRADITIONAL AND
NONTRADITIONAL MEANS TO PROTECT
OUR WORKERS AS WELL AS
UTILIZING CDC AND CDPH GUIDANCE
FOR CONSERVATION. TO BE CLEAR
PP YOU'RE STILL A LIMITED AND
SCARCE RESOURCE. WE TAKE VERY
SERIOUSLY PREVENTING THE
TRANSMISSION OF KOBE NINETEEN
IN OUR HOSPITALS. ALL INTERESTS
INCLUDING STAFF OR SCREEN FOR
FEVER AND SYMPTOMS PRIOR TO
ENTERING THE HOSPITAL. STAFF
MEMBERS HAVE AN EXPOSURE AND
ARE SHOWING SYMPTOMS HOSPITALS
PROVIDE TESTING. IT IS ALSO KEY
FOR. TRACING AS IT RELATES TO
STAFFING SHOULD NOTE THAT THE
WAIVER OF THE STATE'S NURSE
STAFFING RATIO REQUIREMENT HAS
BEEN AN IMPORTANT TOOL TO
PROVIDE RELIEF TO A STREAM
WORKFORCE- AND TO ALSO MEET
PATIENT CARE NEEDS. CURRENTLY
THESE WAIVERS ARE ONLY APPROVED
BY CDPH ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS. CAPPING THE SENATE RIGHT
BILLION WASTE IN THE HANDS OF
ON SITE CLINICAL PROFESSIONALS
ARE OPERATING IN UNPRECEDENTED
CONDITIONS FINALLY OUR
HOSPITALS. ARE DOING THEIR
ABSOLUTE BEST TO CONTINUE TO
LEAD THE FIGHT AGAINST
HEALTHCARE CARLYON NO WE
TOGETHER SHARE RESPONSIBILITY
IN DEFEATING. THIS CONDEMNING
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. MAXELL CAROLINE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE I HAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS YOU'RE
GETTING THE ERROR NUMBER
DIRECTOR OF THE MAINTENANCE
COOPERATION TRUST CONGRESS
STREET WIDE WATCHDOG GROUP THAT
WORKS TO ELIMINATE UNFAIR
BUSINESS PRACTICES IN
CALIFORNIA JANITORIAL INDUSTRY
ALL THE WORKERS THAT WE WORK
WITH OUR NON UNION JANITORS IN
ADDITION TO EDUCATING-
EMPLOYERS COMMUNITY HERE WE
WANT TO EXPRESS THE IMPORTANCE
OF ADOPTING SPECIFIC INDUSTRY
STANDARDS. BECAUSE WITHOUT THEM
IT HAS BEEN OUR EXPERIENCE ON
ENFORCEMENT SIDE THAT GOT LINES
OF CREDIT YOU NEED LAWS BUT WE
CAN HOLD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
KILLING OF TOWARDS YOUR NOT
FALLING ON CAMPBELL STREET
BECAUSE YOU HEARD. WITH NATURAL
NAY TESTIMONY. PART OF ACTUALLY
WITH R. OR- UNDERSTAND THERE'S
NO GOING THERE'S TRAINING. WILL
FINISH THE SURVEY OF TWO
JANITORS JUST A MONTH AND A
HALF AGO WHEN ONLY 45% OF THEM
HAVE RECEIVED TRAINING. ON THE
NEW MORE HARSH CHEMICALS THAT
ARE BEING USED TO HELP FIGHT.
SO WE NEED. STANDARDS THAT ARE
WRITTEN THAT WE CAN AFFORD TO
WE NEED WORKERS IS A PROTECTED
AGAINST RETALIATION SHOULD THE
SPEAK UP FOR THEIR LIVES IN A
CASE LIKE THIS. AND WE ALSO
NEED- DISINFECTING PROTOCOL.
THANK YOU CAN HAVE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T REQUIRE A PLAY CALLED ALL
STANDARDS AND EVEN I'M IN ARE
YOU READY FOR YOUR LEGALLY
RESPONSIBLE EMPLOYERS. TO HAVE
THE INSURANCE AT ALL SENATOR
PENNY YOU FOR YOUR CALL MAY NOT
ENTER YOUR MIND EVERYONE CAN
PULL YOUR ONE MINUTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR CLIENTS. THAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GO OUT AND
ECONOMIC. MIGHT HOMELESSNESS.
THANK YOU KNOW JUST. OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD IS ONE PER OR
TRY TO BE REALLY WITH THAT WE
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S COMMENTS
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. LET LOW MOTEL
NINE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE BY HAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS KIMBERLY
A LEADING OTHER DIRECTORS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S DOMESTIC WORKERS
COALITION WE STILL HAVE FIVE
MEMBERS THAT HAVE BEEN WAITING
FOR MANY HOURS A WEEK I WILL
HAND IT OVER TO OUR INTERPRETER
IN OUR MEMBERS. WE WILL ASK
THAT OF MANY LOTUS A CHALLENGE.
CLICK HERE TO YEAH A LITTLE BIT
OF A HUNDRED LOT OF PEOPLE TO
FLY YOUR- DON'T HAVE A LOT OF.
IT WILL BE A DOLLAR AND THEN
YEAH. IF YOU LOOK AT A LOT.
BETTER IT DURING MY BY LAUREN
FROM HE MAY NEED SHE. A FEDERAL
ABOUT NEWS. THE MORE YOU MORE A
MATTER FAMILY GALA WELL THAT
MIGHT BIT DON'T THINK TO GET A-
EARLY AND FUTURE. MEDIA EVEN AT
THAT LEVEL. THANK YOU COULD ASK.
ANY MINUTE HE GOT OUT OF IT I
KNOW NUMBER OF THE WOMEN
CALLING ABOUT IT'S AND THE CAL
DOMESTIC WE'RE BECAUSE. I'VE
BEEN WORKING THE ENTIRE. OF THE
CLEAN AND BECAUSE OF WE KNEW.
VETO WE DON'T HAVE THE- STILL
ANY KIND OF PROTECTIVE OF. AND
I HAVE TO CONTINUE WORKING MY
HEALTH EVERY DAY TO PROVIDE FOR
MYSELF AND MY FAMILY HERE AND
IN ALL OF THE DOOR. THIS IS
BRIAN. BIG AFFECT ON MY HEALTH
AND WE URGE LEGISLATORS AND
AGENCIES TO GET URGENCY. ACTING.
AT THANK YOU NECK COMMENT
PLEASE. HELLO ONE MOMENT FROM
THIRTY ONE BUT THE WEATHER GET
BACK WITH A ONE LEFT THE HOUSE
OF THE MORE. COUPLE ABOUT HOW
TO HELLO YOU COULD NOT GONNA
HAVE A LOT YEAH DEFINITELY
LOCAL HONDA. NOW THAT. A LOT OF
THE. START. SIX THE BILL ONLY
ONE THAT WE MUST HAVE A LOT NOT
SO MUCH MIGHT HAVE OR NOT. IT
WILL BE A RELATED AND MOST
VALUE THEY WILL THAT NOT YET.
RENDON REYES THAT EXIST FOR A
DURING THE TIME WE FACE DAY TO
DAY READ WORKING THE CAMERA. I
WERE JUST MANY THAT CLEAN
DURING THE- IT'S A MATTER OF
LIFE DEATH AND WE FEEL DID OF
THREE. THE WAY THAT ALL WORK
ARE THREE I'M WE ARE ONLY WHO.
WE'RE THINKING WORKERS AND WE
DID. EIGHT THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE A TO WORKER ONLINE. ONE IS
BETTER SHE MINIMALIST AND ON
FIVE THING IN ANYMORE YES YES
THE ONE IF I THOUGHT OF A LOT
OF MY ON. BECAUSE I MEAN WHAT
THE- WELL BEING THE UNITS IN
OTHER ABOUT COMMITTEE. WE HAVE
TO BE. WITH TWENTY YEAH
NOTEBOOK ON OF THE MOST BEGIN
OPEN UNIT BUT BECAUSE YES THE
THING IT'S WILL BE THE-
NOVEMBER WITH MY NOSE BUT WE.
THAT'S STEVENS OUT OF VITAL AND
THE NUMBER ONE HIT ME WITH THAT
FIVE AND IN THE THAT WE'RE FROM
THAN A LOT YEARS. I AM WORKERS
WERE CONTINUED TO WORK THE CAN.
IT MEANS THAT I BEEN. TO
COMPETE IN MY WORK AND I'M-
KNOW THE SENATE I NOT HAVE ANY
WORK THEY FOR. MEANING I AM
RIGHT MY LIFE I CAN. WORK I ASK
THAT YOU THE WORKER TO CLEAN
HOUSE. I DON'T. HELLO I HAVE
READ THE NUMBER THERE'S. MONEY
LTZ. FINALLY BEGIN. IN AND ALSO
FOR LIKE I'VE ALREADY HAD A FEW
OTHER CAN BE A SOUTHERNMOST YOU
TALKING IN A STEP ON THE- LEGAL
GIVE YOU SEE. ELECTRICAL
DOCUMENT IS A REMOTE. LET'S GO
TO LET'S GET A MOBILE MARC.
LOCAL DON'T FEEL THEY- THE THEY
CAN BE FOUND HERE YOUR IT THE
SIX WANT  MEAN. BERMAN TOLD
ONE THING MAKING BIG THEIR WILL
BE ABLE. TO ENTER BALL IN TO BE
ABLE TO FUNDING AND. YES MY
BROKEN BONES YOUR- OKAY WILL
OPERATE MILOS K. A. MARKETPLACE
OF COURSE IMPROVEMENT ACT THE
RESTING PLACE OKAY PHILIPPIANS
TO LOOK FOR YOUR- OKAY ACTUALLY
ACTUALLY. READ KINGDOM THINK
YOU'LL FIND A LOOKS LONG TERM
THIS ESTIMATES I'M PRETTY THING
EACH ME ME A SOME THE WAYS. I
AM PLEASED BY MONTH. I LOVE ON
THE ANYA DIRECTOR FOR THE
JOURNAL. HELLO I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THE TRANS ONLINE YOU
WANT TO GO AND TRY THAT. OKAY
I'M NOT SURE IF WE STILL HAVE
YOU ON THE LINE BUT- A
MODERATOR IT ARE THERE ANY MORE
OPEN LINES AT THIS POINT. I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE'RE
CAPTURING EVERYONE ON. SURE WE
DO HAVE ONE MORE LINE LOCAL
LINE SIXTY SEVEN I THINK I HAD.
YEAH ANALYSTS. SHE WOULDN'T
WHEN ASSEMBLY NOBODY'S HAPPY
GOT A LITTLE CIRCLES INDICATE
THE WORK ON THAT YOUR NINETY BE
ASSIGNING MANY FEATURE THEY J.
MUCILAGINOUS OCULIST GOOD LUCK
ON WHAT YOUR PRODUCT OF THE AND
I THOUGHT WELL WHO JUST THEY
WILL CONSIDER IT BOB HOPE I
WHAT I IN THE OFFICE OR NOT YOU
KNOW SPEAKING I'M ALSO NEWLY
ATTENDED TO YET UP OUR BATTLING
HIM FOR RESPECTED THEY IN ALL
GUNS UP ON EARLY DATA BEING IN
A LETTER NO NO SUNDERLAND AN
ARMY FOR THIS LITTLE EASIER
WILL BE THAT I DON'T HAVE WATER
IN JENNIFER MILD IN KOBE DID
YOU DON'T HAVE. FLORIDA
SOMEWHERE SO YOU WE'RE ON THE.
A ONE SEVEN FORTY AM ALTHOUGH
SOME OF THE LOS TO TWENTIETH
ARE YOU US OVER UP WITH A
LITTLE BIT WE NEED TO KNOW IF
THAT'S COMBINED YES CAN ASSIST
DONE NOT TECHNICAL YES THEY
KNOW SPEND ON THE LEFT AND LET
ME IN THOUSANDS OF IDEA BUT I
PROTECT OF THIS THE NAME ONLY A
IF IT A MODEL FOCUS WITH YEAH
WATER BEETLES ARE LOOKED UP ON.
GOT DIVORCED THOSE YOUNG
ILLUSTRATOR COMO JOKE KISS A
ESTIMATES THAT YOU GOT LOSE
THEIR IT USED BUT NOT FROM
EARLIER YET GIVE A BIT ABOUT
BACON THAT'LL AT HOW. PUBLIC
FOR THEIR COMMENTS- I APOLOGIZE
IF I'M CUTTING PEOPLE OFF I DO
APOLOGIZE I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE WE'RE FAIR WITH ONE MINUTE
BUT I WE REALLY APPRECIATE ALL
OF THE COMMENTS TODAY AND WE
THINK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
CALLED IN I ALSO JUST WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THERE AREN'T ANY-
PUBLIC COMMENTS FROM THE
GALLERY AND WE SEE NONE THERE-
SO AGAIN THANK YOU TO ALL THE
END OF IT INDIVIDUALS WHO
CALLED IN TO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ARVEST PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS. IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE SPECIAL COMMITTEE ON
PANDEMIC EMERGENCY RESPONSE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AND
AGAIN WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR THEIR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION- THROUGH THIS VERY
VERY- TRYING TIME WE WILL SEE
YOU. AGAIN THANK YOU.